[Musique]
Christophe Bruxet, bonsoir.
Bonsoir et merci de me recevoir.
Nous vous recevons ce soir pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Très bien. Donc Christophe Bruxet, 49
ans, marié, deux filles. Euh je suis
ingénieur agroalimentaire et j'ai fait
toute ma carrière donc dans différentes
entreprises agroalimentaires euh des
petites entreprises, des PME, des
multinationales.
Euh donc ça fait 25 ans que je suis dans
l'agroalimentaire. J'ai commencé par
être ingénieur projet. Ensuite, j'ai été
acheteur, tradeer, euh responsable achat
et directeur achat. Donc j'ai j'ai fait
toute ma carrière en gravissant les
échelons comme on fait chacun fait dans
chaque entreprise. Et j'ai commis un
premier livre en 2015 où j'ai raconté
mes expériences et où j'ai témoigné un
petit peu de ce que de ce qu'on a pu
faire dans les différentes entreprises
où j'ai travaillé et puis de ce que j'ai
pu voir par ailleurs. puis un second
livre en 2000 2018
donc dans lequel j'expliquéis un peu
plus en détail ce que j'avais pas pu
écrire dans le premier et je répondais
aux questions qu'on m'avait posé lorsque
j'avais fait des conférences ou par
courriers.
Et vous expliquez quoi dans vos bouquins
?
Bah en fait, si vous voulez,
bah au cours des des 20 et quelques
années que j'ai passé en France, il
s'est il s'est avéré que plusieurs fois
on a on a on a fait des choses qui nous
ont-mêmes professionnels de
gralimentaire relativement surpris voir
choqué. Et je me rappelle, on en parlait
par exemple avec mes collègues ou mes
assistantes et qui me disaient il
faudrait qu'un jour on en écrivait un
livre quoi. On ne croirait pas si on
racontait ce qu'on faisait ici. Et puis
bon, c'était resté comme ça dans dans un
coin de ma tête. Et puis un jour donc
j'ai eu l'opportunité de partir à
l'étranger pour travailler et c'est à
cette époque-là qu'il y a eu la le
scandale des lasagnes au cheval.
Et et il y avait eu exactement le même
le même scandale en 2001, c'était
l'affaire des lasagnes pardon l'affaire
des raviolis leader price qu'on avait
beaucoup reproché à Jean-Pierre Coffre.
Enfin, ça c'est une petite parenthèse.
Et à l'époque c'était à
son âme
p à son âme. Tout à fait et à l'époque
c'était passé comme une lettre à la
poste. C'était pas il y avait eu un
article dans le magazine Capitale et
puis finalement c'était c'était retombé
comme un soufflet. Alors que l'affaire
des des lasagnes au chevals, donc en
2000 2012-23 de mémoire avait eu un
scandale enfin ça avait fait un scandale
retentissant.
Et comme moi je viens de
l'agroalimentaire que je sais comment ça
fonctionne, que je sais comment ça se
passe, je m'attendais à ce qui est tout
un flow de révélation et puis qu'on
aille jusqu'au bout que qu'on ait un
petit peu des des choses intéressantes à
se mettre sous la dent.
Et j'étais vraiment frustré d'entendre
les représentants agroalimentaires qui
qui arrêtaient pas de dire bah écoutez
tout va bien, c'est sous contrôle et les
politique qui les couvrait en disant bah
non, il y a pas de scandale et puis
l'industrie agroalimentaire française
est la meilleure du monde et il y a rien
à voir. Et moi j'étais un peu dans mon
coin et je me disais c'est quand même
pas possible que quelqu'un ne ne enfin
ne lève pas un peu le voile sur ce qui
se passe vraiment. pas de manière à
dénoncer pour dénoncer, mais de manière
à ce qu'on puisse enfin faire le ménage,
améliorer les choses pour qu'il y ait
plus de scandale à l'avenir.
Alors, les scandales, c'est parce que il
y a il y a
du cheval qui se retrouve dans les
lasagnes parce que il y a un trader
derrière qui a qui s'est fait un peu le
blé, qui voulait marger à fond,
qui parce qu'il y avait derrière un
acheteur, derrière il y avait un client,
parce que tout ça.
Moi je vais vous poser une question très
simple parce que on a une communauté qui
est déjà un petit peu au courant de ce
qui se passe sur l'agroalimentaire et et
sur toutes les saloperies que qu'on
importe. qu'on vend,
qu'on fabrique, quand on fabrique. Je
vous pose juste une question. C'est
c'était quoi votre salaire à l'époque
pour nous fourguer toutes ces merdes ?
Ah, ça dépend, ça dépend quand j'ai
commencé, ça dépend de la fonction que
j'avais, ça dépend de la taille de
l'entreprise.
Allez, on commence par le début.
Mais ça allit entre entre 3 et entre 3
et 10. Ouais. Entre 3 et 10000.
Net.
H
D'accord. Vous avez fini
hors prime hors hors avantage et cetera.
le le le packaging pour que votre
éthique soit en accord avec votre
salaire, c'està-dire le prix de votre
silence ou le prix de votre rémunération
n'a rien à voir. C'est pas parce que
enfin c'est pas parce que j'étais payé
plus ou payé moins que le que
vous fermiez votre gueule
que le comportement changé. En fait,
c'est pas une question d'ouvrir ou de
fermer sa bouche. C'est-à-dire que quand
j'ai enfin, il faut qu'on remonte un
petit peu à l'origine si vous voulez.
C'estàd qu'au début quand moi j'ai
commencé à travailler y compris avant de
travailler. Moi depuis que je suis tout
petit, je trava enfin je suis dans
l'agroalimentaire mais mon père était
dans l'agroalimentaire. Je j'ai
travaillé l'été pour payer mes études
dans l'agroalimentaire. Donc je suis
dans dans la nourriture, dans la bouffe,
on va dire, depuis tout le temps. Et
c'était pour moi une vraie vocation, une
vraie envie de travailler dans
l'agroalimentaire. Et je me rappelle
quand j'étais petit, j'avais vu la pub à
l'époque, je sais pas si ça vous parle,
mais où il y avait un personnage qui
s'appelait El Gringo qui voyageit dans
le monde entier pour acheter du café. Et
moi, j'avais vu ça et ça m'avait ça
m'avait fasciné. Et je m'étais dit si un
jour je dois travailler, j'aimerais
faire ça. J'aimerais comme gringo
voyager dans le monde entier, acheter du
café ou des épices. C'était vraiment mon
rêve de gamin. Et donc il était pas
question de magouille ou autre, c'était
vraiment acheter les meilleurs produits,
les importer, des produits précieux,
enfin des des produits nobles. Euh donc
j'ai travaillé pour ça. Donc j'ai eu un
18 agroalimentaire qui s'est qui s'est
bien passé où il y avait pas de scandale
ou pas de magouille, on va dire. Euh
j'étais ingénieur donc très très bien
aussi. Et c'est qu'une fois dans le
monde de l'entreprise que j'ai commencé
à réaliser qu'il pouvait y avoir des
problèmes.
De quel type ?
Bah on s'accordait on s'accordité. La
réglementation était vraiment mal faite.
C'est quoi les facilités ?
Bon ben, par exemple, quand on avait un
lot qui était qui était pas conforme,
qui était périmé, qui avait des matières
étrangères, qui avait qui était
alors c'est quoi alors ? J'ai j'ai
remarqué il y a une infinité d'exemples.
J'ai j'ai remarqué en préparant
l'interview que comme dans la
communication, vous avez un vocabulaire
qui tort la langue française. C'estàd
que vous utilisez des mots
Oui, c'est vrai.
qui qui c'est un peu comme dans la com,
ça ça tort la langue, ça travestit la
langue française. Donc
dans l'industrie.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Dans l'industrie dans
voilà. D'accord. Donc revenons un petit
peu sur ce jargon. Je vous demanderai si
vous rentrez dans le dans le détail à
chaque rentrez dans le détail à chaque
fois.
OK. Donc revenons. Vous avez dit quel
mot là ?
Des non conformités ou des choses ?
Oui. Non conformité. Ça veut dire quoi ?
Non conformité c'est par rapport à la
loi. C'est par rapport à la santé.
C'estàd que si on dit si je vous parle
de qualité, si je vous dis c'est un
produit de mauvaise qualité, le problème
c'est qu'on s'entend pas sur qu'est-ce
que c'est que la qualité. C'est souvent
moi j'entends dire des des gens qui me
disent "Ah c'est de la mauvaise qualité
chez vous d'accord mais qu'est-ce que tu
entends par qualité ? C'est quoi un
produit de bonne qualité ? C'est un
produit goûteux ? C'est un produit sain
microbiologiquement ? C'est un produit
qui a pas de contamination ? Un produit
de qualité, ça veut rien dire en
lui-même s'il y a pas un cahier des
charges qui lui est associé.
Moi, si on dit
définir la qu il faut définir la
qualité. Si si on me dit un produit de
qualité, par exemple, on va prendre
l'exemple du poulet.
Oui.
D'accord. Vous connaissez bien le poulet
en plus, non ? Oui. Oui, un peu. C'est
pas un poulet que je connais mieux, mais
poulet de qualité, c'est un poulet qui a
eu le temps de grandir, qui a pas mangé
des saloperies, qui a pas été
dopé avec tout un tas de molécules pour
le rendre super balaise au bout de 3
mois, qui a une chair qui tient la
cuisson, qui a une chair goûteuse, qui
est issue d'un élevage raisonné et qui
et qui va surtout m'apporter des
nutriments que je vais pouvoir fixer
dans mon organisme qui va qui vont
pouvoir m'apporter euh une capacité à
fonctionner. Oui, sans doute. Mais le le
le consommateur, il il a pas ce genre de
de définition précise de la qualité pour
un pour un poulet. C'est-à-dire que des
nutriments et cetera, bon c'est pas
forcément marqué sur l'emballage qu'il y
a des nutriments dans le produit ou et
puis par exemple si vous prenez un
chinois pour lui pour le chinois le
somum de la qualité c'est un poulet de 1
kg où ils se ressemblent tous et puis
voilà même la couleur des poulets est
pas la même. Un asiatique va préférer un
poulet plutôt blanchâtre, un européen un
poulet un poulet plutôt jaunâtre. Donc
en fait définir la qualité d'un produit
et la bonne qualité, c'est extrêmement
difficile. Euh cette notion de de
d'élevage en batterie par exemple, les
asiatiques s'en moquent un peu de la de
l'élevage en batterie.
Donc j'ai visité des des fermes en Chine
qui avaient des des
dizaines de milliers de truit dans les
dans dans les dans les fer dans les
élevages de port en Europe, c'est
quasiment inconcevable. H et c'est
pareil, moi je me rappelle, j'ai discuté
avec un fournisseur d'œuf par exemple et
le gars me disait il y a une il y a une
manie maintenant, c'est d'avoir les œufs
de plein air. Voilà. Il me dit "Mais
c'est absolument je cite c'est
absolument dégueulasse parce que les
poules vont pondre dans la dans le prê
dans les déjections et on se retrouve à
avoir des œufs qui sont extrêmement
contaminés par rapport à les œufs en
cage où on a un produit qui est beaucoup
plus sain microbiologiquement. Donc ce
que je veux dire c'est que pour le
professionnel un œuf de plein air c'est
un œuf de mauvaise qualité. Vous avez
déjà visité une une ferme en cage comme
vous le dites. Est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu les les vidéos de L214
où il y a des poulets crevés, où il y a
des euh
Non, parce que moi j'achetais pas le
l'œuf ou je enfin j'acheté des produits
déjà semi-transformés. J'achetais ce
qu'on appelait de la coule d'œuf,
c'estàd l'œuf cassé, séparé, le jaune
d'un côté, le blanc de l'autre en poudre
et cetera. Donc moi, j'ai visité des
usines de transformation d'œuf. Donc
j'ai vu les œufs, les palettes d'œuf,
mais j'ai pas vu ce qu'il y avait avant.
Donc j'ai pas vu d'élevage en général.
Non, j'ai non, j'ai pas enfin en Europe,
du moins à cette époque-là, j'ai pas vu
d'élevage.
Ça vous est déjà arrivé de de passer des
produits périmés ?
C'est arrivé
dans dans la filiale ?
C'est arrivé. C'est arrivé. C'est
arrivé. Souvent, pas souvent.
Oui, très fréquemment.
C'est quoi très fréquemment ? Et dans
quelle quantité ?
Et pour quel type de produit final ?
Et à quel prix ? J'allais dire pour
quasiment tous les produits dans
quasiment toutes les industries, c'est
que quand vous avez un produit qui va se
périmer pour l'entreprise, ça veut dire
une perte sèche et un produit périmé
n'est pas forcément pour autant pas
consommable.
Donc
moi le pire exemple que j'avais par
exemple en mémoire c'était dans une
boîte d'épices où j'ai travaillé où on
faisait du rasel à nous le rasel à nout
c'est un mélange d'épic voyez et ce
rasel nout c'était la
rasel no
raselout c'est j'ai jamais su ce que ça
voulait vraiment dire personne n'était
capable de me le dire donc en fait ce
produitl c'était vraiment la poubelle de
l'entrepris mais la poubelle au sens
véridique c'estàd que tous les lots qui
avaient un problème que ce soit
d'insectes de de de moisie de corps
étranger de date de pérempomtion et
cetera, tout passait dans le raser la
nôtre C'est ma mère qui va être
contente.
Et et
je dis pas que tous les fabricants font
comme ça, je disais que là où je
travaillais, ça faisait comme ça.
Vous avez passé combien de tonnes de
périmé ?
J'aurais pas vous le dire parce que moi
j'étais aux achats, donc j'achetais les
matières. Si ensuite le produit se
périmé en stock, moi je n'avais pas
forcément connaissance. Ça c'était de la
de la responsabilité de la production,
on va dire.
Comment vous pouvez affirmer que vous
avez passé des produits périmés ?
Bah parce que je le savais parce que des
fois on me disait bah voilà, il y a tel
produit parce que je faisais du trading
aussi, du négocios. Donc on disit voilà,
tel produit va être périmé, il faudrait
le revendre, tel produit va être périmé,
il faudrait s'en débarrasser, tel
produit, on l'a pas vendu. On a eu un
retour d'un client. Voilà, un client
nous a rentourné 10 palettes euh parce
qu'il les avait pas lui-même vendu et
qu'elles étaient périmées.
Donc et ben voilà. Et puis moi j'étais
au comité de direction. Donc comité de
direction, tout se dit quasiment. Donc
au comité de direction, prédirecteur
industriel voilà, j'ai eu un tel qui
nous a renvoyé 10 palettes de
mayonnaise. Maintenant, elle est on est
plus dans les clous, elle va avoir un
goût de rance. Qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ?
directeur lui disait "Bah tu la repasses
à 10 % 15 % dans la commande de tel
client." C'était c'était extrêmement
courant. C'était le c'était même pas des
choses qu'on relevait.
Non, c'est enfin voilà si tu veux comme
on avait
c'était on on on parlait techniquement
d'un problème technique. On apportait
une solution à un problème qu'on avait.
On avait 10 tonnes de produits qui
avaient un problème, on essayait de les
passer mais ça s'est passé pour les
épices, ça s'est passé pour les sauces,
ça s'est passé pour le miel, ça s'est
passé pour tous les produits que j'ai
connu, pour des champignons surgelés,
pour des produits surgelés. On a même eu
des containers par exemple qui avaient
une panne pendant le transport. Le
produit avait commencé à décongeler,
avait changé de couleur. On a fait des
analyses, l'analyse microbio était
bonne. On s'est dit bon bah c'est pas un
produit dangereux et ça a été passé.
Mais c'est c'est enfin c'est tout le
temps tout enfin quasiment. Oui.
Jamais entendu de de de ravioli à au
port ou des choses comme ça ?
Pas enfin pas chez moi, enfin pas dans
les entreprises où j'ai travaillé,
on faisait pas genre de produit.
Mais ça s'est déjà entendu dans
l'agroalimentaire que la la chaîne Halal
soit contaminée ?
Bah j'en ai j'en ai souvent entendu
parler mais j'ai jamais pu le vérifier.
Personnellement, j'ai jamais pu le
vérifier. J'ai jamais connu quelqu'un
qui m'est dit "On a fait c, on a fait
ça." Je serais vraiment pas surpris. Je
suis quasiment même persuadé que ça
s'est fait mais je et je sais qu'il y a
eu des analyses dans certains pays. Par
exemple, je sais qu'en Malaisie puisque
bon maintenant je vis en Asie et qu'en
Malaisie eu un scandale récemment sur
ça. Donc je sais que ce sont des choses
qui se sont pratiquées. Oui.
Quand on dit gélatine de porc, quand on
fait des bonbons, ils sont àal ou ils
sont pas àal ?
Bah je suis pas un spécialiste de l'alle
moi. Donc je sais je saurais pas vous
dire quelles sont quelles sont
précisément les critères. Bon la
gélatine qui vient des eau de porc ou de
la peau de porc, c'est forcément à mon
avis pas àal. Voilà, la question a été
provoquée.
Donc la gélatine de porc doit pas être à
l'AL, je suppose.
Les contrôles euh ça se passe comment ?
Les contrôles en général ça se passe
pas. C'està-dire que les contrôles en
fait il faut savoir que les organismes
officiels, c'est pour ça que tu que tu
veux dire les organismes officiels
chargés de faire les contrôles sont trop
peu nombreux parce qu'ils doivent
contrôler tout ce qui rentre, qui se
fabrique et qui s'exporte. Donc c'est
des des des millions de camions qui
entrent et qui sortent du territoire
chaque jour. Donc c'est impossible de
tout contrôler. Donc ils font par
sondage ou éventuellement certains
produits qui sont connus comme étant à
risque. Nous on a eu quelques contrôles
sur les truffes par exemple.
C'est quoi risque ? C'est parce que il y
a il y a un AOC derrière ou un
Non, c'est parce qu'ils savent que il y
a souvent des fraudes, des produits
chers comme le Safran par exemple. Le
Safran, il y avait souvent des contrôles
de Safran. Mais bon, les contrôles de
Safran, ça se bornait à ce qu'un regarde
les factures, les documents. Les
documents étaient conforts mais il
repartait. C'est parce qu'il y a des
c'est un produit cher qui va être acheté
par une personne qui a un fort pouvoir
d'achat qui peut se payer un avocat.
Non, c'est pas ça. C'est que le le
Safran, comme c'est les pistes la plus
chères du monde, c'est très ça enfin ça
attire beaucoup de margoulin pour
essayer de il vaut mieux trafiquer du
safran, ça fait beaucoup plus d'argent
que trafiquer une épice pas chère. Donc
c'est une épice qui est très très
souvent trafiquée. Oui.
Donc revenons sur les contrôles. Donc
ils sont sous-dimensionnés. Qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce
ils sont pas suffisamment nombreux pour
pour pouvoir les faire ? Donc ce qui
fait qu'ils font des contrôles très
rarement. Moi, je me souviens de deux
contrôles dans ma carrière. Donc, deux
contrôles en 20 ans, vous voyez, c'est
pas grand-chose. Euh et la responsab, il
faut savoir que enfin comment on est
protégé, comment le consommateur est
protégé, c'est que la loi fait
obligation à l'industriel
de faire des autocontrôles, lui-même de
s'assurer que la marchandise, elle est
bonne. Donc, c'est soit l'industriel qui
fabrique, soit ce qu'on appelle le
premier importateur. Celui qui importe
un produit chinois, le premier à
importer, il doit s'assurer que le
produit qu'il importe soit de qualité
avant qu'il soit mis en ce qu'on appelle
en libre circulation.
Il il risque quoi quand ils se font top
? C'est une petite tape sur les doigts,
une petite amis. J'ai jamais connu
personne se faire se faire taper sur les
doigts ou se faire chez nous. Enfin, je
veux dire, enfin, tu vois ce que je
raconte dans mon bouquin, je veux dire,
c'est j'ai jamais connu personne de chez
nous, ne serait-ce qu'aller au tribunal
ou ne serait-ce qu'elle est enfin
pour moi, il y a il y a pas de sanction.
Il y a une impunité quasi totale. Alors,
ça peut-être changer ces dernières
années, mais dans ce que j'ai connu, il
y a jamais eu de problème. Mais c'est
bien pour ça que les fraudes continuent
et qu'on a qu'on en a en permanence
parce qu'il y a pas de sanction.
C'est quoi le truc le plus dégueulasse
que vous ayez que vous ayez eu à gérer
pendant votre carrière ?
Le plus dégueu. Alors, je sais pas parce
que
c'est des œufs contaminés, c'est de la
viande de cheval issue des courses
ultrapé.
Non non, ça non, ça on a on a on a pas
fait chez moi. Non, ce qui Non,
peut-être des lots enfin moi c'est c'est
vrai que des choses comme par exemple
les les lots de piment ou les lots
d'épices contaminées où on il y avait eu
des des rats qui s'étaient installés qui
avaient des fqués qui étaient morts
dedans. Enfin bref, il y avait de tout
dans ces produitsl. Donc ça
effectivement c'était peu ragoutant et
c'est comme on est pas arrivé à le
nettoyer, on a tout broyé. Donc ça
effectivement c'est c'est un produit qui
était un petit peu un petit peu
choquant. Mais d'un autre côté, je sais
très bien que comme ce produit-là était
débactérisé, donc traité à la vapeur,
stérilisé, quelque part, c'est pas
dangereux.
Donc visuellement c'est peu ragoûtant
mais d'un autre côté, il y a pas de
danger. Donc chez nous, ça passait comme
une lettre à la poste.
Ça donne du goût, ça fait terroir.
Ouais, même pas, j'en sais rien parce
que enfin personne chez nous les
consommait ces produits là. Donc euh on
les personne chez vous les consommait.
Ça c'est très intéressant de savoir. Tu
me disais tout à l'heure euh par rapport
au salaire et cetera, jeis le problème
c'est pas le salaire, c'est que quand tu
es dans ce genre quand tu fais un gars
comme moi par exemple,
c'est la peur de perdre son travail,
c'est quoi ?
Mais même pas en fait même pas. Ça c'est
au début, enfin si je prends mon cas
particulier, mon cas personnel, quand
j'ai commencé à travailler dans ce
milieu-là, j'étais un employé totalement
dévoué à l'entreprise,
totalement dévoué à mes collègues, à
l'équipe et cetera et et on est dans un
univers, dans un moule qui fait que mon
entreprise a un problème, j'essaie de
résoudre le problème. Il y a une c'est
une loyauté professionnelle et enfin
voilà donc
même le mal qu'on fait du moins au début
on y réfléchit même pas et on le voit
même pas. Quand j'ai écrit mes bouquins,
il y a beaucoup de mes collègues ou mes
anciens collègues qui ont pas compris ce
que j'ai enfin la démarche que j'ai que
j'ai que j'ai fait pour eux. Ils ont
rien à se reprocher. Ils veulent pas le
voir, pas le regarder, j'en sais rien.
Mais il y a beaucoup de de personnes qui
je crois qui le font sans même sans même
voir le mal. Et si moi j'ai évolué,
c'est parce que bah c'est parce que j'ai
été papa, c'est parce que je me suis
marié, c'est parce que je suis plus la
même personne à 40 ans que j'étais à 20
ans. On voit les choses différemment, on
réfléchit et ce qu'on ce qu'on me
demandait de faire quand j'avais 25 30
ans, il y a un moment ça devenait plus
possible. Alors, comment on y échappe ?
C'est soit soit on s'écrase, on rentre
dans le moule et puis on ferme les yeux,
soit on dénonce comme j'ai fini par le
faire, mais ça veut dire que c'est c'est
enfin clairement c'est un suicide
professionnel. Donc il faut il faut il
faut le vouloir. Il faut être enfin
inconscient ou voilà. Ou alors on change
d'entreprise. Alors c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire moi. J'ai changé
d'entreprise quasiment six fois
pour pour essayer de voir si ailleurs
c'était mieux que là où j'étais. Donc
donc voilà, c'est pas c'est pas du tout
simple.
Alors, j'ai appris plein de trucs et et
ce qui m'a fait plaisir, c'est que j'ai
appris des nouveaux mots. Ah !
Et j'aime j'aime j'aime apprendre de
nouveaux mots. Ça veut dire quoi ?
Auxiliaire de production ou auxiliaire
technologique ?
Alors, ça c'est enfin selon moi pour moi
c'est une grosse enfade. C'est c'est
vraiment une arnaquerie intellectuelle.
C'est-à-dire que
où ça aide la où ça aide ?
Pourquoi c'est Je me fais l'avocat du
diable ?
Dire.
Ça veut rien dire en fait. C'est en fait
c'est un additif. C'est un bullshit word
de communiquant.
Oui. Oui. Mais c'est même c'est même pas
que de la communication, c'est vraiment
c'est une catégorie d'additif qui est
spécialement conçue pour ne pas être
déclaré sur la liste sur la liste
d'ingrédients. C'est quelque chose
réellement qu'on ne veut pas dire au
consommateur. Donc il y a il y a 400
additifs qui sont donc un additif, il
faut quand même bien savoir que c'est
pas un aliment. C'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas un aliment qu'on rajoute à
l'alimentaire. Donc c'est c'est quelque
chose qui se consomme pas normalement.
Donc on en a 3 400 qui alors pour faire
plaisir aux industriel, le législateur a
dit bah voilà les produits qui
finalement se retrouvent quasiment pas à
la fin.
Attends attends attends attends. Ça veut
dire quoi pour faire plaisir aux
industriels ? C'estd qu'il y a un lobby,
il y a quoi ? B il y a des lobby on va
aborder le
il y a un lobby, il y a un lobby énorme.
Mais il il y a pas un lobby, il y a des
lobbyes.
Donc revenons revenons à nos
auxiliaires.
Donc auxiliaire technologique c'est des
additifs qu'on peut utiliser sans les
déclarer. Donc si par exemple toi tu es
sensible à un de ces produitsl pourras
pas savoir qu'il y en a. D'accord. Donc
ces produits là c'est quoi ? Il y a je
sais plus 17 catégories. Il y a les les
solvants, par exemple, les solvants,
l'exane, les gens ne savent pas. Mais la
plupart des huiles, que ce soit les
huiles alimentaires ou les le le le
beurre de cacao par exemple, des huiles
comme celle-là sont extraites au solvant
organique cancée.
Donc quand on est
c'est pas marqué.
Non, c'est pas marqué.
Et le le est-ce que les pouvoirs publics
ils sont
c'est légal. C'est la réglementation
européenne qui vous dit qu'un auxiliaire
technologique ne n'a pas être déclaré,
peut ne pas être déclaré, n'est pas
déclarable. Donc vous le déclarez pas
quand on est industriel, on le met, on
le déclare pas. Donc on a je vous dis
400 additifs comme on a le par exemple,
on parlait du du des produits
décaféinés.
Donc il y a il y a il y a un solvant
organique qui permet d'enlever la
caféine qui se retrouve dans le produit
fini à l'état de trace
et qui est dans le produit et que le
consommateur va consommer sans le
savoir. Alors ce qui est drôle c'est que
on vous dit d'un côté que ce sont des
produits qui se retrouvent à l'état de
traces quasiment inquantifiable à la
fin. Par contre pour ces produits là on
met quand même des seuils. On vous dit
voilà pour le
le dichlorométhane par exemple
qui sert à quoi qui fait quoi ?
C'est un solvant.
Prenez du café voyez café en poudre. En
fait du café en poudre ouverz du
solvant. Donc au lieu de mettre de
l'eau, vous mettez un solvant organique
liquide
un peu comme avec la cocaïne.
Je sais pas ça on a on a pas fait mais
bon. Donc un solvant liquide comme de
l'eau et ça va entraîner uniquement la
caféine. Ensuite vous allez avoir un
liquide qui contient de la caféine, vous
évaporez le solvant et il vous reste de
la caféine caféine en poudre qui vont
qui sera utilisé par exemple pour les
boissons type boisson énergisante. Donc
vous avez de la caféine avec un petit
peu de solvant et vous avez du café
décaféiné ou du thé détéiné avec du
solvant également. Donc pour ces
produits-là, vous avez des limites
maximum de résidus. Donc ça veut bien
dire qu'il en reste. Ce sont des
produits qui sont cancérigènes. Donc on
sait très bien que les produits
cancérigènes sont toxiques.
Il y a eu des études euh parce qu'on dit
cancérigène. Hier hier je me suis je me
suis fait plein il y a plein d'études.
Regardez le
je me suis fait un petit plaisir. J'ai
j'ai regardé encore le le sur le jambon
et et
solitaire.
Comment ? Ouais.
Oui. Oui. Les et je me je me suis fait
plaisir à écouter l'argumentation de sur
les études scientifiques, sur le le sel
nitrité, sur ces choses-là. Quand vous
dites cancérigène,
ça veut dire quoi ? S'il y a eu des
études, il y a eu des cas prouvés.
Il y a il y a eu il y a beaucoup
d'études. Alors, il y a c'est toujours
pareil les études, c'est compliqué parce
que quand il y a une étude qui dit que
un produit et cancérène, c'est aussitôt
contrebalancé et contredit par une autre
étude qui dit que ça allait pas. Donc
bah, c'est exactement comme le
glyphosate par exemple. Vous avez le CRC
qui dit que c'est cancérigène et puis
vous avez la Commission européenne et
l'AFSA qui enfin l'FSA qui vous dit ben
non finalement c'est pas prouvé. Donc
vous avez toujours c'est très difficile
de se baser sur une étude parce que vous
avez toujours les études qui en général
sont financées par les fabricants.
Je je me prends le point de vue du
fabricant de d'auxiliaire technologique.
Ah mais ils sont ils sont très nombreux.
C'est c'est je vous dis 400 produits,
c'est fabriqué par des entreprises très
différentes. Ah
s'il faisait des Je me fais encore
l'avquer du diable, ils vont adorer sur
internet. Si c'est si c'était
cancérigène, ça saurait,
il le vendrait pas. Pourquoi vous
rigolez ?
Ah enfin je rigole parce que ça je sais
pas, je veux pas vous vexer, mais on
dirait une question à la la Bourdin. Ça
veut dire c'est
c'est fait exprès.
Bon très bien. Donc
le problème c'est que pour ces produits
là, bah disons comment est-ce qu'on met
sur le marché un auxiliaire
technologique ou un additif ou autre un
nouveau produit, voilà ou un médicament
par exemple, tout ça c'est de la même
catégorie, d'accord ? C'est l'industriel
qu'il fabrique, qui prépare le dossier
et qui va le soumettre. Vous allez dire
voilà, j'ai tel produit qui a telle
propriété, on met ça dans la nourriture.
C'est un auxiliaire technologique parce
que ça aide à la fabrication. D'accord ?
Donc ça apporte rien au produit mais ça
aide à la fabrication. Donc par exemple
un agent antimousse ou un produit pour
faire briller des choses très utiles
pour le consommateur. Et ce produitl
études que j'ai financé et qui prouvent
que c'est pas dangereux. Bon, ces
étudesl il les amène à la Commission
européenne. Donc, par exemple à l'Afsa
pour les les produits alimentaires.
L'AFSA a des commissions, des comités
d'experts qui vont évaluer ses études et
dire si oui ou non c'est dangereux.
Alors, il faut savoir quand même que il
y a l'organisme Transparency Watch, je
vous vérifier le nom, mais qui dit que
oui, mais c'est très bien, mais si ce
n'est que les experts de l'fa, la moitié
d'entre eux sont payés par l'industrie.
Donc ça veut dire que d'une part, c'est
l'industrie qui fait les dossiers, c'est
l'industrie qui les fait évaluer par des
experts qui financent et même ça va plus
loin. C'est qu' les méthodes d'analyse,
les méthodes d'évaluation de la
dangerosité sont définies par
l'industrie. Et là, vous êtes en train
de jeter l'eau propre sur la probité de
des scientifiques.
50 % seulement.
Peut dire qu'il y a quand même la moitié
des scientifiques qui sont probes.
Jusqu'à preuve du contraire
ou con.
Non, il y a il y a forcément des gens
hautes dans le lot. Je veux dire, il y a
Non, il y a des gens qui se font pas
acheter. Bah, je suppose. Oui,
forcément. C'est comme dans toute
industrie, comme dans tout même chez les
journalistes. Certainement.
On n'est pas journaliste.
Ah bon ? Je sais pas. Pour peut-être
qu'un jour vous le serez si vous
travaillez bien et
Ah non,
non.
Euh on va revenir à nos moutons donc sur
les sur les additifs technologiques. Euh
euh d'autres exemples genre des des
filet de poisson un peu plus costaud, un
peu plus dudu, des des crevettes un peu
plus dudes.
Oh bah
des quoi ?
J'en ai Ouais, enfin j'en ai plein.
Enfin c'est si dans le premier bouquin
par exemple, je sais plus, il y a
peut-être 20 chapitres et chaque
chapitre est sur un produit différent.
J'ai eu la chance si tu veux de changer
l'entreprise souvent et de travailler
pour des grosses entreprises. La plus
grosse dans laquelle j'ai travaillé
avait 20000 employés. Te donner un petit
peu une idée de la taille.
Donc dans ces entreprises-là, on a des
filiales, différentes usines et on fait
plein de produits. Dans une entreprise
où je travaillais, on faisait des
épices, du miel, des produits surgelés,
des sauces, enfin tous ces produitsl
dans la même dans la même entreprise et
comme j'étais moi le directeur des
achats, j'achetais tous ces produits-là,
y compris les emballages aussi.
Donc j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir voir
plein de produits différents et plein de
de de
on va pas dire fraude, mais plein
d'astuces, on va dire, différentes pour
tous ces produitsl. Alors oui, il y a
des problèmes sur les filets de poisson,
il y a des problèmes sur le poisson, il
y a des problèmes sur le sur tous les
produits sur le miel énormément sur
miel.
J'étais un des plus gros acheteur de
miel. J'achetais des des des centaines
de tonnes de miel pour la grande
distribution française notamment. Donc
c'est des produits que je connais très
bien et que enfin on parle de choses
enfin pour le miel ça s'est passé comme
il y a assez longtemps. Quand j'ai
commencé moi du miel, mon prédécesseur
m'a dit "Ah tu verras le miel c'est
extraordinaire. C'est c'est enfin tout
le miel que tu vas acheter en Chine,
c'est pas du miel." Donc il m'a expliqué
comment ça se passait. Il m'a dit
"T'inquiète pas, de toute façon tout le
monde est au courant que ce soit les
fraudes, que ce soit les politiques, que
ce soit tout le monde est au courant
mais tout le monde le fait et on nous
laisse faire." J'ai acheté du miel et
effectivement c'est passé comme une
lettre à la poste et
j'en parle dans mon premier bouquin donc
que j'ai écrit en 2015. À cette
époque-là, il est sorti les analyses de
chez que choisir qui disait que 30 % du
miel en Europe était fraudé. Ce que je
disais moi dans mon bouquin aussi.
Est-ce que je connaissais moi depuis
depuis 20 ans, est-ce que mon
prédécesseur connaissait depuis depuis
30 ans peut-être ? Et là, j'ai encore vu
il y a pas très longtemps qu'il y a
encore ces histoires de de miel chinois
fraudé en Europe et qu'on ne fait
toujours rien.
On a reçu Arnaud Montbour sur ce sujet
là, il nous en a bien parlé. Vous avez
vu des trucs du genre on colore les
fruits et légumes avec des petits bains,
on rend les pastèques un peu plus
rouges, on on passe les pommes avec un
super produit qui permet de les
conserver une année, des choses comme
ça.
Ça, je pas non pas non sur ces produits
là non. J'ai pas travaillé les pommes et
les pastèques mais non moi j'ai vu les
fruits de mer par exemple qu' enfin qui
étaiit gonflé à l'eau avec les
injections d'eau, les champignons,
champignons de Paris pareil pol surgelé
où il y avait le glaçage et l'injection
d'eau également avec tous les addifs qui
vont bien mais qui sont pas déclarés
puisque le glaçage et l'injection d'eau
est pas forcément autorisé donc quand on
le fait on dit pas ce qu'il y a dedans.
Euh qu'est-ce qu'on a vu encore ? Oui,
enfin je sais même pas quel exemple vous
prendre. Il a il a
il a eu souvent des des
stocks de viande par exemple qui
venaient de Hongrie mais qui passaient
par l'Argentine le
Non parce que dans les entrepes où j'ai
travaillais, on faisait pas beaucoup de
viande. J'achetais du jambon, j'achetais
ce qu'on appelait des PAI, des produits
alimentaires intermédiaires.
C'est quoi ?
C'est des produits déjà transformés. Par
exemple du jambon, c'est c'est pas la
viande qu'on prend sur l'animal, c'est
le c'est de la viande qu'on prend sur
l'animal mais qui a été déjà transformée
pour pour en faire du jambon cuit. Vous
avez jamais traité du minerais de viande
?
Non.
C'est quoi le minerais de viande ?
Bah le minerais de viande, ce sont des
c'est en gros c'est les copos qu'on de
viande qu'on récupère sur en général sur
les carcasses.
Mais copos, ça fait propre. Euh c'est
quoi les copos ? C'est
c'est des raclures de viande, enfin je
sais pas comment on peut définir ça. Cop
les tendons. Euh
for pas forcément si c'est non. Oui.
Enfin il y aura forcément quand on va
raccler quand on fait ce qu'on appelle
la la viande séparée mécaniquement, on
va forcément récupérer un peu de tendon
et récupérer un petit peu d'os. Un petit
peu
dans les ste cachés. Ça se voit. Ah bah
oui, enfin ça va dans les steak mais non
ça se voit pas.
Hier en préparant l'interview, j'étais
en train de me faire mon petit steak
haché sur joli.
H
et puis j'ai creuser un peu le sujet et
là je me suis rendu compte que mon steak
il avait pas le même goût. C'était
psychologique, pas psychologique.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans un steak haché
surgelé ? Est-ce que vous mangez du
steak haché surgelé ?
Non, j'allais dire faut pas non moi j'
enfin non jamais. Je prends jamais de
viande. Non non non, je mange du sec
haché quand je vois le le le boucher la
le faire devant moi et quand je vois ce
qui met dans la machine. C'est je je
prends un produit fait avec la viande
fraîche de la viande qui me convient.
C'estàd qu'il y a pas trop de tendon et
cetera. Enfin bon bah rappelez-vous,
c'était il y a pas longtemps, c'était il
y a quelques mois les les fameux stchés
qui avaient été achetés par l'État
français en Pologne. Ça on se demande
pourquoi et où on s'est rendu compte en
fait donc des stchés achetés pour les
100 ans et pour les pauvres. Les gens
qui sont rien comme dirait l'autre euh
les send.
Oui bah voilà les stchés c'est parfait
pour les c'est bien.
Bah oui ils ont pas ils ont pas besoin
de mâcher beaucoup donc et ils sont
rendus compte donc dans les restaurants
du cœur et cetera qu'en fait cétait
caché était il contenaient quasiment pas
de viande. C'était des des des
sous-produits enfin des amidons, des
texturants, de la flotte enfin voilà.
Donc ça ça montre bien que oui c'est ces
fraudes continuent encore aujourd'hui.
Ça se fait à très grande échelle.
Vous parlez des pauvres
euh donc des pauvres qui achètent des
produits à bas prix à bas coup.
Euh certaines grandes enseignes disent
"On a quand même la qualité chez nous,
c'est pas cher mais on a la qualité."
Vous y croyez à ce genre de choses ?
Est-ce que plus c'est pas cher, plus on
risque ?
Bah le problème, c'est qu'il faut, je
vous dis encore, il faut s'entendre sur
le terme de qualité. Qu'est-ce qu'on
parle ? Qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
qualité ?
Bah c'est c'est-à-dire
le principe de d'une alimentation, c'est
vous mangez, vous
vous empoisonnez pas, vous digérez bien,
vous devenez pas obèse et pas
diabétique. Bon
et puis on prend pas de cancer.
Voilà. Donc ça pour pour avoir ces
produits là, plus on descend en prix,
plus c'est difficile
parce que les produits pour faire des
produits de de très grande consommation
et de grande masse, il va falloir
forcément produire à grande échelle,
trouver la ne serait-ce que trouver le
produit. C'estàd que les produits de
haute qualité souvent sont sont
relativement peu disponibles. C'estàd
que si vous voulez si demain tout le
monde veut manger, je sais pas moi, euh
de la por deor,
du port de bigor ou de la ou de
l'obraque, enfin voyez, quelque chose de
de de très grande qualité, il y a pas
les quantités disponibles. Donc si
demain tout le monde voulait en acher,
les prix exploderaient, s'envoleraient
de manière astronomique. Donc vous êtes
obligé quand vous faites des gros
volumes de baisser en prix et ça veut
dire souvent oui baisser en qualité.
Alors après il faut comparer les choses
comparables, c'est qu'il y a des
produits qui naturellement sont pas
chers. Par exemple, vous prenez, moi
j'ai acheté au début de ma carrière des
légumes secs, des lentilles, des
haricots. Ces produitsl sont pas chers
par essence. Donc même si vous êtes sur
des produits très peu chers, il y aura
pas de gros problèmes de qualité. Si
vous êtes sur des produits typiquement
de la viande ou des plats préparés, à ce
moment-là, quand vous allez baisser en
prix, vous êtes obligé de dégrader la
qualité. Donc vous allez devoir
remplacer de la viande par quelque chose
qui est pas de la viande. Vous allez
devoir mettre l'ingrédient le moins cher
qui est de la flotte. Donc quand vous
mettez de la flotte, vous perdez en
texture, vous perdez en stabilité. Donc
vous mettez aussi donc des texturants,
vous mettez des conservateurs donc et
vous arrivez comme ça à faire des des
lasagnes ou des ou des hachis par
mentiers qui contiennent quasiment pas
de viande, qui ont des colorants, qui
ont des stabilisant, qui ont des
texturants et des produits qui sont et
du glucose souvent pour donner du goût.
Donc vous arrivez à avoir des produits
qui sont totalement déséquilibrés, trop
gras, trop sucrés, trop salés, qui on
plus de de d'antioxydant, qu' on plus de
vitamines, qui on plus de fibres. Donc
oui, en général quand vous baissez les
prix, vous baissez la qualité.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous avez entendu
euh
dans votre industrie des choses comme on
va rajouter du gras, du sucre, du sel
pour rendre les gens pour avoir vraiment
une grosse appétence comme ça ça va
fixer nos clients, ça va les rendre
dépendants ou des choses comme ça.
Est-ce que la bouffe des pauvres, je
vais être très trivial, est-ce que la
bouffe des pauvres l'opium
du pauvre ? Est-ce que c'est la drogue
des pauvres ? Disons que nous on se le
disait enfin on on le voyait pas comme
ça. C'estd qu'on faisait de la
nourriture pour tout le monde. On dis
enfin pas nous enfin notre enfin ce
qu'on fabriquait c'était pas
spécialement la destination des pauvres.
Par exemple quand on faisait du ketchup
c'est du ketchup pour tout le monde.
C'estd que on vendait du ketchup au au
grand du fast food par exemple. Bah ceux
qui vont dans le fast food c'est
probablement les pauvres mais pas
uniquement. Donc pour nous quand on
vendait à des fast food on vendait du
ketchup.
Ça fait combien de temps que vous avez
pas été dans un un fast food ?
Ouh là ça fait ça fait un bail. Ça fait
un bail. Ça fait très longtemps.
Ça fait très longtemps. Je même pas vous
dire.
Ça fait très longtemps. Ça fait des
années.
Donc c'était du ketchup avec de la
tomate française, de la tomate tomate
chinoise. La tomate chinoise bien sûr.
De la meilleure. Non,
selon nous de la meilleure. Oui, de la
moins chère. Oui.
Donc pour vous la qualité, la meilleure
c'est la moins chère. Pour nous, la
qualité la meilleure là où la plus de
marge,
c'est la qualité la plus la moins chère
que le client est prêt à accepter
et qui passe les contrôles sanitaires.
Tus produits passent les contrôles
sanitaires
parce qu'il y en a pas.
Parce qu'il y en a mais on s'arrange
enfin on s'arrange. Les produits sont
fabriqués et sont ils sont enfin ils
sont conçus pour passer les contrôles.
Si on prend l'exemple le plus le plus
flagrant le miel de Chine par exemple
c'est Mondada. Moi ça c'est c'est un
produit j'arrive pas à comprendre qu'on
qu'on continue à porter ce produitl.
J'ai visité des fournisseurs, j'en ai vu
en Espagne, j'en ai vu dans les pays de
l'ge, j'en ai vu en Hongrie, pour la
cassière de Hongrie, j'en ai vu en
Chine. Mais quand j'ai visité mes
fournisseurs en Chine, j'étais
complètement sur les sur les fesses
parce que c'est j'ai pas vu des usines,
j'ai vu des laboratoires. J'ai vu un
laboratoire d'hôpital avec des HPLC,
avec des chromatogrammes, avec enfin un
matériel qu'on trouve pas dans les plus
grands hôpitaux français. Et qu'est-ce
que faisaient ces gens-là ? Il faisait
des produits artificiels et il
soumettaient tous ces produits qu'ils
avaient fabriqués à des batteries de
test pour voir qu'est-ce qui s' passait.
Et bien sûr, quand on apportait ces
produits-là, on les testait avec des
méthodes souvent moins fiables que les
leur et bien sûr que ça passe.
Et aujourd'hui, on arrive à détecter les
fraudes sur le miel chinois qu'avec des
méthodes très pointues. Il y a des
laboratoires comme Euroins par exemple,
un laboratoire français qui a qui a
défini des nouvelles méthodes d'analyse
qui descendent au niveau du carbone pour
savoir si c'est un carbone qui vient
d'un d'un d'un d'un d'un miel ou si
c'est un carbone qui vient d'un sucre
ajouté, un sucre exogène. Donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que les les produits y
compris fraudés sont souvent très
difficiles à repérer.
Ça coûte cher une analyse de carbone de
miel, vous savez pas non ?
Euh certainement extrêmement cher, ça
n'en a jamais fait. Donc les analyses
qui sont chères, c'est les analyses par
exemple les pesticides sont chères.
Euh après les analyses de routine, la la
microbiologie donc s'il y a des
salmonnelles et cetera, ça ça vaut rien
du tout. Les analyses de routine comme
l'humidité, les matières sèches, ça vaut
rien du tout. Ce qui est cher, c'est les
les et encore de moins en moins mais les
analyses OGM, ça c'est cher, les
analyses euh pesticides euh et
effectivement les analyses très
techniques comme par exemple sur
l'identification des sucres exogènes,
des choses comme ça.
Les douanes euh ils sont intéressés à
vous quand vous êtes vous avez publié
votre bouquin. Ils ont ils ont ils vous
ont contacté en disant voilà vous pouvez
peut-être nous aider. Euh
Non, ben c'est vrai que quand moi je
l'ai publié ce bouquin, je m'attendais
je m'étais dit
je pense que je vais être contacté par
des collègues ou par le les syndicats de
l'agroalimentaire et cetera et peut-être
qu'on pourra faire des choses ensemble.
Je m'étais dit il serait il est quand
même pas normal qu'en France ça se passe
comme ça et on devrait pouvoir améliorer
les choses. Moi je me rappelle j'avais
lu un rapport qui avait fait par qui a
été fait par un universitaire anglais
qui disait voilà on peut mettre fin au
fraudes et au problèmes alimentaires et
il avait fait une étude en Angleterre il
a dit voilà quelles sont les mesures à
prendre à prendre enfin mesures à
prendre. J'avais vu ce rapport, je dit
c'est vachement intelligent. Je me dit
en France peut-être qu'il y aura la
possibilité de faire le même genre de le
même même genre de discussion. Et en
fait les ce que j'ai eu en retour moi,
c'est des communiqués par exemple de
l'ania qui est le le syndicat des
agroalimentaires français pour dire que
bah tout ce qui disait de de bien était
vrai et tout ce que je disais de de mal
était faux. Donc voilà le le retour que
j'ai eu.
L'ania c'est c'est c'est le même
syndicat qui qui était dans le
documentaire d'Élis Luis. Non.
Ah ça peut-être je sais pas, je l'ai pas
vu celui-là. Je sais pas. Fania c'est
syndicat des des industries
alimentaires, c'est pas le syndicat
agricole. Voilà, c'est lui qui est censé
représenter l'intérêt et à mon avis
qu'il le représente pas comme il
faudrait puisque on a des scandales à
répétition. Moi, j'ai encore vu là, j'ai
reçu un un message la semaine dernière
de Foodwatch qui qui épingle les lait
infantiles à marque je crois Nesley et
Danon parce qu'il retrouve dedans des
huiles minérales cancérigènes
et moi j'en parle dans mon premier
bouquin en 2015.
Alors les huiles minérales, on avait dit
qu'on expliquait le vocabulaire. Ah oui
donc les huiles minérales, c'est quoi ?
C'est une en fait c'est une huile qui
est pas alimentaire. C'està-dire que
c'est pas une huile biologique, c'est
pas une
c'est la même huile que je mets dans mon
moteur.
Ouais.
Alors
là le producteur de d'huile minérale, il
va dire non.
Non, ça il va dire non. Bah, il va dire
que c'est pas la même huile.
Non, mais c'estàdire que c'est pas c'est
pas de l'huile de moteur qui aurait
fuité dans les dans les produits.
C'est-à-dire que ce cette huile minfin,
il y a toute une catégorie d'huile
minérale. C'estàd qu'il y a de l'huile
de l'huile pour les moteurs, mais il y a
aussi de l'huile qui sert de on va
trouver de l'huile comme je sais pas moi
quand on fait un moulage plastique, on
va se servir d'une couche d'huile pour
démouler, on va servir d'huile pour
lubrifier les machines, il va y avoir de
l'huile pour
dans les cartons.
Oui, dans les ancres. Dans les ancres,
il va y avoir de l'huile dans les
ancrescres. Il va y avoir des des
lubrifiants, des préservatifs par
exemple. Il y a de l'huile minérale
dessus. Enfin, l'huile minéral, on en
trouve dans plein d'applications et
c'est pour ça dans les vernis. Bah, je
je suppose que l'huile minérale qu'on
retrouve dans les dans les lait pour
bébés Nesle et Danon qui sont mis en
cause par Foodwatch, je suppose qu'elle
vient probablement des vernis des
emballages.
Je vois pas trop d'où elle pourrait
provenir sinon. Euh, mais c'est c'est ça
pose pas de problème pour la santé les
huiles minérales. Vous dites dans les
préservatifs.
Ah si, c'est quand c'est Ouais, mais
c'est pas des produits qui sont destinés
à être avallés logiquement. Non mais
vous êtes jamais fait je suis je suis
désolé mais
vous avez déjà porté un préservatif.
Ça a pu m'arriver.
Ouais. Des fois euh ça ça peut vous
arriver que il y a un transfert d'huile
minérale chez votre partenaire. Non,
ça peut arriver. Ça peut arriver. Donc
c'est consommé, c'est avalé.
Oui, mais enfin bon aujourd'hui les ce
type de de de produits sont pas des
produits alimentaires. Donc ils sont
sont pas soumis à la réglementation des
produits alimentaires comme la
cosmétique et ce genre de choses. Donc
on s'est supposé ne pas bah traverser la
barrière de la peau et cetera. Pour les
produits alimentaires,
je crois même que pour les huiles
minérales, il y a pas eu de seuil
défini. Il y a pas c'est comme c'est pas
un produit, c'est pas un additif, c'est
pas un produit qui doit se retrouver
naturellement dans le produit, c'est pas
un produit qui est volontairement
ajouté, c'est un contaminant. Il y a pas
de réglementation bien définie pour ces
produits-là.
Non, puisque c'est pas supposé se
trouver là si vous voulez. Logiquement,
il devrait pas y en avoir. Foodwatch dit
pour nous consommateurs, surtout pour
les aliments pour bébés, il devrait pas
y avoir d'huile minérale dans des lait
en poudre. Il parle de ce principe-là.
Et en face, on leur répond quoi ? Bon
bah, vous êtes gentil mais il y a pas de
réglementation. Nous, on est dans les
clous. Enfin, ce que ce qu'on faisait ce
qu'on disait nous tout le temps.
La nourriture infantile, est-ce qu'elle
est mieux surveillée ? Oui,
les normes sont différentes. Il y a des
normes plus strictes. Donc il y a
par que les petits pots de bébé aux
petits légumes, c'est pas des petits
légumes qui ont été décongelés 25 fois
où il y a j'en ai jamais fabriqué, donc
je sais pas précisément comment ça se
fait, mais les normes sont beaucoup plus
draconiennes. Par exemple, en ter
plus de contrôle
même des normes c'estàd qu'on est
autorisé à des niveaux de pesticides
beaucoup moindres, bien inférieur.
Donc il y a il y a quasiment enfin les
les taux de pesticides sont très
faibles. Les additifs, je crois que
alors de mémoire, jeis pas dire de
bêtises, mais il y en a peut-être qu'une
qu'une cinquantaine autorisé alors que
des additives, vous en avez 400 plus 400
auxiliaires. Donc vous avez quasiment
800 dans le
après votre bouquin, vous avez pas été
contacté par les douanes.
Ça c'est intéressant parce que après mon
premier bouquin, j'ai été contacté par
quasiment tous les journalistes de la
place. C'est dès qu'il y a un scandale
alimentaire en France ou une question,
on m'appelle que ce soit envoyé spécial
que ce soit des journalistes de la
presse écrite, que ce soit enfin bref
dès qu'il y a un un tournage qui se
fait, une enquête qui se fait enfin j'ai
même fait des préfaces pour des par
exemple pour pour Malais sur son livre
sur la tomate, enfin je suis quasiment
devenu une référence il y a pas une
semaine où j'ai pas quelqu'un qui
m'appelle pour me demander des infos.
Est-ce que vous avez un contact ? Est-ce
que vous savez ce qui se passe ? Est-ce
que vous pouvez m'expliquer ? des
journalistes, je suis hyper connu chez
tous les journalistes.
Par contre, au niveau politique
et au niveau industriel,
j'ai été contacté par personne.
Absolument personne. Aucun politique ne
m'a
contacté.
Mais pourquoi ?
Mais pourquoi ? Mais pourquoi ?
Pourtant, j'ai discuté avec des
politiques parce que au début quand j'ai
quand j'ai quand j'ai sorti mon premier
bouquin, je me rappelle, j'avais discuté
avec un ancien ministre de
l'agriculture.
Comment il s'appelle ?
Ben, j'ai le problème, je m'en souviens
pas.
Il ressemblait à quoi ? Euh c'était pas
téléphone, c'était le téléphone sonne
sur euh C'est quoi France Interre ça ?
Non, téléphone sonne, ça vous parle ?
Téléphone sonne, je me rappelle c'était
téléphone et donc c'était par téléphone.
Donc moi j'étais en studio et lui il
était quelque part ailleurs dans un
bureau, je sais pas où, en voiture, sur
un portable, je sais pas. Et en gros, il
disait bah ce qu'ils disent toujours,
c'est-à-dire que non, vous comprenez,
ailleurs oui, ailleurs, d'accord, mais
en France, non. En France, non. On a
l'industrie la meilleure du monde et
comment vous pouvez dire ça ?
Il faut soutenir notre industrie et on
fait les efforts. Mais ça il le disait
en 2015 et il y a eu depuis 2015 et
maintenant il y a eu 10 ou 15 scandales
en France. Et si vous regardez le site
de que choisir moi que je regarde de
temps en temps, mais vous avez des
rappels tous les jours. Tous les jours
il rappelle des produits parce que dans
un il y a des sales monnelles, dans
l'autre il y a des listérias, dans
l'autre il y a un contaminant, dans
l'autre c'est la DLC qui va pas.
Il y en a combien qui passent dans tout
ça ? Beaucoup. Bah
la majorité passe. La grande majorité
passe. La très grande majorité des
produits qui ont des problèmes passent.
Pourquoi vous croyez qu'il y a des
centaines de milliers d'intoxications
alimentaires en France ? année. Pourquoi
vous croyez qu'il y a autant d'obèses en
France, autant de diabétique ? Enfin,
non, mais l'intoxication alimentaire et
l'obésité, ça rien à voir.
Bah, c'est un problème de qualité.
Après, on va vous dire que c'est les
gens se lavent pas les mains, c'est pour
ça qu'il y a des intoxications fois.
Enfin, il y a eu aussi des problèmes
d'intoxication dans des restaurants
parce que les produits étaient étaient
pas conformes.
Donc, revenons à nos politiques. Donc,
oui, donc contacté par absolument
personne. J'en avais juste croisé une
sur un plateau une fois, une écologiste,
je sais plus comment elle s'appelle, une
écologiste assez connue qui avait fait
une loi sur le bâtiment qui avait été
assez décriée.
Elle est brune avec des petites chrou
longs
assez court à l'époque,
comment elle s'appelle ? du flot, c'est
ça ?
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Donc, je l'avais rencontré sur un
plateau, il m'a dit "Oh, c'est super ce
que vous faites, vraiment, il faut qu'on
se parle et cetera et puis disparu,
c'est la seule et puis voilà." Ensuite,
non, plus aucune nouvelle.
Et mais
ça les intéresse pas, je suppose. Et
il est fonctionnair chargé de de du
contrôle, vous passez un coup de fil.
Par contre, en ce qui me concerne, je
leur rends hommage dans mon bouquin,
dans les deux bouquins
qui au politique,
non au contrôleur de terrain. C'est que
je les ai vu, j'ai discuté avec eux,
j'ai vu comment ils travaillaient. Et
c'est comme les policiers de terrain ou
les pompiers de terrain, ces gens-là
font leur boulot. Ils font leur boulot.
Ils sont payés souvent très mal pour
faire leur boulot et souvent ils croient
en ce qu'ils font. Ils essaient de le
faire bien comme tout à chaque on essaie
de faire son boulot à peu près
correctement en croyant servir au mieux
l'intérêt de ceux qui nous paient. Et
ces gens-là, bon enfin je pourrais leur
en vouloir parce qu'ils nous ont fait
quelques misères à l'époque, mais non,
ils font leur travail comme ils peuvent.
Seulement s'ils sont pas suivis par la
hiérarchie ou si les politiques qui font
les règlements les font les font en gros
pour leur tirer une balle dans le dos,
qu'est-ce qu'ils y peuvent ?
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on les qu'on
les sous-équipe à dessin ? Est-ce que
par exemple, c'est un peu comme le
ministère de la justice en Afrique, on
sous-dimensionne le ministère de la
justice comme ça, on regarde pas trop ce
qui se passe.
Bah, si c'était le cas, j'en serais pas
surpris. Oui, oui, oui. C'estàd que si
on cherche pas, on trouve pas. Donc si
on trouve pas, il y a pas de scandale. B
moi j'étais vraiment choqué. Regardez
dans mon dernier bouquin, il y a une
affaire qui s qui s'est passé en 2016 ou
17, c'est l'affaire des œufs au fiprony
dans les œufs.
Dans les œufs. Donc voilà. Donc ça faire
quand ça a démarré, moi ça m'a intéressé
parce que à l'époque quand je faisais
des mayonnaises, enfin avant dans mon
ancienne vie, je j'étais je travaillais
pour un des plus gros fabricants
européen de mayonnaise
avec que des œufs et que de l'huile. Du
moins que de l'huile, que des œufs et
que de la moutarde, un peu de sel,
du vinaigre aussi et puis ouais, c'est
quasiment tout. Bah la mayonnaise c'est
un produit particulier parce que c'est
un produit pas cher déjà donc c'est
difficile de fraude.
C'est pas cher parce que on on
Voilà c'est c'est 80 % d'huile la
mayonnaise donc 80 % d'huile il y a je
sais plus 8 ou 9 % d'œuf après du
vinaigre et puis voilà c'est un produit
pas compliqué.
Donc revenons à notre petit fipronil.
C'est quoi le fiprony ? Le fipronyl
c'est un poison qui sert à tuer les pou
qui enfin qui était utilisé pour tuer
les pou rouges des poules. C'est que
quand vous avez un élevage de poule,
l'élevage peut être assez vite ravagé
par des pou rouges. Donc les se met sur
les poules, c'est un parasite. Ça peut
ça peut transmettre des maladies, ça
peut même tuer les poules. Voilà. Et ça
ça fait baisser la production. Donc
c'est quelque chose que les voilà mais
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de traiter
les élevages parce qu'il y a peu de
produits qui sont efficaces parce que
forcément si les produits sont
efficaces, ça veut dire qu'ils sont
dangereux. Donc il sont dangereux peut
pas les utiliser. Donc vous voyez, c'est
un peu comme les les pesticides DT et
cetera. LDT est un produit fantastique
mais il est hyper dangereux. Donc et
c'est pour ça qu'on se passer du
glyphosate non plus. Glyphosate est un
produit dangereux mais fantastique.
Bref, donc ce fiprony est un produit
très efficace contre les peaux rouges.
Il a été interdit et bien sûr des petits
malins ont trouvé ont trouvé ça
astucieux de faire des formulations avec
du fipronyl. Donc les gens l'ont utilisé
et bien sûr le fipronil a contaminé les
œufs. Alors ce qui s'est passé c'est que
quand le scandale a a éclaté, donc moi
je je le décris en détail parce que je
l'ai vraiment suivi de près. Euh ça
s'est passé en Hollande. Les Hollandais
se sont rendus compte qu'il y avait un
problème. Le gouvernement de Hollande
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ? Rien. Surtout
silence complet. Pourquoi ? Parce que
s'il l'avait ramené à l'époque,
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé en Europe
? Tous les pays voisins auraient fermé
leur frontières aux œufs hollandais. Et
moi j'en ai acheté des œufs hollandais
princi enfin les gros pays producteurs
d'œuf c'est France, Allemagne, Hollande
et voilà c'est c'est les gros pays
producteurs d'œuf qui exportent
beaucoup. Enf c'est des quantités
impressionnantes.
Pourquoi impressionnantes ?
Moi j'en acheté des camions complets.
J'achetais par 20 tonnes et voilà c'est
les jaunes d'œuf enf de la coule d'œuf.
Vous en avez dans toutes les les
biscuits, dans dans la mayonnaise, enfin
dans tous les produits qui voilà où on
met traditionnellement de l'œuf quoi.
Donc ce sont des Ouais. des enfin ce
sont des des centaines et des milliers
de tonnes.
Donc revenons à la fermeture des
frontières.
Donc la la Hollande se rend compte qu'il
y a ce problème des fipronil. Bien sûr,
ils disent rien justement pour continuer
à exporter et puis essayer de régler le
problème en douce.
C'est quoi en douce ?
Bah c'est-à-dire qu' ils font une
enquête pour voir un petit peu d'où ça
vient, qui c'est, pourquoi il y a ce
fils, dans quels élevages et cetera.
Donc
il s'agit pour rassurer l'opinion
publique.
Non non, silence complet. Personne n'est
informé.
Quelques temps après, il y a un belge,
je crois. Ouais. Un belge.
Comment il s'appelle ? Ah, je saurais
pas vous dire, c'est dans mon bouquin.
Regardez, très bien fait et enfin très
détaillé, on va dire. J'ai vraiment
suivi ça deprès. Donc le belge se rend
compte qu'il y a un problème. Il fait
une ce que la loi lui impose à faire.
Quand vous quand vous êtes professionnel
et que vous sign que vous voyez un
problème, une contamination ou autre qui
peut être dangereuse pour la santé
publique, vous êtes obligé de faire une
déclaration. Ce gars-là fait sa
déclaration disant voilà dans mes
produits, dans mes œufs, j'ai trouvé du
fille. Donc ça commence à à à le
scandale commence à vous. Je suis
désolé, je je suis désolé. Quand il dit
"J'ai trouvé du filipronil", c'estàdire
qu'il l'a cherché parce que le fil ça ça
ça quoi ? C'est insipide. Il a il
saurait pas vous dire.
Bah il a forcément cherché. Oui. Oui.
Mais ça veut dire que peut-être lui a
fait un contrôle sur peut-être qu'il a
pas cherché spécifiquement le fipronine
mais peut-être tous les polluants qui
pouvaient être dedans. Vous fait une
recherche sur quand vous faites une
recherche sur les pesticides par
exemple, vous faites une recherche sur 6
ou 700 molécules.
Donc vous prenez un échantillon et vous
le mettez dans une machine qu'on appelle
un chromatogramme. Et cette machine
enfin une
un chromatographe et cette machine là va
vous analyser tous les composants
individuels et ensuite ça va apparaître
sous forme de pic et ces pics là enfin
du moment où ils apparaissent vous les
identifiez.
OK ? Revenons revenons au belgs ont
trouvé le fipronil. Quelle méthode ils
ont utilisé ? Pourquoi ils ont cherché
ça ? Je sais pas, j'ai pas trouvé
l'information mais bref, ils l'ont
trouvé, ils ont déclaré, donc il a fait
ce qu'il a devait faire, ce qu'il devait
faire. Donc il a déclaré les autorités,
les autorités qui ont commencé à faire
une enquête et ensuite c'est Lidl, donc
la chaîne de supermarché qui a commencé
à faire un rappel sur ses œufs parce que
bien sûr il y avait un problème.
Ils sont bien.
Oui, ils ont ils ont fait ce qu'ils
devaient faire, donc il un rappel et
cetera. Et c'est à ce moment-là que la
Hollande a dit "Ah oui, effectivement,
il y a un problème
de quel pleur ?"
Bah, à l'époque, personne savait trop
quoi. Donc voilà.
toujours toujours pareil, on dit bon bah
il y a un problème alerte et cetera.
Apparemment sur des eaux de Hollande, on
fait une enquête, on essaie d'identifier
d'où, quelle filière machin et on dit
dans les pays bah regardez si vous en
avez importé des produits d'ollande et
cetera. Alors ce qui se passe c'est que
bah en France bien sûr on vous dit pas
de problème, c'est en Hollande, c'est
que des pays étrangers. En France, il y
a rien eu d'importé. Et moi quand je
regarde, je tombe sur un sur le site du
ministère de l'agriculture et il y avait
ce qu'ils appelaient un un point de
situation pour les professionnels.
Donc je tombe là-dessus et je regarde
effectivement et je il y a la liste des
importateurs de ces produits-là. Donc je
vois qui en a importé et quelle
quantité. Il y avait une liste qui était
longue comme le bras. Il y avait j'avais
calculé c'était équivalent à peu près à
5 millions d'œufs.
C'est que j'avais pris le poids total de
de de liquide. Sachant qu'un œuf fait à
peu près 45 50 g. Je dis bon ben voilà,
je divise, paf, et ça fait à peu près 5
millions d'œufs. Et j'entendais non,
vous inquiétez pas, il y a rien du tout,
c'est juste sur des gaufres belges et
cetera.
Et là-dessus, il y a il y a il y a
Foodwatch que je suis régulièrement qui
disent "Mais on comprend pas, le
scandale, il a démarré il y a un mois ou
deux puis on a toujours pas d'info. Ils
sont où ces œufs ? Qui les a consommé ?
Qui les a importé ? Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ?" Et là sur le site du ministère,
pouf, le point date des professionnels
devient inaccessible.
Donc l'info, elle disparaît.
Je me dis, j'ai rêvé ou quoi ? Mais
c'est pas possible. Enfin, moi j'avais
eu le temps d'imprimer les trucs. Donc
je voilà, j'avais j'avais le truc et je
et donc je suis je suis retourné, j'ai
plus qu'à site qui sait qui fait des des
photos régulières de toutes les de
toutes les page. Voilà et je je les
retrouve et je me dis bon finalement si
j'ai regardé à nouveau effectivement on
avait importé en France à peu près 5
millions d'œufs contaminés au fipronil.
information connue par le ministère,
connu des professionnels mais cachés aux
journalistes, caché aux associés
consommateurs et caché et caché aux
consommateurs et le temps bah en
quelques mois en quelques semaines, en
quelques mois ces produitsl
disparaissent, sont consommés puis à la
fin il y a plus rien à voir. Et voilà
comment ça se passe, comment ça se
passait tout le temps, comment je
pensais que ça se passait plus et
comment effectivement ça continua à se
passer.
Vous avez gardé des contacts dans
l'industrie, donc vous avez sorti votre
bouquin. Je suis désolé de faire votre
prom
vous pouvez parce qu'on on n'est pas
nombreux à en parler. Le
le
vos anciens collègues, ils vous ont
appelé, votre ancien patron, il vous a
appelé, vous avez il vous a dit quoi ?
Euh j'ai eu deux de mes anciens
employeurs qui m'ont contacté pour me
menacer de procès simplement
la quand le premier bouquin est sorti,
le tout premier avant même qu'ils ont
connaissent le contenu puisque je c'est
c'est ils se sont basés sur des bonnes
feuilles qui étaient par dans le journal
Le Point une semaine avant l'apparution.
Donc ils savaient pas encore ce que je
disais précisément et ils avaient peur
que je parle d'eux, que je les nomme,
que je les cite et cetera. Donc à ce
moment-là, ils m'ont menacé de procès si
je les nommais si je les ai cité. Donc
on a bien fait attention de pas le faire
justement. Euh et suite à ça, il y a pas
il y a pas eu de suite.
Dans votre contrat, dans le contrat que
vous vous aviez signé chez eux, est-ce
qu'il y avait des clauses de Alors, on
connaît tous la clause de non
concurrence,
mais est-ce qu'il y avait des clauses de
t'ouvre pas ta gueule sur ce qu'on fait
?
Non, je pense pas. Je pense pas. J'ai
pas regardé mes contrats mais je ne
pense pas.
Et ensuite, si j'ouvre ma gueule mais
sans dire chez qui c'était, s'ils
veulent m'attaquer, ils peuvent le
faire. Mais dans ce cas-là, ce serait
reconnaître que ça se passait chez eux.
Donc c'est pas forcément dans leur
intérêt. C'est
c'est un coup de fil qui a duré 5 10 20
1 heure.
C'est pas non c'était pas c'était pas
long. C'était histoire de Alors c'était
assez drôle parce que le gars qui
m'appelait me disait voilà oui il enfin
ça c'était un petit peu au départ sur le
le ton du du reproche paternel. Tu te
rends pas compte du mal que tu nous fais
tu tout le monde ici est atterré. On
comprend pas entre guillemets après tout
ce que tu nous dois, tout ce qu'on a
fait pour toi.
Oui, vraiment le
traître quasiment
mais pas une seconde, il se il se posent
la question sur leur pratique, sur ce
qu'ils font, sur ce qu'ils ont fait et
comment ils pourraient faire mieux.
Est-ce que Est-ce que euh donc il pas
aucune conduite introspective chez eux ?
Bah non. Moi quand j'ai quand j'ai sorti
quand mon second bouquin est sorti par
exemple alors dans le premier bouquin
Lania avait fait un communiqué d'une
page dans quand le deuxième bouquin sort
il faut un un communiqué de trois ou
cinq pages. Alors c'est c'est déjà c'est
un progrès. Mais pour dire les mêmes
choses pour dire les mêmes choses
c'estàd qu'il y a pas de problème qu'on
a l'industrie la meilleure du monde que
ce que je dis ah oui s y a un truc qui
m'a fait rire c'est que ah vraiment si
ce qu'il dit est vrai il devrait aller
en prison.
Bah si ce que je dis est vrai, c'est pas
moi qui devrait aller en prison, c'est
plutôt mon patron et tous ceux qui
étaient voilà. Et si ce que je dis est
pas vrai, je vois pas pourquoi il y
aurait les scandales quasiment toutes
les semaines.
Donc c'est représentant enfin le
discours politique aujourd'hui qui est
de dire chez nous, il y a pas de
problème. On l'a vu mais tout le temps,
on l'a vu avec le Brisol, on l'a vu avec
le Fipronil, on l'a vu avec Ternobyl
Voilà à nous dire qu'il y a jamais de
problème mais plus personne ne les
croit. Qui croit encore les politiques
aujourd'hu un accident ? Non.
Lequel ?
Du brisol.
Oui, mais quand on vous dit que je sais
pas, moi j'ai j'ai lu je sais pas que
les que si les pompiers ont des taux
d'analyse qui sont pas bons, c'est que
peut-être ils étaient malades en
vendant. Enfin, il y a il y a il y a des
hydrocarbures dans le lait maternel.
Les hydrocarbures dans le lait maternel.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais hydrocarbure, c'est
les huiles minérales.
Oh,
c'est magnifique.
Donc, vous pouvez vous en servir soit
pour votre enfance, soit pour votre
voiture, c'est
alors la traçabilité, vous vous rappelez
de du scandale de la vache folle ?
Ouais.
On nous a bien bassiné sur maintenant
tout est traçad.
Mais non, mais non, mais non, mais non,
mais non. Avant tout était tracé déjà.
La traçabilité, elle a toujours existé.
La la traçabilité quand moi j'achetais
un lot avant, maintenant et demain,
parce que je suis encore dans
l'agroalimentaire, j'achète encore des
lots aujourd'hui. Quand j'achète un lot,
un produit, je sais d'où il vient, je
sais qui me l'a vendu. Il y a un numéro
de l'eau, il y a une date de péremption,
il y a une fiche technique, il y a des
documents avec. Tout ça, je les ai il y
a 10 ans, je les avais aussi. Il y a 20
ans, je les avais aussi quand j'ai
commencé. La traçabilité, elle existe.
La traçabilité c'est une obligation
depuis je sais plus depuis la nuit des
temps. Donc la traçabilité elle a
toujours existé pour la faire des
offriles. Ils avaient la traçabilité
mais ils ont pas voulu la communiquer.
Les grandes surfaces, elles ont réagi
par rapport à tout ça ? les grandes
surfaces, ben je suppose qu'elles ont
fait les rappels une fois qu'on leur a
communiqué le numéro de l'eau. Mais
c'est toujours c'est c'est pareil, c'est
une chaîne, c'est-à-dire que il faut que
les il faudrait que les pouvoirs
publics, les industriels et la grande
distribution travaillent main dans la
main quand il y a un scandale.
S'il y a s'il y a un des trois qui fait
pas le job, à ce moment-là, il y a rien
qui peut se faire.
Bon et et quand dans votre boîte, vous
étiez en contact avec le service
marketing ?
Tout le temps.
Oui, tout le temps. Oui. Ouais. Je enfin
oui. Oui, tout le temps.
Est-ce qu'on peut en parler ?
Bah oui, bien sûr.
Ça ressemble à quoi un service marketing
? dans la gr
ça ressemble à quoi ? Ça ressemble à
quoi ? Ouais mais nous on avait des on a
eu des phénomènes quand même. Donc ça
ressemble à quoi ? Enfin chez nous c'est
des gens très
marqué
chqu
c'est quoi la leur
Ouais mais je sais pas si des fois ils
croient pas vraiment dans ce qu'ils
font. Je sais pas trop. C'est c'est de
la communication. C'est bien présenter
le produit, c'est je sais pas je si
vraiment ils sont convaincus de ce
qu'ils font ou s'ils sont extrêmement
cyniques
ils sont honnêtes.
Non, enfin on peut pas être honnête
quoi. Enfin mais les les gens du
marketing chez moi n'avaient rien à
faire du tout du produit. Ils s'en
foutaient complètement du produit. Les
produits qu'on faisait par exemple, je
me rappelle du thé, ils ont ils ont
jamais goûté le thé qu'on faisait. Ils
en avaient rien à faire.
Donc le produit qu'ils étaient censés
vendre et venter et cetera, ils savaient
pas du tout ce que c'était. Il le
goûtait pas. Il n'avaient rien à faire.
Donc les gens qui faisaient du marketing
étaient payés pour faire pour faire une
tâche, pour faire un job et voilà, il y
a pas de conviction, il y a pas il y a
surtout pas de conviction dans le
marketing, certainement pas. Le but
c'est de vendre du produit, c'est du
travail de marchand de tapis.
Donc on voilà, on vous j'en parle j'en
parle beaucoup dans les dans les deux
dans les deux bouquins parce que c'est
toujours des choses qui m'ont qui m'ont
plus amusé que que choqué, on va dire.
C'est que vous vous importiez des
feuilles de thé.
Oui.
Et que vous simplement vous changiez la
boîte et et
on avait x boîte pour le Oui. pour les
mêmes thé. On faisait des formulations,
on le on leur mettait des logos
imaginaires, on leur mettait
C'est quoi les logos imaginaires ? C'est
quoi les formulations ? qualité
garantie, fraîcheur garantie, origine si
mais même les ce qu'on appelle les
allégations santé par exemple, les
allégations
les allégam les allicaments
pas les allicaments les allégations
c'estàd ce que une allégation c'est
quelque chose que vous que vous comment
dire
genre la canne berge ça réduit la
cistite
par exemple voilà ça c'est une
allégation santé prenez de la canne
berge vous aurez pas de cistitte ou
prenez vous avez une cite prenez la
canberge ça va s'arrêter il faut savoir
que ce genre d'allégation y compris pour
la canberge normalement depuis 12 le
règlement européen impose que ce soit
prouvé scientifiquement. Donc vous devez
vous en tant que fabricant de canberge
vous devez faire un essai des femmes qui
ont lait et qui l'ont pas, elles
prennent le caneberge, pas de canberge
et vous et vous soumettez vos résultats
en dire voilà on a prouvé l'effet de la
canberge sur assistite. Aujourd'hui, ça
n'a jamais été prouvé. Donc il n'y a pas
d'effet de la canneberge sur la
cistitte. Ça n'existe pas. C'est une
légende urbaine. Donc c'est sûr que si
vous buvez quand vous avez une cistique,
ça va finir par passer. Mais la
canneberge en aucun cas ne vous aidera.
Et c'est pareil, nous là où je
travaillais, on faisait par exemple, on
avait toute une gamme, plusieurs gammes
même pour nous et pour nos clients. Donc
on avait des des gammes pour x
supermarché, pour des parapharmacies par
exemple, il y a beaucoup de produits qui
se vendent en parapharmacie.
Et pour ces produitsl donc pour les
infusions, vous avez une liste à peu
près une cinquantaine de plantes
autorisées par la réglementation pour
ces produits-là. Et ces 50 plantes
autorisées sont autorisées hors du
monopole des pharmaciens parce qu'elles
n'ont pas d'effets.
Sinon, ce serait les pharmaciens qui les
vendraient si elles avaient un effet
thérapeutique. Donc, vous avez toutes
les plantes type vervine, tiul, reine
des prês, fleurs de bac, en tous ces
produits là, c'est gentil, c'est joli,
ça apporte du goût et que de cerise par
exemple. Bon, c'est sympa mais les
effets c'est peines. Tous les fabricants
qui ont essayé de prouver un effet n'ont
jamais réussi à en prouver un seul. La
camomie ça fait mieux dormir non ?
Quelle molécule dans la camomie vous
fait dormir ? Si demain vous trouvez la
molécule dans la camomie qui vous fait
dormir, vous déposez un dossier à LFa,
ils vous disent effectivement la comomie
s' fait dormir, vous m'avez vous me
l'avez prouvé, vous pouvez le marquer,
ça n'existe pas. Par exemple aussi, nous
on faisait des produits de détox. Ça
c'est un truc qui m'a toujours amusé.
J'en parlais avec mon gars du marketing.
J'ai dis détox. Mais qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire quoi détox ? Il y a détox de
quoi ? Qu'est-ce qui est toxique ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il est pas ? Tu vas
détoxifier de quoi ? Combien ? Ça veut
rien dire. détox. Tu intoxiqué à quoi ?
À la caféine, à la cocaïne, à la
nicotine,
aux huiles minérales.
Aux huiles minérales. Donc détox, c'est
une grosse arnaque. Mais moi, je allé au
supermarché encore il y a pas longtemps.
J'ai vu des produits détox, des produits
sommeil, des produits minceurs. Tout ça
c'est de l'arnaque. Tout ça c'est de
l'arnaque.
Pourquoi vous dites que c'est de
l'arnaque ? Parce que ça a pas été
prouvé scientifiquement.
Exactement. Exactement. La
réglementation, elle est claire. Alors,
ce qui se passe, c'est qu'elle est pas
appliquée aujourd'hui. Elle est
clairement pas appliquée parce que quand
le règlement a été mis en place en 2012,
ils ont laissé du temps aux industriel
de préparer les dossiers et de les
présenter. Et tant que la décision est
pas rendue, il y a
un un comment dire une tolérance enf qui
dure quand même depuis 2012.
Donc aujourd'hui, vous avez encore dans
notamment dans les magasins bio, je all
voir un magasin bio, j'ai vu des
produits détox. Un produit détox, c'est
une grosse produit détox bio.
Ouais, probablement. Oui, probablement.
Oui, bi enfin bon. Pas bon.
Quand vous faites vos courses, qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous fuyez à tout prix
?
Ah, c'est rapide.
C'est super. Bah oui, c'est super
rapide. C'estàd que je rentre dans le
supermarché parce que là où j'habite,
malheureusement, il y a pas beaucoup de
de circuit courts. Donc au supermarché
avec mon épouse. On va au rayon des
produits frais, fruits et légumes.
Vous habitez à Singapour ?
Ouais.
Vous gagnez combien en ce moment ?
Je
Trop peu. Trop peu. Mais j'ai Ça
m'embête de vous le dire. Ce sera
indécent.
C'est quoi ? 2000 balles 3000 balles
4000 balles 5000 balles 10000 balles
mo dans c e là
non d'accord c'est plus près de 10 ou
plus près de 6
plus près de la fourchette de haute que
de la fourchette basse
pour Singapour c'est un petit salaire
pour sa sing non pour Singapour c'est un
salaire correct c'est un salaire correct
mais rassurez-vous je gagnais autant
sinon plus avant donc et j'étais pas non
on reviendraz quand vous travaillez dans
quand vous avez un poste de direction
direction des achats ou autres dans une
grande entreprise les salaires sont
élevés hein donc
non dans l'industrie Il y a de l'argent,
il y a souvent beaucoup d'argent. Donc
les salaires sont pas sont pas les gens
qui sont mal payés sont les gens qui
sont c'est c'est drôle d'ailleurs. C'est
souvent les gens qui qui font tourner la
boîte, ils sont les plus mal payés. En
réalité,
c'est pas très drôle.
Non non, quand je dis drôle, ça veut
dire surprenant,
illogique. C'est que si demain les
petites mains s'arrêtent de travailler,
il y a rien qui sort. Si demain le
directeur général, il vient pas
travailler, tout tourne comme
d'habitude. Donc voilà. Et c'est vrai
que c'est Oui, c'est c'est souvent
indécent. Oui oui.
Donc revenons où vous faites vos
courses.
Donc les rayons frais, c'est
exentiellement là que je vais et on
achète des fruits, des légumes, du
poisson, des viandes et bio si on peut
en trouver, c'est pas toujours possible
mais quand c'est possible on en prend et
puis voilà, c'est ça se fait comme ça
quoi.
Et vous êtes jamais intéressé à ce qui
se passe ? Alors je sais pas ce qui se
passe en Asie
mais par exemple en en France, on on met
des produits sur les pommes pour les les
faire durer plus longtemps.
Ouais. Mais sur les agrumes aussi, on
met des on met des cires avec des
pesticides sur les agrumes. Oui. Sur les
oranges, sur les citrons. Oui. Ça, j'ai
visité par contre en Égypte une usine
qui faisait ça.
Et ça ressemble à quoi ?
Bah
les grands tuyaux, il y a quoi ?
Alors que je me souvienne en fait vous
avez
C'était où ? En Égypte ?
C'était à Alexandrie.
C'était à Alexandrie. Donc des produits
égyptiens. Le gars, il faisait des
artichauds parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'articha qui sont fait de qui sont
importés d'Égypte en France notamment.
il faisait Artichaud et il faisait
orange.
Euh alors que je me souvienne, il y
avait donc le produit étaient lavés et
ensuite dans un liquide,
il il mettait des cires et il mettaient
des produits antifongiques et il les
asperçait. Les asperceurs. Donc il y
avait des espèces de de rouleaux les les
oranges enfin étaient amenés sur des
rouleaux et étaient aspercé de ce
produitl donc ça enrobé l'orange. Et
ensuite ensuite je sais pas trop, j'ai
pas fait attention. Moi, j'achetais pas
ce produit là, j'étais venu pour les
artichauds et euh et voilà, ça se passe
comme ça.
Mais il y a des tests sur ce type de
molécules de cire, des tests sur les
antifongiques quand quand on voit avec
les les accords avec le Canada, quand on
voit les accords avec les États-Unis, il
y a des produits qui sont interdits au
Canada et il y a des produits qui sont
interdits en Europe, mais il y a des
produits pas interdits au Canada qui se
retrouvent dans notre chaîne
alimentaire.
Oui, mais c'est même pas la peine
d'aller jusque là-bas.
Dans mon dernier bouquin, je parle de ce
que je connais. pas pour en faire
19,90,
pas pour en faire la promo édition
Flamarion,
je sais pas mais prenez éventuellement
si c'est trop cher, prenez la version
poche, elle sera beaucoup moins cher
éventuellement trouvez en ailleurs,
faites-vous.
Vous en avez vendu combien ?
Euh du premier, on doit être je sais
plus dans les 70 800 je dirais. Et du
deuxième, je sais pas peut-être la
dernière fois que je m'étais renseigné
en étant les je sais pas 30000
peut-être, aujourd'hui peut-être 40, je
sais pas, j'en sais rien.
Continuons sur
enfin bref, donc on parlait oui des
molécules, ça c'est intéressant.
Aujourd'hui, sans aller sur le CTA ou
autre, restons en France. Et moi pour
écrire ce bouquin, j'ai regardé et c'est
c'est c'est intéressant parce qu'en fait
c'est disponible sur internet. Vous
allez les comprer-endus de la DGCRF.
Donc les compte-rendus des fraudes
DGCCRF, ça veut dire
direction générale de la concurrence de
et de la
la fraude,
c'est les fraudes. On appelait ça les
fraudes, c'était plus simple. Maintenant
GCRF, on sait même plus ce qu'il y a
derrière. Concurrence de la je sais
plus. Bref, bon les fraudes et ces
gens-là donc ils font des analyses, des
contrôles et ils font leur compte-rendu
annuel. Donc quand vous regardez le
contenu annuel, vous avez alors c'est
marrant, vous avez en France depuis tout
le temps et moi c'est les chiffres que
je connaissais aussi de nos contrôles à
nous sur nos produits 6 % de produits
donc fruits et légumes 6 % qui sont non
conformes au pesticides d'accord c'estàd
qui ont des pesticides au-dessus des
normes qui normalement devraient pas
être vendus 6 % et vous avez
qui sont quand même vendus
qui sont vendus parce que des
prélèvements supermarchés et moi c'est
les prélèvements que marchandise qu'on
recevait qui sont vendus et vous avez 2
% des produits fabriqués en France qui
contient des molécules interdites en
France
mais qui sont qui sont vendues
qui sont vendus. Oui, parce qu'en fait
c'est les fraudes, ell font des
prélèvement les analyses sur ce qui
trouve sur ce qui est disponible.
Oh 2 % c'est rien.
Bah 2 % oui mais enfin
ça va atterrir dans les chez les pauvres
s'en fout.
Chez les pauvres et les moins pauvres
chez les pauvres et les moins pauvres.
Mais euh pourquoi
vous dites chez les moins pauvres ?
parce que ça peut être
un jus un jus d'orange ou vous pouvez
enfin quand vous allez faire vos courses
au supermarché un pauvre ou un pas pour
pauvre, il va acheter des oranges pareil
je suppose des oranges ou d'autres
produits. Donc celui qui veut faire
bien, il va se dire "Allez, je vais
éviter les produits industriels parce
que c'est plein de saleté. Je vais faire
je vais prendre des produits naturels,
enfin des produits bruts, je vais faire
ma soupe de légumes, je vais faire et
cetera." Si ces produits là ils sont
pourris en pesticides, il va les avaler,
il va les consommer. Donc qu'il soit
pauvre ou pas, c'est c'est pas c'est pas
du tout le sujet quoi quelque part.
un pauvre ou un riche, il devrait avoir
les mêmes droits à la même nourriture de
qualité.
Donc et voyez ces molécules, ces
péicides et cetera se retrouvent sur
tous les produits. C'est c'est pas
spécialement les produits, c'est pas que
sur les pommes de terre, je veux dire,
c'est aussi sur les sur les fraises, sur
les fraises de la contreaison ou du
chili ou d'ailleurs sur les cerises, sur
enfin tous ces produitsl sont les herbes
fraîches, les produits les plus les plus
contaminés, ces produitsl sont souvent
pourris de pesticides et 6 % sont hors
norme, devrait devrait pas être vendu. 2
% des produits fabriqués en France
contiennent des pesticides interdits en
France et ça je sais d'où il les trouve.
Et le reste des produits suivant les
produits entre 60 et 80 % contiennent
des pesticides en général entre en
moyenne trois pesticides mais dans les
normes. Donc voyez ça veut pas dire que
les produits en ont pas ils ont des
pesticides. Quasiment tous les produits
en supermarché ont des pesticides en
général en dessous d'un certain seuil
mais 6 % dépasse ce seuil.
Alors donc dans les autres produits
frais, il y a la viande.
Oui.
Donc est-ce que vous avez vu des trucs
genre un peu crac cra par exemple en
Afrique ? en Afrique qui mange le coup
des poulets pour faire grossir les
seins. Vous savez pourquoi ?
Non.
Parce qu'on fait les injections
d'hormones dans le cou des poulets.
Ah oui,
ça intéressant.
C'est intéressant. Non, je savais pas.
Franchement, je savais pas. Et mais
c'est ce vrai ce qui est drôle pour les
poulets, moi je dis en Asie, c'est vrai
que les les asiatiques sont friants de
peau de poulet et de pâtes de poulet.
Donc vous voyez, il des habitudes
alimentaires qui diffèrent suivant les
pays. Mais je suis pas très à l'aise
pour vous parler des viandes parce que
je vous dis à part les produits
intermédiaires transformés comme les
lardons, les jambons, personnellement,
j'ai pas acheté beaucoup de viandes,
donc je suis pas un spécialiste des
viandes.
Parlons un peu des lardons.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe chez les lardons
?
Chez les lardons, bah c'est un produit
c'est un produit de charcuterie. Donc ce
sont des des viandes qui sont traitées
en salaison. Donc les vins traités en
salaison, ça veut dire que elles vont
être souvent euh fumées, cuites,
euh on va souvent retrouver des produits
comme les nitrates, nitrites, phosphate
et cetera et cetera. Donc des des
selles. Oui, sont des des produits qui
en général sont pas les produits les
plus naturels. Et on dit d'ailleurs que
les études qui avaient été faites
le lobby de de la charcuterie va monter
au créneau là.
Oui, mais enfin aujourd'hui on en est on
en est on a dépassé ce s là puisqueil y
a beaucoup d'études qui ont démontré que
consommer de la viande rouge était
nocif. Sûr parce que là moi j'ai vu j'ai
vu une étude où qui disait que il
fallait manger de la viande rouge.
Bah le problème ça dépend de quoi on
parle en fait.
C'estàd que si vous prenez un steak de
viande rouge, d'accord, que vous le
faites cuire dans des conditions
normales, c'est sans trop le cuir, sans
pas au barbecue et cetera, il y aura
certainement pas de problème. Ce qui va
poser problème, c'est les molécules que
vous allez générer par une mauvaise
cuisson. Au barbecue, par exemple, vous
allez carboniser un petit peu votre
viande et vous allez créer ce qu'on
appelle des des des composés aromatiques
type nitrosamine, type acrylamine dans
les frites par exemple. Et vous allez
générer des des molécules cancérigènes.
Donc vous allez pas avoir un can fin.
Les produits cancérigènes sont pas sont
pas directement ils viennent pas
directement de la viande. C'est souvent
le mode de cuisson ou alors dans les
charcuteries le mode de production avec
les nitrates et nitrites qu'on va
rajouter. Donc ce qui va vous
empoisonner c'est pas la viande en
elle-même, c'est souvent ou la cuisson
ou les additifs ajoutés.
Et et pourquoi les industriels se
défendent en disant voilà nous on a des
études qui prouvent exactement le
contraire. C'est pour semer le doute,
c'est pour défendre le business. C'est
parce que ils ont peut-être raison.
Bah je suis quand même surpris parce que
quand on prend les études enfin les
études de l'INCERME par exemple, c'est
quand même des études qui sont hyper
sérieuses, hyper documenté. Enfin, il a
pas il lâche pas ce genre de bombe sans
s'être assuré, surassuré, vérifier,
double confirmer que que les que les
produits enfin que les études sont sont
correctes. Et il y a maintenant beaucoup
d'études qui sortent ce genre de choses.
On sait la crry par exemple pour les
chips, on sait que de l'acrylamide se
forment quand on fait frire les frites.
Donc il y a pas de débat là-dessus. On
sait que une frite qui contient de la
crryamide est cancérène.
Donc il y a il y a pas de débat.
Personne aujourd'hui va dire le
contraire. Bon, c'est pas c'est
aujourd'hui c'est passé un peu de mode.
Plus personne n'y fait vraiment très
attention. Mais euh dans les
charcuteries, on sait que les nitrates,
nitrites et cetera, oui, sont nocifs.
Une question d'internet. Que vaut le
label bio selon lui aujourd'hui ?
Le label bio alors le label bio, ça veut
dire en fait que le produit répond au
cahier des charges biologiques.
C'est quoi le cahier des charges
biologiques ? C'est c'est là où je
voulais en venir. C'està-dire que
aujourd'hui, il faut pas demander à un
produit bio autre chose que ce qui est
indiqué dans le cahier des charges. Donc
un produit bio, donc il va avoir une
liste de pesticides, enfin de produits
chimiques interdites.
Euh pour les produits transformés, il y
aura moins d'additifs. Donc les produits
bio, c'est de mémoire une cinquantaine
d'additifs contre, je vous ai dit plus
de plus de 400 pour les les produits
conventionnels. un produit bio, il aura
normalement moins d'additifs, moins de
pesticides,
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il a pas
d'additif du tout et pas de pesticides
du tout. Puisqu'on sait très bien, on
parle souvent du
euh des des sulfates sulfat de cuivre.
Le sulfate de cuivre est autorisé en bio
alors que beaucoup de gens vous disent
que le sulfat de cuivre, c'est pas du
tout inoffensif. Donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut pas attendre du bio plus que ce
qu'il est prêt à donner. Ça c'est un
premier point. Et ensuite quand on parle
du bio, c'est il faut faire aussi
attention à ce qu'on achète.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut faire attention
à acheter aussi local parce que moi
j'étais choqué une fois où j'ai trouvé
de la farine de sarasin bio orté de
Chine.
Donc je comprends qu'on fasse puisque en
France on produit dans les 10000 tonnes
de Sarasin Bio et on en consomme dans
les 40000. Donc il y a il y a il y a un
gap de 30000 qu'il faut combler puisque
la demande est là. Donc on importe de
Chine du bio mais on le fait voyager sur
des milliers de kilomètres. Donc au
niveau empreinte de carbone, c'est
catastrophique.
Ouais, mais ça ça touche pas le bio.
C'est c'est euh
Bah ce que je veux dire, c'est que
souvent on va vous dire "Ah oui, mais le
bio machin, c'est pas logique,
l'empreinte carbone et cetera." Oui,
mais c'est pas parce qu'un produit est
bio, il faut il faut pas du tout comment
dire
peut-être moins là, on parle pas
d'empreinte carbone, attention de pas
d'accord, mais un produit bio est plus 5
qu' un produit conventionnel si si on si
on si on peut résumer puisque
logiquement il y a moins de péicide et
moins de polluant. À ce niveau-là, il
sera plus sain pour le consommateur. Il
sera également mieux pour
l'environnement puisqu'on va balancer
moyen de pesticides.
Je me refais l'avocat du diable. Mais
les autres produits, ils sont sains
parce qu'ils sont vendus. Wouh
!
S'ils étaient pas sains, ils seraient
pas vendus. Bon, alors mis à part le
tabac, l'alcool et je vous en passer les
meilleurs. C'est c'est c'est de la pâtie
à ce niveau-là.
Du quoi ? Du Jean-Michel.
Du Oui, du Jean-Michel, le fameux. On
peut pas le faire avec l'accent du
sud-ouest.
On le connaît bien Jean-Michel. On lui
passe le bonjour d'ailleurs.
Viens nous voir Jean-Michel. On on va on
va discuter de de tes tes petits dîners.
Ah
de l'Assemblée nationale ou
Ouais, on va on tiens vous on va enf on
va parler de Omar des fruits de mer. Il
y a 25 % des des fruits de mer en France
qui sont chargés à l'eau. Vous
confirmez, vous infirmez ? Bah, c'est
difficile de dire à 25 %, ça dépend
beaucoup des produits. Euh moi dans
quand j'avais regardé les études qui
avaient été faites, les plus les
produits les plus contaminés, c'est
souvent les produits les moins chers,
notamment les filets de panga, le
pangasus, les filets qui sont fabriqués
au Vietnam et autres. Souvent, ces
produits-là sont sont gonflés à l'eau à
plus de 30 % largement.
C'est légal ?
Non, c'est pas légal. Ah non, non, c'est
pas légal. C'est pas légal.
Si vous voulez, il y a quelques années,
un distributeur, je veux pas le citer
parce que je suis plus sûr du nom, mais
c'est pareil si dans mon premier
bouquin, avait fait une étude pour
savoir quelle était la tenore normale en
eau d'un filet de poisson. Ah ça paraît
concore en eau d'un filet de poisson ?
Est-ce que c'est 10 % 15 % 20 % 25 % ?
On en sait trop rien. Et puis c'est
pareil, ça va dépendre de l'âge du
poisson, de là où il est pêché. Est-ce
qu'il a été pêché surgelé rapidement ?
Pas rapidement, il va perdre de l'eau,
pas perdre de l'eau, on sait pas trop.
Donc ils avaient fait pendant des mois
avec le gouvernement, enfin avec une un
organisme officiel, ils avaient fait des
analyses de de d'humidité sur plein de
filets de poisson et ils avaient dit bah
voilà le filet de Colin, c'est entre je
sais plus entre 18 et 22. Le filet de 6
c'est entre temps et temps. Et après ils
étaient allés avec ces avec ces chiffres
là, donc avec des choses qu'ils avaient
mesuré sur des produits qui savaient
être conforts mais ils avaient mesuré,
ils avaient trouvé des teneurs en eau
sur des filets de panga notamment qui
étaient qui étaient extravagantes.
Question internet, comment on gonfle en
eau à l'eau ? Alors ça dépend des
produits. Les produits,
c'est des injections, c'est des pains
avec des petits produits. Alors on on
explique
de les deux. C'estàd que pour des
produits qui se gonfle facilement,
typiquement la Saint-Jacques. Moi, j'ai
vu la Saint-Jacques, c'est vous mettez
des saint-jaques fraîches dans un dans
un bain et la Saint-Jacqu, elle va
gonfler toute seule. Donc voilà.
Et dans le bain, il y a quoi ? Il y a de
l'eau de mer.
Il y a de En général, c'est un mélange
avec de l'eau et il y a aussi des
texturants et des produits qui
permettent de de garder l'eau parce que
si vous voulez sortez du bain, l'eau
l'eau elle repart.
Ouais, mais c'est des texturants
naturels,
non ? du du phosphate. Alors à une
époque il mettaient des phosates et
après ils ont changé pour des citrates
parce que un moment on cherchait les
phosfates. Donc il y a des produits
C'est intéressant ça. C'est que
l'industriel
Ah s'adapte
s'adapte à quoi ? S'adapte au contrôle.
S'adapte au oui absolument. Bien sûr. Ah
c'est c'est lour ce que vous dites quand
même.
Un truc qui est marrant qui est qui est
intéressant si vous voulez que j'ai
retracé
je sais plus dans lequel d'ailleurs, le
l'évolution de la fraude au miel de
Chine. Ça c'est un truc que j'ai que
pareil j'ai suivi, c'était mon dada. Et
les Chinois quand ils ont commencé à
faire des fraudes, ils ont fait des
fraudes basiques, des fraudes entre
guillemets peu élaborées. Ils ont pris
du miel. Le miel c'est un antibiotique
naturel. On sait que jusqu'à 18 19 %
d'eau, ça tient. Donc quand ils avaient
la chance d'avoir des miels à 14 15, ils
savaient qu'il pouvaient mettre 3 4 5 %
d'eau. Donc il le faisait, il mettait de
l'eau, il mélangeait et cetera. Après,
ils sont rendus compte que s'il pouvait
en mettre un peu plus, c'était mieux et
que si on en mettait un peu plus,
c'était mieux avec des antibiotiques.
Donc ils ont mis des antibiotiques dans
le miel et un peu plus d'eau. Et à cette
époque-là, attends attendsendsends
attends attends attends.
Pourquoi ? Attends, attends. Là là là,
tu es en train de me dire faire
le miel. Ça ça se fait plus. Je te
raconte l'histoire. Ça c'est l'histoire.
C'est en quelle année ça ? C'était juste
avant que le miel chinois, enfin que les
produits animaux chinois dont le miel
soit interdits en Europe. Alors je sais
plus mais sur internet vous pourrez
facilement le retrouver. Il y a une
année où les produits des chinois ont
été bannis d'Europe une seule année.
Donc voilà, c'est et là et c'était
justement à cause d'antibiotiqu qu'on
trouvait dans dans le miel et dans
d'autres produits. C'était aussi dans
les dans les crevettes enfin il
chargeait tout en eau, il mettait de
l'antibiotiques.
Mais là, tu étais en train de me dire
que le miel il était chargé en
antibiotique pour que
pour pour pas que ça fermente.
Oui, l'antibiotique c'est un
antibiotique.
Donc contre les bactéries. Si tu mets
trop d'eau, le produit il est plus
stable. Donc il faut un ce qu'on appelle
un conservateur. Un antibiotique c'est
un conservateur.
En général, on met pas d'antibiotiques,
on met des conservateurs type et donc
les les mégatones de de miel que tu
faisais revenir en Europe,
c'était sous forme brut brut genre
Oui, c'était des fus des fus de 200 kg,
des fus type fus de de
Et donc là, on s'imagine tous le miel
qui va aller dans le petit pot de miel
avec la petite ruche, tu vois.
D'accord. Mais est-ce que ce miel-là est
utilisé pour faire par exemple une
tisane euh goût miel euh euh des des
petits pots pour bébés avec du miel
dedans ?
Non, je pense pas. Pour une tisane
goumiel, vous avez des arômes.
D'accord.
Donc quand on a un produit goumiel, on
va pas s'embêter à mettre du miel, on
met un arôme, c'est plus facile.
La différence entre goût, saveur et tous
ces petits mots, c'est quoi ?
Goût, saveur ? Alors là, je sais pas,
revoir la réglementation. Revenons à
notre histoire d'ation avec le miel.
c'est que donc les Chinois ont ils ont
commencé par rajouter de l'eau. Ensuite
quand c'était quand c'est devenu quand
ça a été interdit et cetera, ils ont
arrêté mais ils ont commencé à couper
avec du sucre.
Donc le miel, il faut savoir que c'est
essentiellement du glucose et du
fructose et que ça il y a par type de
miel, il y a un ratio. C'estd que il y a
par exemple, je dis n'importe quoi mais
2/3 de fructose, un tiers de glucose par
exemple. Donc ils ont commencé à mettre
un et deux produits, ils ont commencé à
mettre du glucose. Puis finalement nous
on s'en est rendu compte. Alors, on a
commencé à contrôler parce que quand
même il y a trop de glucose dans ce
produit là. On leur a dit arrêtez les
gars de rajouter du glucose. Donc, ils
ont arrêté mais ils ont rajouté du
fructose. Donc comme ça ça rééquilibré.
Donc là, ça passait mieux. Ensuite quand
c'est quand quand les tests ont été
commencés à être un petit peu plus
poussés, on s'est rendu compte que dans
leur miel, il y avait quasiment pas de
pollen. Quand on regarde au microscope,
normalement dans du miel, c'est bourré
de pollen. Et c'est comme ça qu'on sait
de quel type de miel c'est. par exemple
pour savoir si c'est un miel de romarin
de lavande et cetera, on regarde un
microscope et on voit des pollenes tiens
ça c'est un pollen de lavande. Donc il y
a plus de 30 % de pollenes de lavande
donc c'est du miel de lavande. C'est ça
la réglementation.
Euh donc on s'est dit il y a pas assez
ou il y a pas du tout de pollen c'est
quand même louche.
C'était en 2010 pour le miel
antibiotique dit nous dit Raoul Duc.
Voilà donc voilà probablement donc
c'était pile poil pile poil les les
époques que j'ai connu. Donc voilà. Et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ensuite ? Ils
ont rajouté du pollen. Donc ce qui est
marrant avec les Chinois, c'est queils
ont enf dans cet exemple là, mais on
pourrait on pourrait le multiplier pour
d'autres, c'est queils ont suivi
l'évolution des contrôles que faisaient
leurs clients.
Ils sont adaptés.
Donc là, voyez, on s'est adapté pareil
aussi pour le trempage. On mettait du
phosphate à une époque. Quand on se dit,
il y a du phosphate là-dedans, ils ont
enlevé le phosphat, ils ont mis du
citrate.
Mais si si.
Donc pour finir avec ta première
question qui était comment est-ce qu'on
fait gonfler de enfin gonfler à l'eau ce
produit là ? Donc soit par trempage
quand c'est possible, mais la plupart du
temps c'est pas possible. Donc soit par
injection, soit par injection par
exemple avec des aiguilles ou soit par
injection dans des enceintes
pressurisées. Nous c'est ce qu'on
appelle le saturateur.
C'est légal ?
Non c'est pas légal.
C'est pas légal mais ça se pratique
beaucoup en fait si tu veux. Donc quand
je te rappelle de cette étude qui avait
c'est une é une étude qui s'appelait
fraude filet. C'est un nom revient
fraude filet. Donc tu vois, c'était
vraiment il savaiit de quoi il parlait.
Ils étaient voilà, il y av c'était dans
le nom. Ils voulaient vérifier que ils
sont rendus compte que les filets de
poisson étaient très fraudé. À l'époque,
on parlait de 30 à 40 % de fraude quand
même par ajout d'eau. Donc ils sont dit
bon, on va regarder et cetera. Donc ils
ont fait ces fraude filet. Alors pareil,
vous pouvez regarder sur internet, vous
la trouvez sûrement. Et
c'est comme ça qu'ils sont rendus compte
que la plupart des filets étaient
gonflés. Donc soit on peut les gonfler
le produit lui-même, soit on peut le
recouvrir de glace aussi. C'est ce qu'on
appelle le glaçage, le glazing. Alors le
glazing par contre c'est autorisé
puisque c'est une technique qui
normalement permet de protéger le
produit.
C'est quand le le filet de poisson
surgelé il est bien br bien bien
brillant.
Ouais. Quand il est bien brillant mais
c'est tout produit surgelé. Ça peut être
filet de poisson, ça peut être des
champignons, ça peut être tout produit
surgelé peut être recouvert d'une
normalement c'est une fine pellicule de
glace pour empêcher qu'il sèche parce
que si tu mets un produit au frigo,
l'air est très sec en fait et il va
finir par déshydrater petit à petit. Il
va quasiment seophiliser en fait. Donc
pour pas que le produit se se sèche, on
le recouvre d'une fine pellicule d'eau.
Mais normalement quand on vous vend le
produit, on est censé considérer le
poinette. C'est que si je prends 1 kg de
crevette, je te prends 1 kg de crevette
en poinette et je te rajoute l'eau de
glaçage mais je te vends toujours 1 kg.
Alors il y a des petits malins, je me
serais entendu dire qui vendrai 1 kg de
poids brut avec l'eau compris pour 1 kg
de poids net. Il y a des gens encore
plus malins, je me suis laissé entendre
dire qui gonfleraient ses crevettes avec
de l'eau.
Mais
c'est extrêmement fréquent.
Tu vas acheter un un sachet dans un
supermarché de premier prix de crevettes
et de de noix de Saint-Jacques, tu
l'effect cuiras à la poêle et tu verras
ce qui te resteras à la fin.
Oui, je te rassure même pas que sur les
premiers prix.
Même pas que sur les premiers prix, mais
sur les premiers prix, tu es quasiment
sûr d'en trouver. Alors que sur les
produits chers, tu peux avoir des bons
produits. Tu peux avoir si tu as de la
chance de tomber sur des bons produits.
Bon,
revenons à à notre supermarché. Donc les
courses, vous faites vos courses où ? Tu
fais tes courses où ?
Supermarché.
Mais que donc le le le trajet c'est tu
évites tout ce qui est épice en poudre,
tu évites quoi d'autre ? Bah là où on
est, dans le magasin où on va, ils ont
ouvert un rayon bio il y a peu de temps.
Donc c'est
Quand tu es en France, tu vas faire quoi
? Tu vas où ?
Quand je suis en France, alors il y a
deux choses. Quand j'habitais en France,
j'avais mes filières donc je m'étais
organisé. J'avais mon petit producteur
qui on avait un producteur qui livrait
du bœuf, un autre qui livrait du foie
gras.
J'habitais tout près du Mventou. Donc il
y a des élevages de port dans le ventou.
Donc j'achetais mon port à ces élevages
là. Même des fois c'était compliqué
parce qu'il fallait qu'on prenne un port
entier, qu'on se le découpe et qu'on se
le partage. Donc c'était j'étais au sud
de la drôme puisque c'est le Vluse et
dans la drôme ils font de l'agneau. Donc
on avait une filière aussi pour de
l'agneau. Et à côté de chez moi, il y
avait une ferme qui vendait directement.
Donc tout ce que je pouvais prendre, je
le prendrais. Je le prenais chez eux et
ce que je pouvais pas trouver là, bah je
le prenais essentiellement au
supermarché. Parce qu'aujourd'hui où
est-ce que vous voulez trouver vos
produits à part là.
Et aujourd'hui, là où j'habite,
malheureusement, il y a pas ces filières
courtes, elles existent pas. Donc on va
au supermarché en prenant des produits
frais et des produits bio dans la mesure
où on en trouve.
Une question de Philou 88. Quelles sont
les tolérances officielles sur le poids
annoncé sur poids réel ?
Alors là, ça c'est une question qu'il
faudrait poser à quelqu'un de la
qualité.
Il y a une tolérance qui est assez
faible.
Euh l'industriel, il y a une il y a une
norme. Donc si vous cherchez la norme
sur les poids, vous allez la trouver et
c'est un calcul statistique.
Donc Raoul Ducant, c'est entre 95 et
2002. Bon, on continue.
Non, il y a une il y a une norme pour
ça. Vous faites pas ce que vous voulez.
Et c'est quand vous avez le petit E à la
fin, vous savez quand vous avez le poids
net et un petit E, ça veut dire que
l'industriel a contrôlé son poids et qui
garantit que le produit est bien dans le
poids. Donc il y a une tolérance sur les
produits. Alors je saurais pas vous dire
à combien c'est en pourcent mais je
crois que c'est même c'est même plus
compliqué que ça. En fait vous avez une
distribution gosienne et en fonction du
nombre de produits, c'est il y a un
écart-type qui est défini à ce
moment-là. Donc l'industriel il le
définit et il définit des tolérances.
Une question. Quelles sont les
conséquences pour les entreprises
lorsqu'une fraude est découverte ? autre
chose qu'une amende.
Moi, j'ai pas connu j'ai pas connu
personne se faire la la moi le seul la
seule affaire qui où j'ai entendu parler
de procès et autres, c'est celle des
lasagnes justement avec l'affaire enfin
les gens de chez Spanguero qui ont été
inquiétés. Je sais même pas s'il y a eu
des condamnations après. Euh je sais
qu'il y avait eu aussi un procès pour
l'affaire lactalise. Vous savez quand il
y a eu les contaminations de salmonell.
Mais en règle générale les gens se font
pas réellement attraper
et quand ils se font attraper quelque
part on s'arrange quoi.
Si on s'arrange pourquoi ? Parce qu'il
faut pas faire de French bashing, il
faut protéger les emplois. C'est du
chantage à l'emploi. C'est quoi ?
Non, je pense pas. Je pense que l'état
quels emplois quelles conséquences si
les prenil par exemple. Attendez,
attendez la le quand quand je dis ça, je
dis en ce moment, il y a beaucoup de
pauvres et il y a il y a de plus en plus
de pauvres d'ailleurs là, il y a un
papier du monde euh qui qui le
soullignait aujourd'hui.
Et on a un peu moins de 10 millions de
pauvres en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
en France. Euh est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une démarche consciente des
politiques de laisser faire de la bouffe
pas chère pour que les ordes de pauvres
ne s'excitent pas ? Parce que quand il
n'y a plus de foin dans les rateliers,
les chevaux se battent.
Je pense qu' c'est plutôt ça en fait. Je
pense que c'est la la logique est plutôt
là.
Si on part à mon avis, enfin c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué que ça.
Je pense par exemple au miel de Chine.
C'est un produit qui est fraudé. Tout le
monde le dit. Il y a même des députés
français. Dernièrement, j'avais vu un
article qui disait "Il faut arrêter avec
ce miel frodé chinois." Et il y avait
aussi des députés européens qui disaient
"Il faudrait quand même qu'on fasse le
ménage dans ce miel frodé chinois." Donc
tout le monde le sait, tout le monde le
dit. Par contre, on fait rien. Première
chose, on fait rien. Pourquoi ? Parce
que c'est pas dangereux, c'est du sucre.
Donc à la rigueur, il y a il y a jamais
d'urgence pour traiter ce genre de
problème. Il y a il y aura pas demain
quelqu'un qui va tomber malade, qui va
mourir parce qu'il aura mangé du du
sucre. C'est c'est une arnaque.
C'est une arnaque. Mais si vous êtes un
homme politique, est-ce que c'est
vraiment un problème que vous allez
régler dans la minute quoi. Vous allez
peut-être le laisser au suivant. Vous en
foutez en fait en réalité c'est pas
dangereux.
Ensuite effectivement, comme tu le dis,
moi quand j'acheté du miel de Chine, je
le payais 1 € du kilo. 1 € du kilo,
c'est impossible. Quand quand quelqu'un
propose un miel à 1 € du kilo, je sais
que c'est pas du miel. C'est genre pas
la peine de faire la more analyse. Je
sais que c'est pas possible un miel à 1
€ du kilo ou un dollar du kilo comme je
le payais à l'époque. Donc j'achète un
produit à 1 dollar, je le transforme, je
paye mon conditionnement, mes pertes,
mon emballage et cetera. Je revends ça
au supermarché, je sais pas à 2 dollars
ou enfin ou à 2 € pardon ou à 2,50 €. Le
supermarché va le transporter, faire sa
marche, ses promotions et cetera, il va
le vendre à 5 € 5 6 € le kilo.
Donc donc voilà. Enfin, c'est pas du
miel,
c'est de l'argent vite fait.
Ouais. Ouais. Oui, ben oui, on fait des
Moi, j'avais des contrats jusqu'à 400
tonnes quand même. En pot de 1 kg, c'est
hyper facile quoi. Fait un conditionner
du pot de 1 kg en verre, c'est hyper
simple. Ça va super vite. Ça prend c'est
automatisé. Euh, prend les fus, on les
retourne, paf, ça ça coule, ça se
remplit, c'est hyper simple. Donc voilà,
tout le monde est content. Même un truc
qui est plus marrant, tiens, je vais te
dire
qui tout le monde le consommateur.
Consommateur, il en sait trop rien en
fait.
Celui qui va acheter ce pot de miel à la
rigueur, il va avoir un goût de miel
parce qu'il y a du rôme dedans. Il y a
de l'arôme miel. Donc quand il va
l'utiliser, il verra même pas la
différence. Il saura pas qu'il y a du
sucre.
Donc lui le consommateur final qui va
acheter ça, il a l'impression qu'il va
acheter du miel pour pas cher et il aura
un sirop de glucose aromatisé au miel
qui est un produit que je je connais
bien puisquon en fabriqué de ça aussi.
Non, mais aromatisé au miel, c'est goût
miel avec des des adjuvents des
adjuvents chimiques.
Mais à la rigueur, on le sait pas parce
que c'est vendu pour du miel donc on
sait pas ce qu'il y a dedans. Il y a que
le chinois qui le sait ou alors Europ
les ont analysé mais bon ça je sais pas,
j'ai pas j'ai pas les analyses sous les
yeux, je sais pas ce qu'il y a dedans.
Le sucre qui mettent dedans, je sais
même pas à partir de quelle plante ils
l'ont fait. Le c'est capable de vous le
dire. Est-ce que c'est du sucre de
céréales à partir de blé, de maïs, de
riz, ça ils le savent.
Non, en général dans ces pays là.
Mais bon bref, ce que je veux dire c'est
que
on sait pas réellement ce qu'il y a
dedans puisque c'est pas déclaré. Donc
c'est vraiment une fraude organisé par
les Chinois avec la compété de l'État
parce que enfin les volumes sont
tellement gigantesques, les ça se fait
tellement ouvertement,
c'est tellement su partout que c'est pas
possible que ce soit autrement. En
Chine, vous pouvez pas aller pisser sans
demander l'autorisation au gouvernement.
Donc il y a des caméras partout, j'ai
compris dans les urines. Donc c'est une
fraute enfin c'est organisé au niveau de
l'État. Je pense que ça aussi ça joue.
C'estàd qu'il y a un jeu
au niveau de l'État. C'est c'est lourd
comme accusation.
Mais non mais il y a plein de choses. Il
y a
plein de choses. Alors d'autres
exemples.
Si on parle de la tomate par exemple la
tomate la tomate de Chine alors moi j'en
acheté beaucoup puisquon était je veux
dire un des un des plus gros producteurs
européens de ketchup. Donc, j'acheté des
des milliers de tonnes de tomates par an
de con de tomates de Chine et euh et en
Chine, c'est fait dans les dans les
Sjang, c'est fait euh à la frontière
avec la Mongolie intérieure. Donc entre
la les usines de production et le port,
il y a plus de 3000 km.
Le transport, il est payé par l'État.
Les gens qui fabriquent, il y a deux Il
y a deux gros conglomérats qui gèrent la
potion de tomate en Chine. Ça vous
pourrez lire le livre de de Malais,
l'Empire de l'or rouge, par exemple.
C'est moi qui a fait la préface pour son
édition italienne. Et ben, il y a deux
il y a deux fabricants, c'est Kovko et
Chalqis. Shalkquis qui a arraché le
cabanon en France entre parenthèses. Et
c'est ces ces deux structures sont des
émanations de l'armée populaire
et le le le patron de Shalkis c'était le
général Liudju. Donc c'est et les
employés de Shalkis ce sont des
commandants, des colonels, des enfin
c'est c'est une entreprise d'état qui
qui est organisée par les militaires.
D'accord. Côté français.
Côté français, bah côté français, on se
dit mais est-ce que ça vaut vraiment la
peine d'emmerder les Chinois pour du
sucre ? Bon ok, on sait que c'est pas
mais enfin on l'achète 1 € c'est pas
cher, tout le monde est content.
Pourquoi on irait faire une guerre avec
la Chine ? Parce que s'il faut regarder
le miel, ça commencerait par le miel. Ça
s'arrêterait où ? Il faudrait aussi se
poser les questions sur le sur la
tomate. On parle d'antidumping et
cetera, mais si la tomate chinoise était
vraiment au coût de production, jamais
on achètera. Elle serait beaucoup trop
cher. C'est un produit qui est sous
dumping phénoménal.
Donc il faudrait regarder effectivement
la tomate, il faudrait regarder tous les
produits quasiment et là on se rendait
compte qu'il y a vraiment des problèmes
et puis personne n'a envie d'avoir un
problème avec la Chine, de faire une
guerre commerciale avec la Chine
aujourd'hui. Sinon on vendrait pas de
vin, on vendrait pas de Rockfort, on
vendrait pas d'Airbus et cetera. Donc
tout le monde se tient un peu par la
barbichette.
Donc revenons revenons au racine de ma
question. Est-ce que vous pensez que
l'État français laisse faire ce petit
tour ou du moins ferme un peu les yeux,
détourne leur gard ou ou parce qu'il
faut de la bouffe pas chère pour
entretenir nos pauvres ? Bah, je pense
qu'il y a un peu de ça. C'estàd que
effectivement, il faut de la bouffe pas
chère. Donc ce miel pas cher, cette
tomate pas cher les arrange bien.
Le prétexte de l'emploi, j'y crois pas
une seconde, pas une seconde. Si
vraiment l'emploi était au sein de leur
préoccupation, qu'est-ce qu'il ferait ?
Il dirait "Ce miel qui est pas du miel,
on en veut pas et il inciterait nos
producteurs de miel à faire du vrai
miel." Parce que si onit pas cette merde
de qui est du faux miel, on en
fabriquerait plus chez nous. Il y aurait
plus d'apiculteurs qui vivraient de leur
métier.
Ouais. Et toutes les abeilles elles
crèvent chez nous.
Voilà. Et puis si on avait un minimum
protégé notre industrie de la tomate, le
cabanon, il aurait pas été en faillite,
il aurait pas été repris par Chalkis.
Le cabanon, c'était un petit producteur
de tomate. C'est ça ?
Non, c'était le numéro 1 français de la
tomate. C'était une coopérative en
Provence qui était installée à Camaret
Suregg. C'était un des plus gros mais
vous aviez cabanon, vous aviez Tomat
daquiten. Enfin, il y avait des il y
avait une industrie de la tomate en
France
et pareil au Portugal, en Espagne, en
Italie. Et donc si vraiment nos
politiques défendaient l'emploi, ils se
seraient occupés de ces usines. Ils
auraient dit "Attendez". Voilà. Donc
mais si si on on fait du miel à 15
balles le kilo,
Ouais.
et puis personne va acheter de miel chez
les pauvres.
Bah moi, j'achète du miel chez un
producteur dans les dans les Alpes et je
le paye. Non mais je le paye à je le
paye, je sais plus je le paye combien je
le paye.
Euh la miellerie d'Émilie, elle
s'appelle. Je peux vous en parler, il
est super bon en plus. Combien je le
paye ? Je le paye je sais plus 8 ou 9 €
le kilou un truc comme ça. Mais c'est le
prix que ça doit avoir ce produit là. Et
et je vous dis il est pas cher du tout à
ce prix 1 kg de miel à 9 € ou à 10 €.
Moi je le paye plutôt 15 balles les 500
g.
Ça dépend où tu l'achètes
les Seven.
Bah moi je suis dans les Alpes et enfin
voilà je trouvais ce cette ce petit
producteur là qui en aille il a des prix
très raisonnables et puis voilà. Mais
bon même si je le payais 12 ou 15 c'est
pas exagéré pour genre de produit. C'est
enfin faire du miel c'est compliqué.
C'est les abeilles, elles produit enfin
c'est pas des vaches quoi. Je veux dire.
Revenons. Oui, surtout que en ce moment
elles sont un peu décimées dans tous les
sens.
Revenons un peu à la mentalité des gens
qui que vous avez que tu as côtoyé
pendant le le ton expérience dans
l'agroalimentaire.
C'est quoi ? C'est
bah c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai voulu
écrire ce livre. Le premier, c'est je me
suis dit quand même ce serait
intéressant
pas tellement de faire le sensationnel
pour pour raconter un peu ce que j'ai
vu. Bon, c'est c'est enfin anecdotique
mais ça illustre. Mais d'expliquer
comment ces gens-là, comment moi aussi à
cette époque je réfléchissais, comment
je voyais les choses, comment je
pensais, comment voilà et et je vous dis
ces gens-là ont pas l'impression de mal
faire.
Il y a toujours cette ma c'est pas ma
responsabilité, c'est la responsabilité
de quelqu'un d'autre. Typiquement, je
fais des produits dans les normes. C'est
pas de ma faute si les normes sont mal
foutues. C'est la faute de l'État. Euh
OK, on met des additifs mais c'est
autorisé. Si c'est autorisé, c'est que
ça a été évalué. Si ça a été évalué,
c'est que c'est sans danger. Donc c'est
pas de ma faute si j'en mets. Mais
c'est sûr c'est légal.
Sûr que c'est légal.
Mais à notre niveau, au niveau de
l'usine,
on se pose pas la question de pourquoi
c'est légal. On se pose pas la question
des lobbies, on se pose pas la question
de la corruption, on se pose pas la
question de ce qui se passe à Bruxelles.
Ça, on le voit pas.
Ça, on parle la prochaine question, ce
sera ça. Là, je veux dire, tout ça, tout
ça, on voit pas. On voit pas les les
vraies causes du problème. On se dit
c'est pas nous, nous on est des
exécutants. Tu vois, c'estàd que les
décisions sont prises loin, ailleurs, en
haut lieu par des gens qui savent. Donc
nous, si c'est autorisé, c'est sans
danger et on y va. On se pose pas la
question de savoir pourquoi les gens ont
de plus en plus de diabète, pourquoi il
y a de plus en plus de problèmes. Ça
c'est pas notre problème. À la rigueur
même, l'industrie et ses représentants
nous fait nous nous envoie des réponses
toutes faites. Par exemple, si les
consommateurs, si les pauvres ils sont
trop gros, c'est qu'ils font pas assez
d'efforts et qu'ils ont pas un régime
équilibré.
quand même, ils sont cons quand même. On
leur dit 30 minutes d'effort par jour et
5 fruits et légumes. Avec ça, il y a pas
de problème. Donc le gars qui est sur sa
ligne de fabrication, mais même
l'ingénieur en RD par exemple ou même
moi à mon niveau à cette époque-là,
je me dis bah oui, les produits sont
autorisés, ils ont été évalués, il y a
des normes, il y a des normes de
partout. L'usine, elle est certifiée
BRS, IFS, ISO et cetera. On a des
certifications, veux tu en voilà, on a
des manuelles qualité mais j'en avais
des piles comme ça. Euh, on nous dit ces
produits sont pas dangereux. Pour pas
être obèse, il suffit de faire un peu
d'exercice et de consommer nos produits
pourris. Mais si on consomme avec une
pomme et une tomate, c'est il y a il y a
pas de problème. Donc finalement tout le
monde se dit il y a pas de problème.
Vous tu as parlé de de corruption ?
Ouais.
Quelles sont les preuves ?
Preuve de
corruption.
Bah il faut qu'on s'entende sur les sur
les termes. C'estd que enfin ce que moi
j'appelle de la corruption c'est ce que
les autres appellent du lobisme. Enfin
pour moi je vois pas bien la différence.
Souvent on prend comme tu dis la novel
langue on prend un mot à la mode et on
voilà on
et bon tu un sens c'est enlever le sens.
Oui mais lobbying qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire lobbying ? C'est même pas un mot
français. Lobbying c'est quoi du
lobbying ?
Si je t'invite par exemple à faire une
conférence à 100000 € est-ce que c'est
du lobbying ou est-ce que c'est la
corruption ?
Conférence sur quoi ?
Je m'en fous je te file 100000 € tu fais
une conférence. Est-ce que c'est de la
corruption ou pas ? habillé,
tu fais ce que tu veux.
Est-ce que Est-ce que je perds mon
honneur ?
Tu perds rien du tout. Mais peut-être
qu'il est pas possible ma réputation
comme on dirait vu le parent, il est
possible qu'un jour mais lointain je te
demande un service. Mais ce jour
n'arrivera peut-être jamais.
Donc on va pas dire à un gars viens chez
nous, on va te payer 100000 € pour une
conférence. C'est de la corruption.
Qui a été payé 100000 € ?
Je sais pas, c'est un exemple fictif.
qui aurait je sais pas, il y aurait eu
des gens, des chefs d'état et autres qui
auraient fait des conférences payées par
des banques à des niveaux ces
niveaux-là. Mais
mais ça tu le sais très bien mais même
je l'ai vécu mais on l'a fait on l'a
fait nous à notre niveau. Bah genre on
on invite des chercheurs. Enfin la le
lobbyisme ou la enfin je sais pas le
terme qu'il faut utiliser mais quand
nous on finance des chercheurs par
exemple d'accord à faire des études qui
nous intéressent moyen moyen, on s'en
fout un peu, qui sont un peu dans notre
domaine par exemple sur je sais pas moi
le métabolisme des graisses ou n'importe
quoi. Enfin le mec il s'en fout il fait
ses études après il publie. Pourquoi on
le finance ce gars-là ?
Parce qu'il publie bien.
Oui, mais justement c'est ça, on veut
qu'il publie. Pourquoi ? Pour qu'il
fasse une carrière académique. Et un mec
qui publie bien parce qu'on le finance,
qu'est-ce qu'il devient ? Expert à la
FSA. Et le mec qui est expert à la FSA,
parce qu'on aé ses études, quand il
verra notre produit de nous, d'un
collègue à nous ou d'un syndicat à nous,
enfin voilà arriver devant lui, est-ce
qu'il aura vraiment toute l'objectivité
pour dire que ce produit là finalement
il est pas bon ?
Oui. Dans ce casl, on financera plus.
C'est à lui de voir.
Si tu veux faire une enfin si tu veux
faire une carrière académique ou
journalistique ou tiens, j'ai vu tu
avais invité un gaz qui parlait de la
critique gastronomique, je crois qui
parlait de la gaz,
je sais plus, je veux pas citer de nom
parce que c'est pas j'ai pas envie de me
faire des nuis. Mais enfin, tu parlais
de Jean-Pierre Cof par exemple.
Jean-Pierre Cof, on va parler des morts
comme ça on aura pas d'ennui.
Jean-Pierre Cof, moi je moi j'adore ce
gars-là, je l'adore toujours d'ailleurs.
Faut pas je je suis pas comme dirait
l'autre cavas, il faut pardonner.
Il avait donc il a fait sa carrière sur
ses fameux coups de gueule, voilà, en
dénonçant la malbouffe qui était très
bien. Et puis à un moment, il a eu un
coup de mou, on va dire et il a
travaillé avec Leader Price à l'époque.
Et ça me fait marrer parce que je me
rappelle, il y avait eu, je te parlais
au tout début de cette affaire des
raviolis ravioli leader Price en 2001
donc publié dans le magazine Capital où
en fait ils avaient fait des raviolis au
bœuf qui contenaient pas de bœuf qui
contenaient même pas de la viande, il y
avait des gland de salivaire de
volaille, des poumons, de la plèvre,
enfin les beaux morceaux de la volaille
mais c'était pas cher. Et quand les
journalistes avaient dit Jean-Pierre
Coff il s'en était pris, il s'en étaiit
pris plein la gueule à ce moment-là, on
lui avait dit "Ouais mais le ravioli
Leader Price" et il en pouvait plus le
P. Il s'est pris des coups mais partout.
Il avait dit "Mais peut-être que vous
pourrez retrouver la vidéo". Cé un
moment super marrant. Il avait dit bah
les patrons de leader Press, ils ont
fait caca dans les raviolis. Si c'est ça
que vous voulez entendre, ça vous vous
verrez, vous pourrez la retrouver cette
vidéo. Ça m'a fait ça m'avait fait
marrer à l'époque.
Et ce qui me fait encore plus marrer
pour pour parler d'une autre personne,
c'est que justement personne que tu as
que tu as nommé tout à l'heure avait dit
euh
j'ess de me rappeler, je l'avais lu à
l'époque dans l'humanité que et il avait
dit un truc du genre Jean-Pierre Cof,
mon ami, je sais pas trop quoi, il a
vendu son âme au diable. Non, il a c'est
un naufrage moral. Il a vendu son âme.
Il a vendu son âme pour un plat de
l'antilader price. Bon, vous pourrez
peut-être trouver la chercher sur
internet, vous trouvez sûrement la
citation exacte. Donc ça, c'est son ami
Peréico qui disait ça. Alors, OK, on
peut on peut le penser comme ça. Bon,
OK, très bien. Ceci dit, enfin c'est
quand même malvenu de faire ce genre de
commentaire et quelques années plus tard
de se faire payer son émission par
Nesleé.
Bah, il me semble. Faut être cohérent
quelque part.
Alors, on va me dire "Ouais, je suis
droit dans mes bottes, je reçois de
l'argent de ces gens-là." Mais c'est pas
du lobbéisme, c'est pas de l'influence,
j'ai toute liberté et cetera. Il
n'empêche que quand la personne qui l'a
interrogé,
Bourdin ou je sais plus qui lui demande
alors c'est qui le responsable de la
malbouffe et cetera, qu'est-ce qui vous
répond ?
C'est la grande distribution.
Celui qui finance mon émission, il
aimerait faire de la bonne bouffe, mais
il peut pas. C'est la grande
distribution, le grand méchant.
Alors, est-ce que quelque part
c'est une réponse qu'on peut penser
sincère ?
Ah oui,
on peut en douter. Enfin, moi je je vous
dis oui, la grande distribution
effectivement, elle a une part de
responsabilité, mais il peut-être qu'il
sait garder son intégrité que non. Bah
alors dans ce cas-là, pourquoi est-ce
qu'il dit pas que le le la la la
responsabilité est largement partagée ?
La distribution vend les produits mais
qui les fabrique ?
Alors là quand vous êtes financé par le
numéro 1 mondial de l'industrie
agroalimentaire, 93 milliards de
chiffres d'affaires,
enfin il y a un moment il faut être
cohérent et surtout quand vous dites que
les petits copains qui ont vendu leur
âme avant enfin un naufrage et cetera.
Enfin, il y a un moment, il faut être
Oui, il faut être cohérent, quoi.
C'est Ils ont déjà retrouvé la vidéo
avec Jean-Pierre Cof Caca.
Elle est drôle, hein.
Ouais, on va pas la passer tout de suite
parce qu'on va pas les droits. Mais euh,
ils l'ont déjà trouvé.
Non, mais
à l'époque, je me rappelle, il disait
"Oui, je travaillais avec Leader Price
mais vous allez voir, je vais leur faire
changer leur recette, on va faire des
trucs." Peut-être qu'il y croyait,
peut-être qu'il était motivé. Je me
serais pas permis de dire, par exemple,
que ce mec-là c'était il a perdu son
honneur, sa morale, il a vendu son âme
et cetera.
Mais les gens qui se permettent de dire
ça, il faut quand même que quelque part
après il soit irréprochable.
Et donc pourquoi je dis ça ? C'est par
rapport au lobbyisme.
Pour en revenir à ta question initiale,
si nous on finançait des chercheurs en
ayant espoir qu'un jour il soit dans des
commissions qui nous aident et ils y
arrivent s'ils publient, s'ils sont
connus dans le monde académique sur pour
avoir travaillé sur les graisses et
cetera ou sur d'autres produits, ils ils
ils iront quelque part à un moment dans
des postes haut placés dans les dans les
organismes officiels. On le sait, c'est
ça marche comme ça. C'est pour ça que
vous avez 50 % des des membres des
comités scientifiques de l'f qui sont
financés par l'industrie. C'est comme ça
que ça marche. Quelles sont vos sources
?
Bah je sais, je on le pratiquait mes
sources et mes yeux, mes oreilles. Donc
oui, on le faisait. Donc on les
finançait. Ensuite, vous allez pouvoir
voir chez Transparency Watch,
Transparency Transparency Watch et ils
vous diront la même chose. Ils vous
diront que la plupart enfin la moitié de
ceux qui travaillent dans les panels de
l'EFSA sont financés par sont financés
par l'industrie au sens large. Mais là,
on parle de l'agroalimentaire, mais
c'est pareil pour tout le reste. Et
Bruxelles,
pardon,
il se passe quoi à Bruxelles ? Le QG des
lobbyistes, c'est eux qui rédigent les
les amendement. On sait qu' il y a plus
de lobbyistes à Bruxelles que d'employés
de la que d'employés européen. Donc oui,
il y a énormément énormément de
lobbyistes.
Il y a plus d'agents de renseignement
que de lobbyistes.
Ah ça je saurais pas vous dire, je peux
pas dire je sais pas, c'est pas c'est
pas mon domaine. Mais ce que je sais
aussi c'est que moi je l'ai vu. Enfin
pour pour ce que ce que ce que nous on
voyait, ce que nous on faisait c'est que
l'argent qui va dans le lobby, ce sont
des sommes monstrueuses.
C'est combien ? Difficile de le dire
mais ça ça se chiffre en en en milliards
en dizaines de milliards. Ce sont des
sommes monstrueuses. Vous avez déjà il
faudrait voir le chiffre exact
actualisé, moi j'avais 30000 en tête
mais je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui. Donc vous avez des dizaines
de milliers de gens payés à temps plein
pour faire du lobby. Alors pour
l'agroalimentaire, pour la voiture, pour
le textile, pour la chimie, pour
l'avion, pour tout, pour l'acier, pour
tout. Donc vous avez des dizaines de
milliers de lobbyistes. Donc il faut
payer ces gens-là. Donc ça déjà ça fait
des salaires monstrueux. Et qu'est-ce
que font ces gens-là ? et ben il
s'invitent, il finance, il supportent,
il donnent de l'info, il donnent du
conseil, de l'influence et cetera. Donc
voilà, ça marche comme ça. Donc quand je
vous dis que par exemple les chercheurs
quand nous on finance des recherches de
certains mais on fait pas que ça. On
fait aussi par exemple des des
séminaires, des conférences, des
symposiums.
Donc on organise un truc dans un coin
bien sympa, on les invite en business,
une semaine, tout ferait payé, on les
dédommage et tout le monde est content.
C'est fun.
Bah oui, c'est pour enfin le lobby
personnellement, je suis je suis
extrêmement extrêmement choqué par ce
genre de ce genre de pratique. Pour moi,
le lobbyme devrait pas devrait pas
exister. Les asutions européennes, enfin
quand on voit que la France a un un
déficit net de 10 milliards d'euros avec
l'Europe, on aurait utilisé cet argent
là pour se payer des vrais experts
indépendants et [__] ces lobby dehors.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin des lobby ?
Pourquoi faire ? Alors, on vous dit ils
apportent de l'information mais c'est de
l'information biaisée, tronquée,
falsifiée.
On a pas du tout besoin de ces lobis.
Mais
il y a peut-être des lobis aussi qui
apportent de l'information pas biaisé,
pas falsifié.
On voit en général que ce qui se passe
que on passe d'un lobby à la commission.
La commission passe dans un lobby.
Enfin, un coup c'est la chef de la enfin
la responsable de l'alimentaire qui
parle pour je sais plus quel lobby.
Après, on a vu dans les banques aussi,
j'avais vu tiens justement un SV de je
sais plus quelle personne qui était
spécialisé dans les banques et qui
disait
pantouflage
bah bien sûr je sais plus qui est parti
de la Commission européenne pour sep
fois son salaire pour aller dans un
organisme de lobby mais c'est pareil si
on c'est comme un par exemple un un un
commissaire on appelle ça les ceux qui
font les Nat qui sont je dire commissai
au compte mais inspecteur des finances
qui ensuite passent par pantouffer dans
le privé dans une banque privée puis qui
ensuite reviennent au gouvernement par
exemple et qui en fait qui font que
monayer leur contact
donc Tout ça, on peut dire c'est du
lobbisme. Enfin bon, pour moi, c'est de
la corruption.
Est-ce que vous avez Est-ce que tu as vu
Soleil Vert ? Oh
oui, il y a longtemps.
Est-ce qu'on se dirige vers Soleil Vert
?
Oh ben non, c'était quand même un Non,
soleil vert c'était de la de la c'est du
cannibalisme donc on en est pas là
encore.
On transformé les vieux en croquette.
Ouais.
Non, on on en est on en est pas là mais
soleil vert, ça répondait à un autre
problème. C'était vraiment un problème
de ressources. Alors que là tout ce
qu'on ce qu'on voit c'est pour je dire
c'est pour l'argent mais vous savez on
vous dit des fois souvent oui le
problème c'est la financiérisation et
cetera en fait ça veut rien dire en fait
il y a pas de financiarisation dans
l'alimentaire parce que dans
l'alimentaire
ce qu'on veut c'est juste gagner de
l'argent comme n'importe quelle
entreprise ou même quelquefois survivre.
Moi je travaillais dans des entreprises
par exemple qui étaient qui étaient en
situation financière très difficile donc
elles étaient prêtes à faire n'importe
quoi pour survivre.
Donc
donc c'est une industrie, c'est un
business et dans un dans un business les
entreprises sont amoral.
Ell elles font ni le bien ni le mal.
Elles elles essaient d'évoluer avec les
règles qu'on leur impose si elles
peuvent modifier, influencer ces règles
et puis de temps en temps essayer de les
contourner.
En en en quand il y a des crises
financières, qu'est-ce qui se passe pour
l'agroalimentaire ? Ils sont contents,
pas contents ?
Ça va dépendre les entreprises mais là
où j'ai travaillé, je me rappelle que la
la la personne qui m'avait embouché,
enfin une des personnes qui m'avait
embouché, c'était une légende de
l'agroalimentaire et et donc c'était un
légende pourquoi ? parce qu'ils avent
fait beaucoup de pognons ou il a fait
gagner beaucoup de pognons
euh
un peu tout ça mais surtout il avait
j'ai pas trop envie de vous vous enfin
si je vous dis pourquoi ça vous allez
identifier la personne donc j'ai pas
trop envie
et en fait c'était une légende parce que
c'est un monsieur qui avait qui avait
qui a construit une des plus belles
entreprises
qui a fait beaucoup d'argent avec et
alors qu'elle était en faillite qui a
réussi à la revendre a revendu une
fortune.
Voilà. Et avec l'argent, il a redémarré
un nouveau business.
Donc voilà, c'est donc il disait quoi ?
Donc cette personne m'a embauché, moi je
suis extrêmement fier de travailler avec
lui et il me disait tu sais quand c'est
la crise pour nous c'est tout bf parce
que les gens qui ont pas d'argent
ils vont de toute façon manger parce
qu'il faut bien manger. On peut couper
dans toutes les dépenses mais pas
tellement dans l'alimentaire. Et les
gens si à la rigueur ils mangent plus de
riz, de pâtes et cetera, ils auront
besoin de davantage d'épices. Et comme
nous on était des fabricants d'épices,
on était très content de ça. Donc
l'alimentaire c'est un c'est pour les
produits de grande consommation, les
crises sont plutôt des opportunités, on
va dire, parce que c'est sur ces postes
là que les gens vont renier en dernier.
Vous allez peut-être différer l'achat de
la voiture, de la machine à laver,
acheter moins de vêtements. Par contre,
il vous faut manger tous les jours.
Question d'internet très intéressante.
Quit de la spéculation sur les matières
premières alimentaires qui vont parfois
tendre les marchés jusqu'à affamer les
populations.
Ouais. Ouais. Bah oui, enfin on parlait
à une époque de l'interdire, il faudrait
l'interdire. Oui. Oui. Il y a il y a
énormément de spéculations qui se font
sur les produits alimentaires. Oui.
Surtout les produits alimentaires
d'ailleurs. Euh moi, j'ai acheté du
poivre, il y avait une grosse
spéculation sur le poivre. quand j'aché
des huiles alimentaires, il y avait un
peu moins de spéculation parce que c'est
quand même des produits qui sont qui
sont à très très gros volume. Donc oui,
il y a de la spéculation sur les
matières alimentaires et ça devrait être
absolument interdit.
Question d'internet, nous avons évoqué
Attendez juste une parenthèse par
rapport à ça, c'est que il y a rien
techniquement qui qui s'oppose à enfin
on peut très bien définir que seul ne ne
trade les matières premières que ceux
qui les utilisent.
Par exemple, il y a pas de de raison
qu'une banque ou qu' une compagnie
d'assurance ou ou un trader financier
achète par exemple du cacao, du café, de
la farine, de l'huile. On pourrait dire
voilà, ce serait c'est pas une quelque
chose d'impossible ou de compliqué à
mettre en œuvre. Ce serait extrêmement
simple en réalité.
On pourrait revenir sur le le trading de
matière première alimentaire avec les
banques qui qui mettent les doigts
dedans, mais ils vont vous dire qu'il se
couvr grâce à ça ou que c'est
Oui, mais qui se couvre ? Qui a besoin
de se couvrir ? que celui qui utilise
par exemple. Moi je fais des sauces,
j'achète de l'huile pour faire des
mayonnaises par exemple. Les huiles sont
côté à Rotterdam. Donc vous avez une
bourse à Rotterdam où c'est côté. Donc
il y a le cours de l'huile soja
le colza. Je crois que le soja c'est
côté aux États-Unis. Enfin bref, vous
avez un cours officiel, donc vous suivez
ce cours et cetera et bien sûr comme le
cours varie tous les jours, même d'heure
en heure, si vous avez des volumes comme
moi par exemple, il me faut je sais pas
moi 10000 tonnes d'huile sur les 3 mois
à venir, soit je peux l'acheter, je fais
un contrat. Tu
as déjà fait des commandes à 10000
tonnes.
Bah mes volumes c'était plus de 40000
tonnes par an.
Donc j'ai fait des contrats
euh
un intérêt un pourcentage sur les
contrats que vous passiez.
Non parce qu'on l' acheté pour nous. Non
non. Donc on payait un prix. Voilà, on a
on avait donc un prix et puis on payait
après on payait après en fonction des
dates de livraison. C'estàd que le prix
était en général augmenté par par
période. Donc on payait je sais pas moi,
j'ai 800 800 € la tonne pour prise
immédiate, 810 le mois d'après, 820, 830
et cetera pour pour avoir compenser les
frais financiers. Donc revenons au tr
Donc en fait ce que je veux dire c'est
que les gens qui ont besoin d'huile
physiquement pour en faire faire quelque
chose, donc nous on fabriquait de la
mayonnaise avec donc il nous fallait
l'huile. C'est normal qu'on se couvre et
cetera parce que si on vend à des
clients par exemple des fast food qui
vont faire des dosettes de mayonnaise,
on a besoin de cette matière à un moment
donné et par exemple avec ces
clients-là, on peut faire un contrat
annuel. On dit voilà tu vas payer mes
deux aes de mayonnaise, tu vas les payer
je sais pas moi 10 € les 1000 toute
l'année. Donc il faut moi que par
rapport à ça, je sais quel prix de
matière première maximum je peux payer.
10 € les 1000 c'est le vrai prix.
Non si c'est je je m'en souviens plus
des prix en fait et en plus je les
connais même pas parce que c'est pas moi
qui les vendait les produits. Moi
j'achetais les matières mais j'étais pas
le vendeur donc je les connaissais pas
les prix de vente en fait. Mais par
contre j'avais des objectifs. On me dis
voilà Christophe tu peux pas acheter de
l'huile au-dessus de voilà et par contre
si tu peux en acheter en dessous de 850
par exemple et ben tu te couvres sur 6
mois.
et je faisais des contrats sur des
longues périodes comme ça. Donc ces
gens-là qui ont besoin du produit, oui,
c'est normal qu'il se couvrent. Mais un
banquier, un un un financier n'a pas
besoin de se couvrir puisqu'il a pas
besoin de la marchandise.
Question Internet, nous avons évoqué les
produits non conformes en France qui ne
sont pas testés, mais que se
passera-t-il lorsque nous aurons les
produits issus des traités de libre
échange, TAFTA, CTA, Jefta,
ce sera encore plus compliqué parce que
les produits seront fabriqués dans des
lieux où on aura aucun contrôle. C'estàd
que aujourd'hui encore en France, en
Europe et cetera, on peut enf les
organismes de l'État français peuvent
aller voir sur place contrôler et
cetera. Quand sera fabriqué quand ça
fabriqué, je sais pas moi, en Amérique
du Sud, aux États-Unis ou au Canada, bah
il faudra faire confiance aux gens sur
place. Et ensuite, on sait très bien que
les normes sont extrêmement différentes.
Tout est différent. Là-bas, vous pouvez
traiter de la viande, vous pouvez la
passer au chlore, par exemple. Vous
pouvez découper la viande comme un
sagouin et puis à la fin pour tout
nettoyer, vous mettez un B chlore et le
poulet, il est bon. En France, c'est pas
autorisé. C'est quoi découper la viande
comme un sagouin ?
Bah c'estàd qu'en général, il faut
éviter quand vous découpez la viande de
la contaminer et notamment avec les le
tube digestif.
Donc quand vous quand vous évisserez des
volailles par exemple ou du voilà, il
faut pas
ou du bœuf. Oui, il faut pas que les le
contenu digestif souille la viande.
Sinon la viande parce qu'en fait quand
vous quand vous enlevez la peau, la
viande se trouve exposée. Donc si vous
avez des souillures, vous allez vous
retrouver avec des salmonnelles, des
coliformes et cetera. Donc ça en Europe,
on fait bien attention, on procède avec
avec prudence et et on en théorie
par contre aux États-Unis, au Canada et
cetera, il est autorisé de traiter de
désinfecter la viande après si tu veux.
Donc de lui faire par exemple un bain au
chlore et avec le chlore, on désinfecte.
Bah
c'est bien.
Bah ça se discute ça. Il vaut mieux
enfin je pense qu'il vaut mieux faire
attention quand on travaille le produit
plutôt que rajouter des produits
chimiques encore après. Alors après, on
va vous dire le chlore, c'est pas
dangereux. Oui, probablement. Mais enfin
bon,
irradier certains produits pour les les
Ah, ça c'est intéressant ça aussi.
L'irradiation, c'est la méthode de c'est
le la méthode de traitement pour enlever
les bactéries la plus efficace, la moins
chère, la plus rapide. Donc, elle a
énormément d'avantages.
Vous pouvez traiter un produit
conditionné puisque les rayonnement, ils
passent au travers de des emballages, du
papier, du carton, du plastique et
cetera. Donc c'est c'est vous fabriquez
votre produit, vous mettez une palette
dans les enfin dans le dans une enceinte
protégée, un coup de sésium et cetera et
le produit il est nickel. Donc c'est
c'est pratique. Et le produit est pas
dégradé c'estàd qu'il est pas dégradé
visuellement. Par exemple nous quand on
achetait des des du des produits qui
devaient garder une belle couleur
visuelle comme du paprika par exemple.
Le paprika doit être bien rouge avec un
rouge brillant traité par ionisation. Ça
donne des résultats fantastiques.
C'était du paprico paprika hongroire.
Dans ce cas-là, c'est du paprika
d'Afrique du Sud. Voilà. mais que
j'achetais moi pour du pap traité à la
vapeur d'eau. Vous voyez, j'étais
arnaqué en fait dans ce cas-là.
On on s'en doutait quand même. On s'en
doutait parce que vu le prix où on le
payait puis vu la qualité du produit, on
s'en est douté presque tout de suite.
Ouais. Mais donc
mais donc
et donc vous vous en doutiez mais et
vous avez laissé faire ?
On a laissé faire jusqu'à un certain
point quand même. Quand on s'est on
s'est dit quand même
on va se faire toper. Voilà, on s'est
dit quand même n'importe quel imbécile
en voyant ces analyses là, il y a qu'une
explication possible quoi.
Alors n'importe quel imbécile, ça veut
dire n'importe quel fonctionnaire. C'est
ça
? Ouais. Mais pas le terme imbécile me
va pas parce que je vous dis enfin un
fonctionnaire des des des des fraudes et
cetera, moi j'ai un respect absolu pour
ces gens-là et même enfin beaucoup plus
de respect pour ces gens-là que pour les
gens qui travaillent dans l'industrie
qui sont souvent payés deux ou trois
fois plus.
Revenons à l'irradiation.
Donc l'irradiation c'est une technique
facile et cetera. Et donc moi, j'ai eu
des problèmes à l'époque sur ces
produits là et ce qui m'a fait ce qui
m'a fait rire il y a pas il y a pas très
longtemps en entre guillemets, c'est que
la DGCRF reconnaît que il y a de plus en
plus de produits qui arrivent en Europe,
notamment d'Asie et qui ont été
irradiés. Alors il citait dans dans les
rapports que que je que je donne, il
citait par exemple les soupes
déshydratées de Chine, les crevettes de
Thaïlande et cetera et cetera parce que
on peut quand même le détecter mais
c'est pas du tout facile, c'est pas
simple. Donc il y a beaucoup de produits
qui aujourd'hui sont irradiés notamment
en Asie et qui passent qui passent en
Europe. Et
ça change quelque chose ? Ça fait quoi ?
Oui oui c'est important parce qu'il y a
des produits vous pouvez pas
débactériser autrement. Par exemple, moi
j'avais visité
la crevette c'est clair qu'il faut la
passer au rayon. Non
bah non pas forcément. Si elle si elle
est faite dans des proprements si elle
est faite de manière saine si elle est
faite dans les règles de l'art, il y a
pas besoin de la traiter.
Vous déjà en Asie ? Non. Ah bah oui,
c'est Oui, j'y vais depuis première fois
que j'y suis allé, c'était j'avais 25
ans, c'était en 80 là 93 14 15, je sais
plus. Enfin au siècle dernier, à
l'époque où j'y allais, Hong Kong était
encore sous domination anglaise.
Et et donc la la l'irradiation, ça
change quoi ? Bah
l'irradiation c'est que c'est simplement
que ça change pas grand-chose, ça
débactérise, ça stérilise mais les
clients aiment pas ça. Ils ont pas
confiance. Donc si tu vois sur un
produit irradié ou traité par événement
ionisant, en général les gens ils
veulent pas, ils ont pas confiance, ils
achètent pas.
Ça laisse des traces, ça change,
ça fait ça fait quoi ? Ça fait rien au
produit, ça fait quelque chose,
ça altère l'ADN. C'est comme ça que ça
tue en fait. Ça tue les bactéries et
cetera parce que ça ça détruit l'ADN. Ça
ça empêche aussi les pommes de terre de
germer. Ça tue les germes, ça tu enf
tout ce qui est vivant en fait, ça
enlève toute vie. C'est bien le principe
de c'est de la radioactivité en fait.
C'est ça enlève toute vie. Donc le
produit, il est mort de chez mort mais
il est beau.
Donc les gens la f
les gens ils ont pas ils ont pas
confiance. Alors peut-être peut-être
bêtement, je sais pas. Je sais pas s'il
enfin toutes les études entre guillemets
faites par les professionnels qui prome
la méthode disent que c'est pas
dangereux mais les gens ont pas
confiance. Donc c'est quand même
autorisé pour certains produits. Il y a
des produits où c'est interdit par
contre mais bon
par exemplequ
bah les crevettes, les soupes de légumes
déshydratées. Ça ces produits c'est pas
autorisé. Je crois que c'est autorisé de
mémoire sur les cuisses de grenouilles,
sur peut-être les écrevises, enfin
quelques produits un petit peu
spécifiques. Mais par exemple, j'ai
visité moi des entreprises qui faisaient
de la tomate séchée. Tu as la tomate
séchée, tu as des fois des tomates
séchées qui sont qui sont coupées en
deux là, tu sais demi tomates. Bah, ils
prennent des tomates, ils les récoltent,
ils les coupent en deux puis ils les
mettent à l'air libre dehors.
Donc dehors, il y a des mouches, il y a
des insectes, des fois il y a un courant
d'air, il y a un petit nuage de de sable
qui qui recouvre tout ça.
C'est pas un produit sain, c'est pas un
produit propre. Donc en général
autorouteout à côté.
Comment
une autoroute à côté ?
Oui, bien sûr. Autoroute, des voitures
qui passe. Oui, bien sûr. Moi, je me
rappelle, j'ai vu ça, comment vous
faites ? Il me dit "Oh, on met du
souffre, c'est pas un problème." Donc
ils mettent du souffre mais des fois ça
suffit pas.
Donc, il y a beaucoup de produits qui
sont irradiés sans être déclarés. Bien
sûr.
Et moi, nous enfin mes sources, oui, on
l'a vécu, on l'a vu. Et en plus, je suis
allé en Afrique du Sud. Après quand
même, je suis allé le voir le gars, je
dis bon ben maintenant montre-moi ton
installation, ton appareil de
stérilisation. J'ai rien vu, il m'a rien
montré. Il me dit "Ouais, tu comprends ?
Il en pas tu tombes mal."
Donc voilà.
Une question sur le véganisme. Est-ce
que les les végan acheter leurs petites
graines, ils peuvent se faire pigeonner,
arnaquer ou il y a des risques ? Quels
sont les risques ? Végan c'est quoi
précisément ? En fait,
il mange pas tout ce qui a été. que des
graines quand même.
Non, il mange pas des graines, il mange
du tofou et plein d'autres choses, hein.
Bah, je sais pas trop. Moi, je suis pas
je suis je me méfie quand même. C'estàd
que je pense que on est omnivore, donc
on est quand même conçu pour manger un
peu.
Non, mais ça ça se discute. C'est c'est
Non, mais dire les produits pour végan
enfin, il y a peut-être quelques
catégories de produits, je pense par
exemple au succès d'année de viande, ce
qui les remplaceurs de viande, les airat
de viande type corne par exemple. Tu
connais le corn ?
Connaî pas le corn le corne. Le corn O Q
O R N corn
le maïs
non non la marque c'est une marque.
Ah non non non. Ah non on connait pas
le corn. Cais pas le corn. Ah pourtant
c'est extrêmement je crois que c'est la
marque numéro 1 de du produit pour
végan. C'est c'est le c'est du Ah c'est
non c'est des micoprotéines.
La moisissure mois que c'est du mois tu
prends ça un bloc. C'est ça.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Mais ça pousse en
plaque, il découpe en cube et ils
aromatisent. Et ça c'est le corn. Donc
c'est c'est vendu, c'est anglais
d'origine. Ça été fabriqué en Angleterre
avec je sais plus quel quelle moisissure
puis il y a un nom. Je sais plus.
Champignon.
C'est c'est un champignon. Voilà, c'est
ça. Champignon. Mais quand on dit
champignon, les gens ils pensent
champignons de Paris. C'est une
moisissure en fait. Donc ils font
pousser ça, ils aromatisent ça, ils
découpent en cube et ils le vendent.
Donc ce produit-là, c'est un produit
typique végétarien végan, on va dire.
C'est c'est pas du tout fou mais c'est
de la moisissure donc c'est un produit
c'est du du mycélium donc c'est
de la protéine
micoprotéin et c'est important parce que
en fait il y a il y a en ce moment un
mouvement aux États-Unis pour
l'interdire parce qu'il s'est réveillé
qu'il y a des gens qui étaient
allergiques à ces microprotéines. Donc
il y a eu des cas très graves de
réaction allergique à ce produit là.
Donc ça c'est un danger de ce genre de
produit où on n'est pas réellement conçu
pour manger des micoprotéines en grosse
quantité. Tu vois ? manger un steak,
manger un plat de lentille, ça va. Mais
par contre, manger une galette de de
moisissure, on n pas on est apparemment
pas prévu pour
D'accord. Et donc sur les sur les
graines sur les les
Ah bah il peut y avoir des fraudes et
des rest des transferts d'huile minéral
parce que c'est du carton recyclé des
choses comme ça.
Moi à l'époque où j'avais eu le problème
des huiles minérales, c'était sur des
lentilles mais on l'a découvert sur les
lentilles mais c'était pareil pour les
haricots, c'était pareil pour le
couscous, le boule, enfin tout ce qui
était conditionné dans les mêmes
paquets. Là vous voyez comment il
s'appelle Food Watch. Euh,
ils ont découvert des huiles minérales.
Ils l'avaient découvert dans la purée en
flocon au tout début et euh ils l'ont
découvert là dans le lait en poudre pour
les enfants.
Vous avez Est-ce que vous avez une
application sur votre téléphone qui vous
renseigne sur ce que vous achetez par
rapport au code barre ou des choses
comme ça ?
Ben, j'ai rencontré les gens de chez
Yuka et de chez Open Food Fact. On a
discuté pas mal. J'aime bien ce qu'ils
font. Franchement, je trouve que c'est
vraiment utile. C'est c'est bien. Ceci
dit, vu mon bagage, j'ai j'en ai pas du
tout besoin, quoi. Je connais les
produits mieux que ces applications là
pour notre communauté.
Ah, pour votre communauté. Oui, je les
recommande bien sûr. Bien sûr. Mais si
vous voulez
donc le nom le nom des applications,
bah vous avez UK et vous avez Open Food
Fact. Alors, ce sont des gens qui
travaillent ensemble main dans la main.
Donc voilà, vous avez aussi Scanit, je
crois. Donc vous avez quelques
applications. Oui, c'est intéressant.
Alors par contre, il faut faire
attention parce que je sais que
maintenant les supermarchés quelques-uns
se sont dit hop, on va essayer nous
aussi de faire notre application euh et
d'être jugé parti parce que il y a aussi
nos produits mar distributeurs qui vont
forcément bref et il y a aussi des
industriels qui se disent "Ouais, ça
serait pas mal quand même que peut-être
nos produits aussi ont puissent un peu
les placer." Donc euh je vous recommande
ces applications vraiment indépendantes
pour avoir un minimum d'objectivité.
Ceci dit, petite remarque par rapport à
ces applications, c'est que pourquoi
elles sont utiles ? C'est simplement
parce que les industriels, ils veulent
ils vous mettent pas les informations de
manière enfin simple et compréhensible.
Mett les informations déjà.
Oui, mais justement c'est c'est pas
toutes
comme comme
parce que les ils les connaissent
peut-être pas toutes.
Ah ben si. Ben si, on pourra en mettre
beaucoup. Mais le problème c'est pour
c'est comme tu disais pour noyer le
poisson, tu vois. Ben
je dis pour noyer le poisson. Non mais
quand tu dis quelque part c'est euh en
en faisant trop,
ça revient en fait à en donner moins.
C'estàd que le consommateur qui va
vouloir comparer de produits, ne
serait-ce que par exemple les les
données nutritionnelles. Dans certains
cas, c'est en kilcalories, dans l'autre
cas c'est en kiloj, dans quelques pas
c'est c'est en portion et dans l'autre
cas c'est en 100 g. Al vous prenez deux
emballages de deux produits différents,
vous pouvez pas les comparer. Bon,
celui-là, il est en kiljoule,
kilcalories, 100 g. Oui, mais une
portion c'est une portion de combien ?
Donc c'est c'est c'est incompréhensible.
Ce que le consommateur veut, c'est quoi
? C'est qu'on lui dise c'est vert, c'est
rouge, c'est jaune.
C'est c'est passé ça. Non.
Bah le nutri score. Bah oui, c'est très
bien dans ce caslà. C'est très bien et
plutôt ça se mettra en place mais ce
sera en fait le les applications,
qu'est-ce qu'ils font d'autre ? Si ce
n'est que faire leur propre nutriscore.
Donc oui, c'est bien. Tout ce qui
permettra au consommateur de s'y
retrouver rapidement, ce sera bien.
Alors, ceci dit, c'est pas non plus un
système parfait parce que il faut bien
définir des critères de qualité. Ce que
je te disais au début, la qualité c'est
super difficile à définir. Il y en a qui
vont vous dire, je veux un produit
naturel.
Il veut dire "Ah mais ce produit là, il
est pas assez naturel." Il a qui veut
dire "Je veux pas d'additif du tout." Ah
oui mais Yuka ils disent que le produit
il est bien. Il y a quand même des
additifs. Ah oui mais je préfère un
produit bio. Un produit qui est pas bio
pour moi c'est pas de qualité. Donc tu
vois chacun voit un peu midi à sa porte
et définir la qualité une qualité qui
soit la même et perçue de la même façon
pour tout le monde c'est extrêmement
difficile.
Question d'internet. La traçabilité sur
blockchain peut-elle améliorer les
choses ?
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais, oui.
La blockchain, ça il y a eu des
expérimentations qui ont commencé,
notamment sur le le poisson par exemple.
Euh c'est-à-dire que il faut que la
traçabilité commence vraiment au moment
où la ressource est pêchée. Donc sur le
poisson, je sais qu'ils ont fait des
expériences en blockchain. Donc, il y a
des zones de pêche définies, pêche
durable et cetera. Donc, un chalutier va
récupérer, je sais pas moi, une tonne de
merlu et hop, il va lui attribuer un
numéro de l'eau et l'entrée donc être la
première rentrée de la blockchain. Et
ensuite, on peut suivre ce lot partout
où il ira.
Donc ça permet effectivement de suivre
des lots de A à Z. Donc oui, c'est une
bonne idée, c'est une bonne méthode et
encore faut-il par contre que ça se met
en place. Euh il y a un problème de
confidentialité donc il faudra sûrement
passer avec des des codes parce que les
industriels elles veulent pas savoir qui
achète où il achète, qui a vendu et
cetera. Donc il y a certainement des
problèmes techniques à à résoudre. Mais
oui, c'est une bonne c'est vraiment une
bonne chose. Oui.
Alors question de Mickey Way.
Bonsoir. Connaissez-vous Yasmine Motard
Gémis ex-directrice qualité Nestley et
lanceur d'alerte aujourd'hui ?
Non mais ça m'intéresse de la connaître.
On la connaissait pas non plus.
Non non non mais si elle si elle lance
effectivement de
Alors question d'internet
un vrai missile un Exos 7 quelle action
a-t-il fait dont il est le moins fier ?
Quelle action j'ai fait dont je suis le
moins fier ?
J'ai j'ai voté pour un président qui a
été élu comme je le regrette.
Donc vous avez voté George Pompidou.
Non, je je peux pas vous dire, ce serait
trop dur.
Mais bon, le choix était difficile
aussi. Mais j'aurais dû voter blanc
finalement avec le recul.
Il sort avec sa maîtresse.
Hm.
Non, c'est c'est ce président là
et pour sa maîtresse, son épouse.
Oui. C'est assez c'est assez récent.
C'est assez récent. Mais bon.
Et pourquoi pas fier professionnellement
? Pourquoi vous en êtes pas fier ?
Oh bah par rapport à par rapport à tout
ce qui se dit, par rapport à enfin enfin
par rapport à tout ce qu'il fait. Tu dis
par exemple tout à l'heure, tu dis tiens
aujourd'hui on a jamais eu autant de
pauvres et c'est vrai, j'ai j'ai vu une
mais
c'est pas de sa faute, il est arrivé, il
y avait déjà le bordel.
Bah oui, mais si c'est si c'est jamais
de la faute de personne, à quoi ça sert
d'avoir des politiques et des présidents
? Si si c'est jamais de leur faute,
quoi. S'ils sont ils disent "Voter pour
moi et ça va changer." Et puis quand ils
sont là, ça change mais enfin pas dans
le bon sens quoi. Tu me dis aujourd'hui
il y a de plus en plus de pauvres. C'est
vrai, j'ai j'ai vu, il y avait il y a ça
pire qui était sur RT quand même.
Rends-toi compte que j'en suis revenu à
regarder RT maintenant.
Poutine, c'est ça ?
Mais je sais pas mais c'est la seule qui
me donne des informations qui me
semblent à peu près crédible. C'est
quand même grave quoi. Enfin bon, petite
parenthèse. Et
pourquoi ça vous semble un peu près
crédible ?
Bah quand quand avant j'étais j'écoutéis
pas mal BFM parce que je m'intéresse à
l'actualité économique et cetera.
J'écouté BFM du temps où il y avait
quelqu'un que j'aimais bien qui
s'appelle Liv de la marche. Tu tu la
connaître. Donc j'aimais bien ses
analyses et cetera et puis euh il a osé
la ramener, il s'est fait virer et il
est passé sur RT.
Ouais. Non, il il a massacré
l'économiste maison euh sur Twitter et
ça a pas plu euh au patron de soumier.
Non non,
je sais pas à qui mais ce qui ça veut
dire quoi ? c'est que c'est veut dire
que dans dans cette boutique, ils
avaient les seules voix un peu
dissidentes et qui disent les choses qui
sont des grandes gueules quelque part,
elles se font virer. Donc et quand tu
mets cette chaîne, quand je tombe dessus
par hasard, mais c'est c'est c'est une
c'est une chaîne de propagande quoi.
Quoi ? BFM ou RT ?
Bon, je veux pas les citer. Enfin bon,
moi aujourd'hui, je regarde RT mais
enfin il y a un moment si les gens n'ont
plus confiance dans dans ces chaînes
mainstream, on va dire françaises, c'est
que vraiment il y a il y a un vrai
problème d'objectivité. Donc revenons à
à notre président. Pourquoi vous
C'est pas ça la question au départ ?
Oui, c'était pourquoi voilà on parlait
on parlait des pauvres. Bah si juste un
simple constat, c'est que aujourd'hui tu
me dis il y a de plus en plus de pauvres
et la croissance elle a jamais été
négative en France. On a jamais une
récession depuis voilà depuis 2008. Ah
on est toujours en 1 et quelques pourc
de croissance.
Donc ça veut dire que le pays est de
plus en plus riche chaque année.
Riche de dettes.
Non le le GDP c'est pas les dettes. Le
GDP c'est c'est l'activité.
Les dettes c'est autre chose. Les dettes
c'est du c'est du stock. Le GDP c'est de
la production.
D'accord. Quand on met 10 dollars de
dette pour 1 dollar de de GDP de PIB h
oui, on s'en
sur du vent ou c'est de l'investissement
ou c'est quoi ?
Bah c'est qu'on vit au-dessus de nos
moyens. Non, c'est pas c'est pas de
l'investissement. On sait très bien que
c'est c'est la GABG J à tous les étages.
Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que cet
argent quelque enfin il va bien quelque
part. Toute l'injection que fait la la
les banques centrales européennes,
l'endettement les dettes que c'est la
dette d'un côté mais c'est une dépense
de l'autre. On s'endette pour pour
dépenser. Donc cet argent, il est bien
dépensé, il va bien quelque part.
Pourquoi Macron c'est pas un bon
président ?
Bah c'est un bon président pour ceux de
qui il sertent les intérêts.
Mais
le mec qui vit à Singapour,
la la déclaration fiscale, elle est en
France ou en expatrié là ?
Non, je suis pas expatrié, je suis en
contrat local. Je suis employé à
Singapour par une société
singapourienne. Je suis payé en monnaie
locale. J'habite sur Je paye mes impôts
sur place. Je paye mes impôts
la tranche maximale d'imposition locale
à 20 % si tu veux savoir
20 % c'est pas beaucoup.
Ouais mais c'est le maximum là-bas.
Considère que l'argent que tu gagnes,
ben quelque part il t'appartient sauf 20
% ce qui me paraît raisonnable.
Donc mais c'est c'est difficile comment
l'impôt sur revenu en France c'est
combien ? C'est 20 %.
Je sais pas je sais pas. Macr
c'est difficile de comparer parce qu'en
contrepartie il y a beaucoup de choses
que tu dois payer aussi par exemple
l'éducation des enfants les pas
sécurité sociale donc si on doit
comparer le le ce serait ce serait moins
je veux pas être trop sévère avec le
système français parce qu'il y a quand
même beaucoup d'avantages l'éducation
est gratuite donc on peut pas comparer
juste comme ça sur en donnant un chiffre
mais bon
donc Macron
bah il y a tellement il y a tellement à
dire donc là si on si on parlait des
pauvres des inégalités on peut pas dire
qu'en France les inégalités se se
réduisent on peut pas dire d'un côté On
va réduire le le le apl de de de 5 € ce
qui représente rien pour lui mais ce qui
représente beaucoup pour des gens qui
ont rien et puis d'un autre côté
augmenter l'indemnité logement des
parlementaires. Enfin c'est il y a un
moment où il faut être cohérent et on
parle souvent en politique c'est souvent
une affaire de symbole. Pareil quand on
a enfin une grande partie de la
population qui se révolte et qu'on est
aujourd'hui à un an de manifestation
qu'on est capable que de que de que
d'insulter les gens de les mépriser.
Il y a un moment il y a un problème. Il
faut quand même discuter avec les gens.
Il faut leur proposer des solutions.
C'est pas leur balancer 10 milliards
qu'on jette un os à un chien qui va les
calmer. Les gens sont pas idiots, les
gens sont éduqués. Pareil. Enfin, moi je
je vois enfin un truc intéressant.
Singapour 75 % de chinois, enfin des
gens de résine chinoise, ils suivent
énormément en ce moment ce qui se passe
à à Hong Kong.
Aujourd'hui, il y a moins de violence à
Hong Kong quasiment que ce qu'il y a de
violence en France sur les gilets
jaunes.
Bah, il y a à Hong Kong, il y a quand
même des tirs au bal réel.
Il y a un député qui s'est fait
poignarder. Euh il y a
en France en France il y a eu
il y a pas eu de tir au bal en France il
y a pas eu de députés polnés,
il y a des mains arrachées. Enfin voilà
quoi.
Enfin il y a un moment je m'attendais
pas du tout à voir ce genre de choses en
France quoi. Pas du tout. Moi, je suis
tombé enfin vraiment j'étais extrêmement
déçu par le non réponse à des des
réclamations, enfin des demandes qui me
semblent légitimes quoi. Les gens
veulent participer à la démocratie, les
gens veulent qu'on les écoute. Je vois
vraiment pas ce qu'il y a de scandaleux.
Enfin moi aujourd'hui, en plus j'en
parle, j'en parle ouvertement parce
qu'on peut dire que quelque part, je
suis plutôt un privilégié aujourd'hui,
mais c'est pas pour ça que je me
rappelle pas d'où je viens aussi. Donc
voilà, moi j'étais famille modeste,
boursier tant jeune. Je je dois beaucoup
à l'état, à l'éducation, à la formation
et cetera. Et il me semble normal de
partager les fruits de la croissance
quoi. Alors qu'aujourd'hui comme tu dis,
il y a de plus en plus de pauvres alors
que le produit enfin le pays est en
croissance toujours. Même si c'est que 1
% par an, c'est quand même 1 % par an.
Et il devrait pas y avoir de plus en
plus de pauvres. Ça devrait au moins
être stabilisé. Donc c'est bien quelque
part qu'il y a un problème de de de
gestion et de répartition des
recherches.
Ouais. Les gens qui ont du pouvoir en
veulent toujours plus mais ça fait plus
de 2000 ans que ça dure. Question
d'internet. Selon lui, quel est le pays
qui a les réglementations les plus
strictes ?
Bon, je pense que c'est l'Europe. Ça
reste l'Europe malgré tout.
L'Europe, c'est pas un pays.
Non, mais la réglementation aujourd'hui
à l'européenne, il y a plus de pays en
Europe. D'ailleurs, ça existe plus les
pays en Europe.
Quel est quel est aujourd'hui le enfin
qu'est-ce qu'on peut décider encore
localement en France ? La France a plus
de monnaie, bientôt on aura plus
d'armée,
quasiment plus d'industrie. Enfin,
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui nous reste
en terme de de souveraineté en France ?
Quoi ? Alors, une question totalement
sujet mais je vais quand même la poser.
Un avis sur l'abattage rituel et les
dérogations ?
L'abattage rituel
encore
bah
alors l'avocat c'est bien, c'est pas
bien ? L'avocat à manger, il y a des
trucs à se méfier ou pas ? Il y a un
documentaire sur Netflix en ce moment ?
très décrié parce que ouais, je sais que
c'est l'avocat très décrié parce que
c'est euh c'est pareil, c'est des
grandes monocultures. C'est un peu les
mêmes aussi le même problème que l'huile
de palme, que les oliviers ensuite de
l'Espagne. Enfin, quand on a une grande
monoculture, ça crée beaucoup de
problèmes. Ça crée des problèmes
écologiques. Mais il y a aussi des
problèmes sociaux. C'està-dire qu'il y a
beaucoup c'est l'avocat, il se fait par
exemple dans les pays comme le Mexique
où il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
violence et cetera.
Ouais.
Autre question d'internet. Bonjour. Euh
comment lutt-il contre les problèmes
qu'il fait remonter ?
Ouais. Est-ce que ça continue comme
avant ? Non, vous avez changé totalement
d'industrie. Vous êtes sur la croquette
pour chien en ce moment ? Non.
Non, je suis pour dans l'alimentation
animale mais pour les animaux de
d'élevage.
Ah,
pas des animaux de compagnie. Animaux
d'élevage, animaux qui sont destinés à
la consommation humaine.
D'accord.
Donc les poules, cochon, poulet, tout
ça.
Et
genre donc vous travaillez pour des
céréaliers ?
Non, je travaille pour une entreprise
qui fait des additifs naturels pour
l'alimentation.
C'est quoi des additifs naturels ? Ce
sont alors on a pas mal de gammes mort
pas mal de gammes de produits. C'est ce
qu'on appelle des phytogéniques. Comment
on appelle ça en anglais ? En français,
c'est des huiles essentiel en fait. Et
c'est censé remplacer dans certaines
dans certains cas les antibiotiques.
Ça peut être dangereux les huiles
essentielles non ?
Bah moins que les antibiotiques et c'est
beaucoup plus naturel. Alors si c'est
fait avec le bon dosage avec
parsimonie en faisant attention avec de
ce qu'on appelle de la biosécurité
autour de autour des élevages, c'est
censé en fait si vous voulez. C'est quoi
la biosécurité ? C'est quoi ça encore
que cette expression ? La biosécurité.
Alors raconte un peu. La biosécurité
c'est un petit peu biofortifié
des connaissez bullshit language c'est
du c'est du c'est du c'est des termes
techniques qu'on utilise entre nous
aussi.
D'accord. On va on va
entre nous là on n'est pas entre nous.
C'est comment s'assurer que les zones
d'élevage restent saines propre
c'estàdire on passe tout
qui pas de contam qui est pas d'épidémie
par voilà
on passe tout à palme. On fait quoi Non,
c'estd que par exemple on ferme les
bâtiments pour éviter que par exemple
dans un élevage de poulet un oiseau
sauvage rentre dans l'élevage ou fiante
dans les aliments des des animaux. On va
grillager pour pas que des rats ou des
des rongeurs puissent rentrer et
apporter des maladies. Euh, on va
demander aux employés de on va faire un
sas par exemple avec une zone de
décontamination, une combinaison et une
douche. Donc voilà, tu as des des un
mélange de de traitement mécanique.
Pareil quand on va euh changer de
d'élevage, c'estàd que quand on va par
exemple changer de de l'eau d'animaux,
on va tout nettoyer, tout désinfecter et
ensuite une fois que tout sera bien
propre et bien simple, contrôler,
remettre en place des animaux. Donc, ce
sont des mesures pour éviter justement
d'avoir à utiliser les antibiotiques
plus tard.
C'est à peu près les mêmes mesures que
quand vous faites pousser des tomates en
placard. C'est ça.
Non, c'est un joke mais il faut
comprendre. C'est c'est c'est
une blague suisse.
Non, c'est pas ça. C'est que aujourd'hui
quand tu as des des élevages industriels
parce que bon, alors en France, c'est
marrant, il y a enfin c'est marrant non,
en France, il y a le le la fameuse ferme
des 1000 vaches, d'accord ? Donc qui
fait scandale et cetera. Je crois que
c'est toujours pas, je sais pas si c'est
autorisé et cetera mais mais aujourd'hui
la plus grosse ferme c'est en Chine,
elle a 100000 vaches. Tu as des fermes
en Australie qui font 40000 vaches. En
États aux États-Unis, tu as des fermes à
4500 vaches. Donc ça c'est vraiment des
c'est c'est des usines à viande. Si tu
veux que dans ces fermes là les choses
se passent bien, soit tu as deux
solutions. Soit tu fais attention avant
qu'il y ait une épidémie, soit tu
matraques les animaux et les
antibiotiques parce que tu as tout le
temps des maladies, une épidémie en plus
ou moins en en gestation. Donc le fait
de faire attention avant de de mettre en
place ce qu'on appelle ces mesures de
biosécurité de de sécurité de barrière
si tu veux de de
pas de salle blanche mais tu vois de de
protection ça évite d'avoir à utiliser
des antibiotiques qui enfin qui ce qui
quand même est un problème plus
important puisquon parle de la de la
biorésistance et là on arrive à un
problème chez les humains où il y a des
gens qui meurent parce qu'ils sont plus
ils sont infectés par des bactéries
multirésistantes.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
de fausses bouffes vendu pour de la
vraie bouffe genre du riz mine plastique
ou des choses comme ça ? C'est un
canular ? C'est quoi une fake news ?
Je sais pas. On m'en a parlé à
Singapour, on m'en a beaucoup parlé
parce que là-bas c'est du riz matin,
midi et soir mais j'en ai jamais vu.
Donc je sais pas si c'est vrai ou faux.
J'en ai jamais vu. Euh la fausse bouffe,
bah il y a eu la la mélan la mélamine.
La mélamine était de la fausse bouffe.
Donc la mélamine ça a même commencé
avant le
C'est quoi la mélamine ? Ah ça c'était
c'est c'est le plus gros scandale qu'il
y a eu en Chine en fait ce qui s'est
passé.
Je sais pas vraiment non si si si je
Donc en gros en gros ce qui s'est passé
en Chine c'est que
quasiment tous les fabricants de lait
d'accord diluaient le lait à l'eau et
pour faire croire en fait qu'il y avait
que le lait était pur, il rajoutait de
l'azote
parce que en fait on pour vérifier que
le lait contient suffisamment de matière
sèche, on dose les protéines, d'accord ?
Mais on dose pas directement les
protéines, on dose l'azote qui est censé
être contenu dans les protéines puisque
les protéines sont sont des chaînes
d'acid amique qui contiennent de
l'azote. Donc on sait que si on dose du
lait, on doit trouver un certain niveau
d'azote. Donc ce qu'ils ont trouvé malin
de faire à ce moment-là, c'est de
rajouter de l'azote mais non alimentaire
qu'ils ont trouvé dans la mélamine. Donc
la mélamine, c'est ce qui sert à faire
le le formica. Donc c'est un produit
chimique de ces chimiques et ils en ont
mis partout dans les en poudre, dans les
yaourts, dans tout ce qui contait du
lait, dans les bonbons, dans les
biscuits, il y en avait absolument
partout. Et ça a posé le problème quand
ils ont commencé à en mettre dans le
lait en poudre pour les enfants. Je
crois qu'il y a eu 300000 bébés qui ont
été contaminés
et il y a eu, je crois, 50000
hospitalisations. Il y a eu je sais plus
combien de morts de bébés qui sont
décédés.
Magnifique.
Et ensuite ce qui s'est passé donc ça en
Chine, ça a été un scandale mais
absolument monstrueux. Ils ont arrêté
une quinzaine de personnes, il y a eu
deux condamnations à mort. Donc tu vois
qu'en Chine, c'est quand même assez
dissuasif. Et ils ont effectivement ils
ont ils ont ils ont je crois qu'il il
les ont ils ont fusillé ou tué avec une
balle. Deux personnes ont été tuées à
cause de cette affaire-là. Et ensuite ça
a tellement eu un retentissant important
chez les Chinois qu'ils ont commencé à
importer du lait en poudre de partout
dans le monde et c'est c'est ça qui a
lancé la consommation de de lait en
poudre et de de produits laiti notamment
en Chine.
Une autre question.
On a vu certains paquets de gâteaux
diminuer de volume.
Ouais, mais pas que.
Et et augmenter en prix pour certains ou
pour maintenir le prix.
Est-ce que c'est une technique des des
des industriels pour masquer la la
réelle inflation ou
bien sûr ? C'estàd que
quand vous avez baissé la qualité, quand
vous avez il y a un moment vous pouvez
plus tellement jouer sur quoi que ce
soit pour baisser encore les prix.
Donc une des dernières astuces,
je sais pas si c'est une astuce très
intelligente puisqueen fait les
consommateurs souvent se rendent compte,
c'est de baisser le grammage. Alors on
baisse le grammage soit dans des pots,
soit dans des biscuits, on baisse le
diamètre et effectivement on en met
moins et on et on laisse le prix
inchanger. Donc il y a effectivement une
marque du biscuit très célèbre qui où
ils sont passés de je sais plus de 300
300 g le paquet de biscuits à 280 ou
250. Euh il y a les pots de yaourt
aujourd'hui qui qui beaucoup de pot de
yaourt ne font plus 125 g comme les
comomisé avant mais on est à 115 110
voire 100 g. Tablettes de chocolat. Il y
a beaucoup de tables de chocolat aussi
aujourd'hui qui sont passé à au lieu de
100 g qui sont passés à 90 voire 85.
Donc en fait oui, c'est une astuce pour
pour gruger le consommateur. Et ce qui
est encore plus drôle c'est que
auparavant, à l'époque où les pouvoirs
publics nous protégeait un minimum, il
était interdit de vendre les produits
alimentaires autrement que par fraction
de kilo. C'est-à-dire, tu devais vendre
soit au kilo, soit à 750 g, 500 g, 450,
200 g, 100 g. Tu pouvais pas vendre un
produit, te dire tiens allez tiens, je
vais te le faire à 30 g, 50 g, 52 g et
cetera. Donc ça c'est passé à la trappe,
je plus 2007 de mémoire à vérifier. Et
maintenant on peut faire absolument ce
qu'on veut.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour lutter
contre les formules complètement creuses
des services de marketing ?
Bah il faut pas il faut pas être naïf.
Il faut la seule chose à regarder, c'est
la liste d'ingrédients déjà. Donc on
peut si on la comprend pas, on peut
céder avec une application ou
éventuellement avec le score, mais il
faut absolument oublier les belles
illustrations.
Moi, je prends toujours comme exemple la
fameuse pâte à tartiner où on voit des
noisettes et du lait, mais les deux
ingrédients majeurs, c'est de l'huile et
du sucre. La pâte à tartiner, c'est une
émulsion de poudre dans de l'huile.
C'est ça qu'il faut c'est c'est des
poudres micronisées dans de l'huile.
Donc il y a de la poudre de a du sucre
en poudre, ingrédient numéro 1. Il y a
du des noisettes à 13 % ingrédient
numéro 2. Et il y a un peu de lait. Mais
c'est essentiellement de l'huile et du
sucre. Mais sur l'illustration, vous
voyez du lait et des noisettes. Donc ça
c'est typiquement une une astuce ou une
arnaque marketing diraient certains.
Mais c'est le cas pour tous les
produits. Donc il faut faire attention
aux illustrations, il faut faire
attention aux mentions. On a parlé tout
à l'heure des allégations, des
allégations qui sont trompeuses. Labell
les labelles.
Des labels. Oui, il y a des labels
inventés, vous savez des labels. Par
exemple, moi je me rappelle, on en
acheté de ça. Euh, vous savez où on dit
"Ouais, le produit a été élu
produit d'année."
Voilà. En général, c'est meilleur. Non
mais non, c'est du bullshit complet. Ça
c'est c'est complètement faux. Ça se
paye ça ça s'achète. C'est c'est ces
trucs là typiquement élu par des
consommateurs et cetera, c'est des
marques commerciales. Ça appartient à
des à des sociétés.
Donc si si tu as un produit que tu veux
que tu veux avoir le logo dessus machin,
tu dis voilà j'ai un nouveau produit.
Alors un nouveau produit c'est facile he
tu fais une nouvelle recette, tu fais un
nouveau logo, un nouveau design, un
nouveau nom, enfin un truc un truc bidon
alors que le produit a pas changé. Tu
dis voilà, c'est un nouveau produit que
je lance. Mais tu verras qu'ils vont
trouver des des trois consommateurs qui
vont voter pour toi. Tu auras le logo,
tu vas payer la contribution et puis tu
auras tu auras ton produit en rayon. Et
voilà. Mais ça c'est typiquement des
logos qui qui qui t'apportent aucune
aucune valeur ajoutée, aucune indication
sur la qualité réelle du produit.
Mais il y a il y a par exemple quand tu
vois nous on mettait par exemple qualité
garantie mais garantie par qui ? Par
personne par nous. Euh fraîcheur
garantie. Mais fraîcheur garantie pareil
par qui ? Par personne. Par nous. Donc
voilà, tu tu as plein de de mention
comme ça qui veulent rien dire, qui
engage.
Je vais juste faire une parenthèse pour
notre communauté qui est en train de
nous envoyer des questions sur Discord.
Merci de respecter le forum question et
pas aller discuter avec
Envoyez-nous juste les questions sur le
Discord, merci. Sinon, on va bannir à
coup de hache.
Et eh les abattoirs, bon, c'est pas
votre rayon. Non, je pas
leage. Alors le fromage, il y a du vrai
fromage. Pas de vrai fromage, du faux
fromage.
Pas du faux fromage, on dit de
l'analogue.
Ah bah oui quand même, faut être précis.
On dit pas corruption, on dit lobby et
on dit pas faux fromage. On dit analogue
fromage ou du fromage analogue plutôt,
c'est le bon terme.
C'est quoi ? C'est quoi ?
Bah c'est pas du fromage. C'est alors
dans le fromage, il y a il y a il y a
vraiment il y a de tout. C'estàd qu'il y
a du bon fromage, du vrai fromage
naturel fait à l'ancienne dans les
normes, fromage au lait cru et cetera.
Un produit excellent nickel. Bon, ça
c'est des normes françaises. La France
est obligé de se battre pour pour on va
dire dans la tradition. D'accord. Un bon
fromage français, un camember roulé cru,
un fromage d'ossé,
c'est dangereux.
C'est dangereux.
Rendez pas compte aux États-Unis, c'est
interdit. C'est trop dangereux.
Il y a plus de gens qui qui meurent
aujourd'bouffe que que de manger du bon
fromage.
Il y a plus de gens qui crèvent de
Kalashnikov que de Camemberbert.
Exactement.
Donc
la vie est dangereuse. On finit toujours
par en mourir. Mais il y a un moment
enfin moi je vois je me vois pas
consommer autre chose que du fromage au
cru par exemple. Sinon s'il y a pas de
plaisir à quoi ça sert ? Autant manger
je sais pas moi, de la purée ou
donc l'analogue.
Donc alors il y a le fromage, le vrai
fromage. Après vous avez des fromages
industriels au lait pasteurisés et
cetera. En fait ils veulent pas
s'embêter. Ils fabriquent un produit
industriel bas de gamme standard.
Ils veulent pas d'accident de
fabrication. Ils veulent pas que ce soit
compliqué. C'est une recette, un
process. C'est tant de minutes à telle
de telle température, tant de minutes
dans la cuve, tant de minutes, on
soutire, on conditionne, on envoie. Donc
voilà. Donc pour faire ça, il faut
standardiser. On reçoit le lait, on le
standardise, on met les germes
pour le standardiser
à une époque à une époque il mélangeait
des lots de lait, à une époque, ils
mettaient même de l'eau. Ils ont été
condamnés parce qu' on disait qu'il
mouillaient le lait et eux, ils disaient
qu'il standardisaient. Mais ça se fait
plus ça normalement, paraît-il. Donc
maintenant, ils mélangent des lots avec
des teneurs de matière grasse et des
teneurs de
de essentiellement de matière grasse
différente et de protéines différentes.
Donc ceuxlà, ils vont l'ensemancer, ils
vont d'abord le pasteuriser. Donc ils
vont tuer les germes, les bactéries,
ensuite ils vont mettre une souche
sélectionnée et ça ils vont le faire
fermenter. Donc ça va faire un produit
bah tous les fromages industriels qu'on
voit hein qui de grande consommation qui
sont pas c'est pas mauvais mauvais enfin
c'est pas bon quoi. C'est un fromage pas
de caractère, pas d'âme, pas de corps.
Camber.
Ouais voilà, un produit industriel
basique
euh pas spécial pas vendu spécialement
bon marché d'ailleurs pour ce que c'est
mais ça reste du vrai ça reste du vrai
fromage. Et ensuite vous avez toutes les
préparations fromageères. Donc vous avez
le fromage fondu. Nous on en utilisait
beaucoup donc tout ce qui est
préparation industrielle donc on en
mettait dans les sauces par exemple pour
faire des des sauces des sauces au
rockfort des sauces au bleu des sauces
voilà tom vous avez aussi tout ce qui
est préparation industrielle type cordon
bleu fromage à pizza. Alors là, vous
pouvez utiliser du fromage fondu, donc
qui contient du vrai fromage. Vous
pouvez utiliser du des préparations
fromageères qui contient moins de
fromage et plus d'additifs. Donc le
fromage fonduit contient quand même déjà
un peu d'additif, notamment les selles
de fond.
C'est quoi les selles de fonte ?
Selles de fond, c'est des additifs qui
permettent de d'avoir d'intégrer de
l'eau au produit.
Donc vous mettez du fromage mais pour
que ça baisse en prix, vous mettez de
l'eau. Mais pour que ça tienne ensemble,
vous mettez des salles de fondte. C'est
un genre de de liant si vous voulez.
Donc ça permet d'avoir un un produit qui
se tient. Après, vous pouvez rajouter
des poudres de lèit, vous pouvez
rajouter du beurre, enfin voilà,
d'autres ingrédients un peu laitiers
pour avoir un fromage fondu. Ça c'est
réglementé. Après, vous avez la
préparation de laitière, donc où on
baisse encore la teneur en fromage et
vous pouvez mettre d'autres produits
éventuellement, je sais pas, des huiles
végétales, tout ce que vous voulez. Ça
reste encore un produit vaguement
fromagé et à la fin vous avez l'analogue
qui plus qui est plus du tout du
fromage. Alors là, on remplace
complètement le fromage par des huiles.
On met de l'amidon, enfin on met des
texturants pour que ça prenne en bloc.
On met éventuellement un petit peu de
colorant pour ça une couleur un petit
peu un petit peu jaune, un peu jaune
paille, voyez, un petit peu couleur
beurre. On met éventuellement des
arômes, ça fait un bloc. Ça on le rappe
et on le balance sur une pizza et ça ça
ça va très bien pour les gens qui font
des produits de de mauvaise qualité.
Et c'est et sur l'emballage, il y a
marqué quoi ? analogue de fromage.
Non non, il va y avoir marqué la liste
des ingrédients. C'est par exemple, vous
allez trouver huile végétale, vous allez
trouver euh peut-être selle de fond,
amidon, voilà, vous allez trouver la
composition. Mais je pense que le terme
analogue, je pense qu'il figure pas à
vérifier. Et quand vous allez acheter
une une pizza chez un vous allez dans un
restaurant ou autre ou dans un camion
sur le bord d'une route ou autre, vous
savez pas ce qui met.
Donc vous voyez ça, c'est pareil. Je
critique pas mal les métiers de bouche,
restaurateur, boulanger et cetera qui
étaient nos clients. Donc je peux en
parler d'autant plus facilement parce
que nous on vendait non seulement à la
grande distribution, on vendait au fast
food et on vendait aussi au
professionnels.
Boulanger,
boulanger, pâtissier, petit, gros,
moyen, enfin on vendait à tout le monde
quoi. Ces produitsl
c'est quoi petit ? C'est deux quartiers.
Oui. De de petit. Enfin, on vendait à un
distributeur qui vendait, par exemple,
un distributeur départemental original
qui vendait sur une zone, on lui vendait
des produits et lui il vendait au petit
boulanger ou au petit pâtissier du coin.
Et quand on avait des des des
industriels, même des petites
industrielles qui faisaient, je sais pas
moi, des des vieilles noiseries surgelé
ou des choses comme ça, on leur vendait
aussi nos produits. Donc
donc on vendait, il y a aussi des
distributeurs pour les professionnels.
Par exemple, vous avez métro, promoche
qui qui vendent à des des restaurateurs.
Donc, on vendit aussi à ces gens-là.
vous vend à métro, c'est ça ?
Oui, à métro et à promocage par exemple.
Donc différents types de produits, ça
pouvait être des épices, ça pouvait être
ces produits là. Donc donc ce que je
veux dire, c'est qu'on touchait vraiment
tout le monde, tous les circuits de
distribution.
Donc le le professionnel de de quartier
est aussi responsable d'utiliser
Bah bien sûr, même mais même j'allais
dire c'est souvent plus grave chez les
professionnels parce que ils sont pas
tenus de vous montrer la liste
d'ingrédients. Tu vas dans une pizzeria,
tu commandes une pizza, on t'amène une
pizza. tu sais pas ce qu'il y a dedans.
Même souvent moi quand je suis allé au
restaurant, j'ai vu des produits
industriels, je les ai vu même j'en
parle dans dans j'en parle de de dans
dans le dernier que j'ai fait parce que
je suis allé quelque part, j'ai reconnu
nos produits et j'ai même discuté avec
le chef après et je lui ai dit tiens,
j'ai reconnu nos fagots, il m dit ah oui
c'est
fagot
c'est des fagot d'asperge. C'est des
produits qu'on faisait nous chez nous.
C'estàd c'est des on achetait les
asperges vertes surgelées du Pérou.
On avait un lien c'était un lien végétal
cit de la ciboulette ou du ou de l'ail.
On faisait des fagots et on mettait une
une rendelle de poitrine fumée autour.
On roulait ça et on surgelait.
On les a vu ceuxlà. Ouais.
Voilà. Donc ces produits là, on faisait
ça, on faisait des fagot d'asperge, on
faisait des fagotes de haricot vert, on
faisait des
Quel est le problème ? C'est des bons
produits, pas des bons produits.
Oui, mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que
quand j'ai demandé à la à la serveuse,
j'ai dit vous Il me dit "Oui, c'est tout
est frais, tout est des produits de
marché." J'ai pris le menu de marché
d'ailleurs. Mais
moi j'étais avec un copain gen on
faisait du vélo ensemble et lui il avait
que du feu. Mais moi je le connaissais
ce produit, c'est moi qui l'avais
développé. J'en voilà, j'en avais vu des
des containers et des containers. Donc
je savais très bien. Dès que je l'ai vu,
je l'ai reconnu. Donc quand j'ai discuté
avec le gars qui on a commencé à parler
m' expliqué oui ouais ça marche bien,
c'est super ce produit là. J'en prends
un, j'en prends deux. Et oui, mais pour
lui, il me dit "Mais te rends pas
compte, je le paye, je sais pas, je le
paye 50 centimes si je devais le
fabriquer, mais je per déjà moi aussi
cher les ingrédients. Plus il me
faudrait quelqu'un qui sache les faire,
j'auraiis des pertes, je devrais les
faire frais." Je prends ma barquette, je
l'ouvre, j'en prends le nombre qui m'en
faut, je les fa je l' fais un petit peu
de minutes à la poêle, je te les ser
tout le monde est content.
Donc juste ce que je veux dire c'est que
souvent chez les professionnels, c'est
pire que dans la grande distribution. Et
même tiens justement
je parle de ce restaurateur là justement
et on faisait aussi donc on avait une
toute petite gamme de fond de sauce
déshydraté. Donc c'est quand par exemple
tu vas au restaurant et que tu vas te
consommer des tu vas prendre un poisson
au beurre blanc, c'est sauce
hollandaise, choses comme ça ou bien un
civ sauce chasseur et cetera. Bon alors
il y a différentes façons de faire les
sauces. Soit tu l' fait toi, enfin un
cuisinier, un bon cuisinier va te faire
la sauce vraiment dans dans la rue de
l'art. Soit tu prends une poudre, tu
mets de la flotte, tu fais chauffer, ça
fait de la sauce.
Mais
je connaissais très bien les sauces on
en faisait nous et la sauce que qu'on
m'avait servi ce jour-là, j'ai demandé
au gars, donc on a discuté le même, il
m'a dit voilà, j'ai pris la sauce
d'intel. Je oui, je la connais, c'est le
leader du marché forcément. Et sur mon
bouquin, je donne la composition de ces
sauce là. Mais cette sauce là, tu ne la
retrouverais pas en supermarché parce
que la composition est trop pourrie.
Personne ne l'achèterait. Un
pourri en quel sens ?
Mais elle contient par exemple un
ingrédient que dont personne ne veut.
Elle contient des huiles hydrogénées.
Plus personne ne veut bouffer des huiles
hydrogénées aujourd'hui. Mais le
restaurateur lui, ça le dérange pas d'en
acheter pour la faire manger à ses
clients puisque le client ne le sait
pas.
Donc tu prends un fond de sauce
déshydraté de cette marque là, tu vas
trouver
huile végétale hydrogénée et tu vas
prendre en supermarché un produit de
cette même marque là, de ce même
fabricant, il y aura pas d'huile
végétale hydrogénée parce qu'il sait
très bien que les consommateurs en
veulent pas.
Et ce genre de fabricant qui par
ailleurs à une fondation, qui part
ailleurs finance des gens et cetera et
cetera,
faut pas dire qu'il fasse de la qualité.
C'est quoi ? C'est pour tenir un marché
pour permettre à à des petits des petits
commerçants de survivre plus facilement.
C'est pour être moins cher. Alors la
motivation des des des la motivation du
restaurateur c'est c'est c'est libre à
lui. Je peux pas juger. Je connais pas
leur situation. Mais moi ce qu'on me dit
quand j'ai posé la question, le mec me
dit "Mais tu te rends pas compte ? Je
pourrais pas les faire ces produits là.
Ça coûterait beaucoup trop cher. C'est
beaucoup moins cher et en plus il pas
besoin de savoir faire." Il m'a dit
"Moi, mon aide, mon aide il a jamais
fait de cuisine quoi." Il m'a dit "Avant
mon aide, il était il faisait quand
c'est la touristique qui est terminée,
il va faire les vendes après il part, je
sais pas dans quelle station faire je
sais pas trop quoi." Donc le mec, il a
aucun savoir-faire culinaire.
Question d'internet, quels sont les
indicateurs de qualité auxquels il se
fit ?
Euh certains labels, notamment le label
bio parce que bah parce que c'est mieux
que rien et je sais que c'est quand même
contrôler. Donc il y a des organismes
comme Écosert par exemple, il a 7 ou H8
en France qui contrôlent ça. Donc il y a
un référentiel, c'est officiel. Donc moi
je consomme des produits bio autant que
je peux. Donc j'ai plutôt tendance
confiance enfin tendance à faire
confiance à ce label là. Il m'arrive
aussi souvent de prendre des produits
Maxavlard, des produits comme ça parce
que je sais que c'est un label
relativement sérieux. Moi je travaillais
avec Maxavlard dans certaines
entreprises où j'étais. Il y a pas eu de
des problèmes avec ces label
et coresponsable ou je sais pas quoi.
Non, il a jamais
bah il y en a plusieurs. Il y a Maxlard
mais ils sont pas les seuls.
Donc moi Maxlard, je l'ai j'ai travaillé
avec eux. Je il y avait bon il y avait
une bonne traçabilité.
J'ai pas grand-chose à dire mais
ça fait partie enfin je peux me le
permettre et puis je enfin à mon niveau
donner un peu plus d'argent pour que les
personnes vivent dignement ça me dérange
pas quoi.
Clairement.
Donc donc voilà donc oui enfin pour
répondre à la question certains label
euh et puis bah moi la liste
d'ingrédients quoi. J'ai voilà je il
faut il faut lire la liste
d'ingrédients, il faut regarder. Mais
alors les gens vont vous dire ouais mais
c'est chiant c'est
il faut la comprendre aussi hein.
Ouais il faut la comprendre. Mais après
il faut on peut aussi se renseigner on
peut tu vois par exemple tu dis
la passivité intellectuelle du
consommateur.
Ouais ouais mais pas que pour ça pour
pour un peu tout. Pour un peu tout. On
parlait de politique tout à l'heure on
parlait de voilà il faut s'informer. Il
faut se renseigner. On dit on dit on euh
on a les politiques qu'on mérite.
Est-ce qu'on peut dire on a la bouffe
qu'on mérite ?
Quelque part. Ouais, quelque part.
Quelque part quand même. Mais quelque
part enfin et c'est aussi en train de
changer. C'est que j'ai vu mon premier
bouquin est paru en 2015, le 2e en 2018
et j'ai vu en quoi 3 4 ans que les
choses ont beaucoup changé en France.
quand j'ai discuté enfin les les
discours que j'avais, le dialogue que
j'avais et cetera sont complètement
différents maintenant il y a 3 4 ans.
Donc ça change ça change relativement
vite. Donc il y a beaucoup il y a de
plus en plus de bios dans les magasins.
Les gens ont quand même compris les
produits ont disparu des rayons des
supermarchés comme les hues hydrogéné.
Il y a bi il y a il y a il y a bio.
Ouais il il y a encore à améliorer mais
il faut pas enfin il faut pas vouloir
passer
les industriels sont ont quand même
sauté sur le truc du bio pour pour se
faire du blé aussi. Non
mais tout le monde les industriels les
distributeurs, ils ont tous sauté sur le
truc du bio quand ils ont commencé. Moi,
je me rappelle il y a au tout début du
bio, ça intéressait absolument pas mes
patrons de faire du bio. Ça n'avait rien
à faire. Il y avait pas les volumes, il
y avait machin. Qu'est-ce qu'on allait
faire du bio ? Pourquoi faire ? C'est
c'était des coûts supplémentaires, il y
avait pas voilà donc on l'a pas fait.
Les ceux qui avaient vraiment de la
motivation, les gens qui croyaient ce
qu'il faisaient, c'est les c'est les
précurseurs du bio. Ce ceux qui ont fait
du bio au tout début, ces gens-là, ils y
croyaient. C'est certainement des gens
qui si je devais acheter des marques,
oui, je prendrais plutôt les marques des
précurseurs. Mais quand vous avez des
marques distributeurs aux industriels
qui se mettent dans le bio les dernier,
c'est que bon voilà, il il se raccroche
au wagon pour faire Oui, parce qu'il y a
il y a un marché et puis en plus qui est
plutôt lucratif.
On connaît les les les enquêtes qu'on
fait que choisir sur les marges de la
grande distribution sur le bio et on
sait qu'elles sont absolument
scandaleuses.
C'est quoi une marge acceptable ?
Une marge acceptable. une marge
acceptable, ça
que le producteur arrive à vivre, que le
consommateur se fait pas entuber euh et
que et que l'industriel fait pas, c'est
c'est difficile, ça dépend
ça dépend de la taille de l'entreprise,
ça dépend dans l'agroie alimentaire en
général, je parle au niveau industriel
que je connais, moi les marges sont
plutôt faibles, donc on compense sur les
volumes, mais comme on fait des volumes,
on fait des qualités souvent assez
médiocres.
Donc quelque part, le consommateur va
pas forcément s'y retrouver. Il va pas
il va payer des produits relativement
peu chers mais pour une qualité assez
médiocre et les gens vont avoir des
marges plutôt petites. Euh ce qui est
assez scandaleux, c'est c'est que oui,
il y a des marges abusives sur les
produits sains comme par exemple les
produits bio. Alors, les supermarchés se
gavent, oui, c'est clair. Les
industriels aussi en profitent en tant
qu'à faire. Euh mais l'État se gêne pas
non plus. Enfin, il y a pas de de
comment dire de TVA inférieur pour les
produits bios par exemple. Pourquoi pas
?
Ce serait ce serait une bonne piste.
Bah ce serait une parmi d'autres. Ce
serait pas une ce serait pas miracle
mais ça donnerait un petit coup de
pouce, ça aiderait. Euh alors je sais
qu'il y a des il y a des aides de l'État
pour la conversion pour le notamment
ceux qui veulent passer donc de de
conventionnel en bio. Donc oui, il il y
a certainement il
ne touchent pas tous leurs aides au bon
moment.
Je suis pas spécialiste, je je saurais
pas dire. Ce que je veux dire, c'est que
c'est pas ou tout noir ou tout blanc. Il
y a quand même certainement des choses
qui se qui se font. Euh mais la marge
acceptable, c'est super difficile à
définir parce que il y a des gens qui
ont besoin de beaucoup de marge parce
qu' la marge c'est pas aussi c'est pas
de l'argent que tu te mets dans la poche
pour aller le placer en Suisse. La marge
ça te sert aussi à investir, à racheter
des machines, ça te sert à bien payer
tes employés. Ça te sert en théorie
quand même un peu. Oui. Bon, ça va plus
dans la poche de l'actionnaire que dans
la poche des salariés. Mais bon, oui,
ben alors là, tu m'entraînes sur des sur
des sur des comment dire des
considérations qui sont bien éloignées.
Autre question internet. Existe-t-il des
pressions pour éviter que le vrac ne
devienne trop à la mode ?
Pas que je sache. Pas que je sache
peut-être, mais j'en ça, j'en suis pas
au courant.
Alors, que pensez-il de l'arrivée de
gros fonds étrangers, notamment asiatiqu
dans les vignobles français risque de
perte sur les marchés à terme ?
De perte sur les marchés
à terme
h de perte. Pourquoi ? parce qu'ils vont
racheter des vignobles, pour eux, c'est
un investissement. Donc je pense qu'ils
vont vouloir les rentabiliser.
Donc euh
que l'investisseur soit chinois,
américain ou russe euh ça reste un
investisseur qui veut faire de l'argent.
Donc euh et en plus les Chinois ont
quand même cet avantage, c'est queils
ont dès qu'un chinois a de l'argent, si
la première chose qu'il veut, c'est un
passeport étranger,
c'est de la bouffe. Il investit dans de
la bouffe un restaurant
dès qu'il a de l'argent. Oui,
dès qu'il a suffisamment d'argent, ce
qu'il veut c'est parti s'quitter, enfin
c'est avoir un passeport étranger et
ensuite mettre son argent, sortir son
argent de Chine pour la placer à
l'étranger. C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
les Chinois, ils essaient de verrouiller
et que le bitcoins est aussi populaire
en Chine.
Donc voilà, moi j'ai plein d'amis
chinois, je travaillais avec la Chine
depuis depuis 25 ans. J'ai plein d'amis
chinois, ils me disent "Ah, c'est j'ai
réussi à avoir à être Pierre à
Singapour, à être résident à Singapour,
c'est bon, j'ai envoyé ma fille machin,
j'ai monté ma société et dès que je
peux, je vais être citizen, je vais être
citoyen."
Mais tous, ils font ça, ils achètent des
passeports. Voilà. Mal
com ça vaut combien ça vaut ?
Ça vaut à peu près dans les 500000 €. Ça
ça dépend des pays. Si vous voulez
acheter un passeport à mal, c'est à peu
près dans les 500000 €. Si vous pouz en
acheter à éviter, je sais plus comment
il s'appelle. Voilà, si vous avez entre
500000 voir moins, oui, 500000 € pour
avoir un passeport étranger.
Ça s'achète comment ?
Vous faites une demande officielle et
vous faites voilà, vous faites une
demande.
C'est un investissement sur place ou
c'est c'est ou c'est dans la poche du
Je connais qu'une personne qui a qui a
obtenu un passeport mal. Il m'a pas dit
tout le détail.
Je sais qu'il a loué une maison sur
place, qu'il y a allé deux trois fois,
qu'il a un avocat sur place qui s'en est
occupé. qu'il a dû faire plein de
dossiers et plein de paper et qu'il a dû
payer.
Voilà, ça c'est pour cette ce pays-là.
Euh j'ai vu un reportage, je l'ai pas vu
personnellement, mais j'ai vu un
reportage d'un gars de la tomate qui
avait acheté un passeport à
Saint Nieves. Saint Nieves, c'est une
île Saintvest
dans les Caraïbes.
Ouais, c'est ça. Une petite île dans les
Caraïbes qui vit beaucoup de ça. Et pour
avoir son passeport, il a dû faire un ce
qu'ils appellent un
investissement non récupérable.
Il a eu dû payer 500000 en
investissement qui récupère pas. qu'en
fait celui du pays quoi. Et en échanger,
il a un passeport de cette de cette
localité. Mais c'est beaucoup moins
intéressant qu'un passeport d'un pays
européen qui te permet d'avoir accès au
à toute l'Europe.
Autre question internet. Quel est le
plus gros scandale alimentaire selon
l'invité de ces 20 dernières années ?
Le plus gros scandale alimentaire. Alors
bah on a parlé de la mélamine en Chine,
c'était certainement le plus
retentissant.
Euh si plus près de nous, plus près de
nous plus près de nous.
Il y en a quand même beaucoup hein. Moi
je j'ai le fibrony en tête. Alors c'est
c'est un truc qui me ça me
parce que parce que ce fibronil c'est
pas forcément le pire mais c'est le plus
caractéristique et le plus visible.
C'estàd que enfin on les prend la main
dans le sac quoi.
On on voit tout ce qui s'est passé. On
voit que que vraiment le but c'est de
protéger le business
et euh et c'est pas un scandale quelque
part alimentaire, c'est plutôt un
scandale politico-financier quelque
part. Ça aurait pu très bien être un
scandale sur les les voitures truquées
ou tu vois c'est l'alimentaire c'est un
support comme un autre. Ce qui se passe,
c'est que les politiques et les
industriels s'arrangent toujours pour
étouffer les scandales. Donc le FIP
Pronil est un bon exemple et au niveau
des scandales pour la santé, ben il il y
en a plein. C'estd que si on regarde les
20 dernières années,
moi je j'ai commencé ma carrière ouais
il y a 25 ans. Donc voilà, en 20 ans,
j'ai vu les cas d'obésité et de diabète
exploser et c'est pas fini. On est qu'au
début des épidémies aujourd'hui. Donc on
va voir les des on va avoir du des des
des taux de diabète de type 2 qui vont
commencer à exploser maintenant.
Quelles sont vos sources ? Bah c'est
sources, c'est les études américaines
qui sont avec quelques années d'avance
par rapport à nous et puis les études
les plus récentes montrent que ça ça
monte comme ça. Donc si étude américaine
ah je sais plus, j'ai j'ai dû les citer
dans mon bouquin, il faut regarder. Il y
a des il y a des euh il y a des un truc
intéressant, juste une petite
parenthèse, tu me parles des sources et
c'est un truc que moi j'avais pas
conscience au début quand j'ai commencé
à écrire mon bouquin et j'avais comme
conseil quelqu'un qui s'appelle Éric Mro
qui était directeur d'une école de
journalisme.
Je sais tu les aimes pas trop mais quand
même ce gars-là m'a dit écoute tout ce
que tu dis
tu le prouves, tu le sources, tu
l'expliques, tu le montre. Donc c'est ce
que j'ai fait pour le premier bouquin et
c'est ce que j'ai fait pour le deuxième.
Donc tout ce que je dis, je cherche les
études que j'ai trouvé ou ce que j'ai vu
moi-même, je lu dis voilà, je l'ai vu.
Donc la source c'est où moi ou les
études que je peux trouver. Mais sur les
épidémies d'obésité, tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que c'est que en
plein dedans, que les les courbes
d'épidémie c'est des c'est des courbes
qui sont connues partout. Enfin, c'est
des trucs qui sont il y a des modèles
qui existent depuis très longtemps et on
sait qu'on est en début d'épidémie.
Il y a il y a Voras qui a débarqué euh
Voras qui devait être au travail. Est-ce
qu'il discutait avec ses collègues de
l'impact des prix d'achat sur le taux de
suicide des agriculteurs ?
Non, parce que on nachetait jamais nous
aux agriculteurs en fait. On achetait à
des entreprises
de première trans B. Non, parce que pour
nous l'agriculteur, c'est quelqu'un
qu'on a jamais rencontré, qu'on
connaissait pas. On avait j'avais pas de
contact avec l'agriculteur.
Donc pour nous,
c'est à ce point déshumanisé.
C'est pas déshumanisé mais c'est
compartimenté quoi. C'est
en fait l'agriculteur pour nous il
existait pas parce qu'on il était on le
voyait pas, on avait pas de contact avec
eux. Moi les gens que je voyais
c'étaient mes fournisseurs. Mes
fournisseurs c'était d'autres
industriels. Par exemple, j'acheté de la
tomate à les industriels de la tomate.
J'ai acheté du jambon à des industriels
de la charcuterie. J'achetais de l'huile
à des industriels de l'huile
mais
ouais mais tu lisais le journal,
tu voyais bien que queil y avait des des
suicides chez les agriculteurs. Tu
voyais bien que
Ouais. Oui oui oui. Mais bon, qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit en général ? Ce qu'on
vous dit en général, c'est que les prix
sont pas assez élevés, que les
supermarchés les pressures et cetera.
Donc ouais, on pense un peu comme ça
aussi. On se dit "Ouais, on voit nous,
enfin dans notre image, c'est que le
cultivateur qui mène son ses produits
frais au supermarché qui les vend, qui
se fait assassiner.
Mais
mais nous enfin les produits que moi
j'achetais, c'était souvent des produits
de la de la grosse industrie. C'est pas
du tout les par exemple quand j'achè la
tomate de Chine, je dis il y a deux
fabricants en Chine, Kovko et Chalkis.
C'est des multinationales où il y a des
dizaines de milliers d'employés. C'est
c'est pas il y a pas de petits
producteurs derrière. Et même, on
pourrait en parler beaucoup. Il faudrait
lire le livre de de Malais sur la sur la
tomate en Chine pour savoir vraiment
comment ça se passe sur place. travail
des enfants, les esclaves, les gourours
et cetera. Enfin, il il y aurait
vraiment à dire sur ces pays-là.
Donc euh
donc nous le paysan, il existait pas. Et
quand j'achetais de l'huile par exemple,
j'achetis de l'huile à des gros
huiliers, des gens comme Cargil, comme
ADM, comme le Suur des Et pour moi, ces
gens-là sont pas des petits des petits
paysans. Qui a qui qui a derrière ? J'en
sais rien en fait. Est-ce que c'est des
petits paysans qui les livrent ? Est-ce
que c'est eux-mêmes qui possèdent leur
champs et cetera ? J'en sais trop rien.
Et toi, ça te fait quoi de voir un
agriculteur qui se suicide parce que il
est à 300 balles par mois que
Ben moi, je comprends pas. C'estàd que
bah évidemment humainement c'est c'est
dramatique mais même je comprends pas.
C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui, on n
jamais consommé autant de bouffe. La
population n'arrête pas d'augmenter.
Il y a un marché, enfin
il y a de moins en moins d'agriculteurs.
Ouais, mais c'est toujours pareil, c'est
que le en fait ce qui s'est passé, c'est
qu'on a laissé les marchés se concentrer
et le le vrai problème, c'est la
globalisation. On parle de pour moi
c'est ça le problème, la globalisation
c'estd qu'on a laissé trop se concentrer
des entreprises. Par exemple, dans la
distribution en France, tuas 5 acteurs
aujourd'hui 5 centrales d'achat.
Face à eux, tu as des milliers voir
peut-être quelques millions encore de
cultivateurs et il y a des dizaines de
milliers d'entreprises de PME
agroalimentaire en France. C'estàd que
quand aujourd'hui tu commences à
produire en quantité, tu as pas d'autre
débouché que le supermarché parce qu'
même les petites superettes, ça
appartient à des grands groupes de
supermarchés et même l'épicerie locale
souvent c'est un petit casino, c'est un
petit système U enfin tout est entre les
mains de la grande distribution. Donc si
tu produis des quantités enfin on va
dire industriel même un petit industriel
tu dois passer par la grande
distribution. Mais ils sont quatre ils
sont ils sont cinq aujourd'hui je crois
même qu' ils avaient une une volonté
d'en fusionner deux pour arriver à trois
ou quatre centrales d'achat. Ça veut
dire que si tu arrives à à vendre à ces
gens-là, tu as 4 cents
dont le le plus petit fera au moins 20 %
de ton chiffre d'affaires. Si jamais tu
perds un client, tu peux fermer la
boutique. Donc ces gens-là te tiennent.
Bon, une dernière question, il y a
énormément de questions ce soir. Doit-on
former nos enfants à l'école pour
comprendre comment s'alimenter ?
Oui, mais je crois que c'est fait déjà
un petit peu. Ma femme ma femme est
enseignante, donc je sais qu'elle
qu'elle le fait et que ses collègues
aussi sont
Bon, je vous laisse 2 minutes pour vos
dernières questions. Dépêchez-vous. Euh
on arrive à la fin de notre interview.
On va laisser 2 minutes à notre
communauté pour poser les dernières
questions.
Trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté. Alors, me sors pas acheter
mon livre parce que là, bon,
non, non, mais des livres, bah des
livres à conseiller, il y en a
énormément. Euh des livres à conseiller.
Euh moi, je vais vous donner les livres
que que moi j'ai le plus aimé parmi tous
ceux que j'ai lu. J'en lis beaucoup,
j'en ai toujours deux en deux en deux en
cours, mais ceux que j'ai lis là en ce
moment sont pas forcément les plus les
voilà. Moi, j'ai beaucoup beaucoup aimé.
et j'ai relu plusieurs fois la trilogie
de Jules Valè parce que je trouve ça à
chaque fois que je le relise ça m'émeux,
ça m'intéresse.
Donc donc voilà, en plus moi j'ai habité
quelques temps au pu en vallet donc
c'est un environnement que je connais et
puis j'aime beaucoup l'histoire de ce
personnage, sa construction le c'est une
époque qui m'intéresse. Moi je suis
d'une famille d'ouvriers. Mon grand-père
était ouvrier avec une vraie fierté de
ce que c'était
et euh voilà c'est un univers qui me
parle. Donc c'est des ouvrages qui sont
pas forcément les plus connus. On parle
souvent Balza, Xola et cetera, mais la
trilogie de Jul Vals est vraiment
vraiment sympa. Euh j'ai lu il y a pas
très longtemps les mémoires de De
Gaulle, donc ça reste un peu dans dans
la biographie
et j'ai lu les mémoires de guerre, donc
les trois tomes. J'ai trouvé ça vraiment
génial
parce que ça m'a ouvert les yeux sur la
relation avec nos alliés. Tu vois, on
parle beaucoup de aujourd'hui de les
guerres économiques, les États-Unis, le
machin, l'OTAN et cetera. Et je trouve
que lire les mémoires de De Gaulle, de
savoir comment les alliés se sont
comportés avec lui pendant la guerre est
vraiment instructif.
Donc voilà. Donc donc tu vois, tu m'as
toi je suis un peu fininté parce que tu
m'as dit trois livres mais là ça fait
déjà 6 hein.
Ouais parce qu'il mett et puis un der un
dernier j'ai beaucoup aimé aussi. Alors
c'est un livre que j'ai lu il y a assez
longtemps. C'était les tribulations d'un
précair, je suis tombé dessus mais
vraiment par hasard. C'est un un livre
d'un américain qui s'appelle je crois
d'origine irlandaise Yan Lévison. Je
sais pas si je le dis bien et ça a été
publié à l'époque chez Lévi euh Yana
Lévi, je crois. Et en fait, c'est donc
l'histoire d'un Américain qui après
avoir obtenu son diplôme aux États-Unis
se retrouve à à survivre. En fait, il se
retrouve avec un préétudiant qu'il
arrive pas à rembourser, il arrive pas à
trouver un job, un job stable et il fait
tous les boulots qu'il peut trouver. Et
je trouve que c'est assez
représentatif d'une certaine image de
l'Amérique aujourd'hui.
C'est quoi la marque de ta montre ?
C'est écrit petit. C'est c'est une
marque française
lip.
Non.
Ah
c'est quartier mais bon
bah ça on s'emmerde pas. Vous travailler
dans alimentaire.
C'est un cadeau de mon épouse. Elle
s'est saigné au 80 ma fois.
Mais non mais c'est vrai que dans dans
les industries dans l'industrie on gagne
bien sa vie. Enfin dès qu'on arrive à
certains certains niveaux de
responsabilité.
Question de VAPA. Euh est-ce qualité
dans les cantines ?
Ça dépend des cantines hein. Non, je
pense qu'il y a des cantines qui font
qui font très bien les choses. Quand
vous avez un maire qui est un petit peu
sensibilisé à ça, qui veut faire du bio,
qui veut avoir des produits locaux, qui
veut éventuellement récupérer la cantine
et voilà. Donc à une époque, nous on
habitait dans un petit village et c'est
vrai que la cantine était vraiment
excellente. Donc il y a du mieux et puis
après il y a les cantines industrielles
qui sont confiées à des compagnies de
restauration. Donc là là, il faut pas
espérer avoir une qualité une qualité
extraordinaire. Donc ça dépend vraiment
de qui fait quoi, on trouve de tout.
Alors que pensent-ils des petits
producteurs locaux qui s'associent et
ouvrent leur propre supermarché ?
Première question, j'en j'en balance
plein et puis après tu choisis ce que tu
veux. Est-il possible de nourrir
convenablement 9 milliards d'êtres
humains ? On a déjà répondu à cette
question lors d'une des précédentes
interviews.
Euh que pensent-il des AMAP ? Euh
comment nourrir le monde sans pétrole ?
Bon ça c'est hors sujet.
un film ou un documentaire dans le
domaine à conseiller,
un paris sur l'avenir.
Comment revenir sur un modèle sain ?
Très bonne question.
Ouais, il y a plein de bonnes questions
effectivement. Alors,
sommes-nous dans l'impasse alimentaire ?
alimentairement parlant pardon
il y a pas de bonnes question alors je
vais commencer à y répondre sinon je
vais les oublier
ah bah écoute tout ce qui est déjà vente
direct producteur qui se regroupe et
cetera, tout ça oui c'est très bien ça
permet déjà à ce que au moins les
producteurs puissent probablement mieux
valoriser leurs produit
quel avenir pour la Knaki on a dit pas
de marque
pas pour la saucisse industrielle de
Strasbourg et autres au plasma de port
et autres
joye quoi làdedans
il y a du plasma de port souvent
Bon,
entre autres, il doit y avoir d'autres
d'autres ingrédients.
La qualité de la nourriture des
restaurants universitaires.
Ah, ça, j'en sais trop rien. C'est
pareil. Je pense que ça peut être doit y
avoir du meilleur ou du pire parce que
c'est ça dépend certainement de la
ville, ça dépend du gestionnaire de de
la cantine.
Son avis sur l'appli tout good to go.
Ah, c je le connais pas.
OK. Bon, alors fini les questions les
enfants, désolé. Ah, il y a Voras.
Voras.
Voilà. Non mais bon, la vente directe
c'est très bien. Si on peut aider les
les les producteurs locaux, c'est c'est
super.
Le modèle, alors c'est vrai que la
population continue d'augmenter. C'est
vrai que s'il fallait tout passer en
bio, ce serait probablement compliqué,
mais enfin bon, si on commence pas, on y
arrivera pas. Et puis
et puis euh enfin, il y a probablement
de meilleures solutions pour pour
produire mieux. Et moi, par exemple, je
me rappelle quand j'achè de l'huile,
peut-être une chose que tu sais pas,
mais à ton avis, qu'est-ce qui fait le
prix de l'huile sur
une bouteille de plastique ? Non, non,
mais je veux dire, qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui donne la valeur à l'huile
? Sur quoi sur pourquoi l'huile vaut
aujourd'hui 100 et demain 1000 ?
La demande,
non, c'est le c'est le c'est le pétrole.
C'est le pétrole parce que la majorité
de l'huile passe pas en alimentaire,
elle passe en biocarburant enfin en
diester.
Oui. Donc quand le pétrole augmentail
tout le tintin pareil
euh oui toutes les huiles. Toutes les
huiles l'une ou l'autre elle passe. Donc
en fait quand le pétrole augmente
automatiquement le prix des huiles
augmente puisque à ce moment-là les les
les pétroliers vont incorporer plus de
diester.
C'est ce qui s'est passé aux alentours
de 2008 avec les émeutes de la fin quand
le prix du baril de pétrole était arrivé
à 147.
Exactement. Mais moi je me je me
rappelle, j'ai une anecdote à ce
moment-là, c'est que quand le baril de
pétrole évé à 140 dollars, je me
rappelle c'était euh au début de l'été
et moi j'étais parti en vacances
et euh j'avais laissé les clés de la
boutique à mon patron et j'avais dit à
mon avis 140 dollars, ils vont mie
attendre de laisser passer le truc. Et
pendant que j'étais en vacances, il
avait fait un super gros contrat. Il
m'avait dit mon conseiller en Suisse de
mon gestionnaire de fortune en Suisse
m'avait dit que de toute façon au rythme
on est parti, on sera à 200 dollars
bientôt. Et juste quand je suis rentré,
ça s'est cassé la gueule. et on avait
acheté je sais plus combien on avait des
couvertures dont tu parles à un prix
super élevé et on a perdu je sais pas 3
ou 4 millions d'euros
dans la semaine.
Bon dernière question est-ce que moins
cher veut forcément dire moindre qualité
en agroalimentaire
généralement oui. Je peux pas dire
toujours parce que on peut trouver moins
cher pour d'autres raisons. C'est-à-dire
que bah il peut y avoir un producteur
qui est mieux organisé ou qui est moins
gourmand ou donc voilà. Mais
globalement, oui, la qualité est liée au
prix.
Bon, allez, on avait 10 dernières
questions, mais on va en faire une
dernière. Les industries
agroalimentaires et les industries
pharmaceutiques, même combat,
c'est ça
est-ce que on bouffe mal, ça crée des
maladies, est-ce que les industries
pharmaceutiques derrière sont contents ?
qui m' qui m'amuse parce que parce que
ça c'est pareil, je le suis aussi et euh
et ce qui ce qui me surprend toujours,
c'est que la c'est la solution qu'on
veut apporter au problèmes. Par exemple,
l'obésité, le diabète et cetera.
Les industries pharmaceutiques essayent
de sauver des gens quand même.
Oui, mais c'est ça qui fait qui c'est
marrant, c'est on s'attaque à la à la
comment dire à la cause du problème mais
pas à la racine.
Il suffirait que la bouffe industrielle
soit moins nocive et on aurait pas
besoin de se soigner. Par exemple, moins
d'additifs. Alors, on a des catégories
complètes d'additifs qui servent à rien.
Les colorants par exemple, pourquoi du
colorant ? En quoi ça
provoquer l'acte d'achat ?
Oui, mais je veux dire, c'est du
commercial, c'est pas du ça améliore pas
la qualité du produit. Toi le
consommateur, OK, tu veux que ton
produit soit bien rouge, bien blanc et
cetera, mais au niveau qualité, ça
n'apporte rien, au contraire. Donc les
colors servent à rien. Euh les ex de
goût, glutamat et autres, ça sert
strictement à rien aussi. Les sucres
artificiels, les les comment les
édulclorants intenses, on sait que c'est
nocif, ça rapporte rien rien de bon. On
devrait les supprimer tous ces produits
là. Si déjà on avait plus ces
produits-là, on aurait quand même
beaucoup moins de problèmes. Euh,
on sait aussi qu'une partie du diabète
de type 2, elle est elle est lié à
l'utilisation de fructose. Et ça parce
qu'on a vu, il y avait une corrélation
entre aux États-Unis, entre la
consommation de fructose et le diabète
de type 2. Donc on sait, il suffirait
par exemple de limiter la consommation
de fructose. Alors, ce qui est drôle,
c'est que les industriels de la
pharmacie aujourd'hui arrivent avec tout
un tas de produits, de molécules et
cetera censé vous guérir alors qu'en
fait, ça fait que traiter les symptômes.
Donc même combat, oui, quelque part.
Bon, allez, dernière. Comment se porte
sa conscience d'avoir vendu de la merde
pour de l'argent ?
Mais non, c'est pas ça. C'est pas une
bonne question ça.
C'est la question de Nick Sam.
C'est pas plutôt on fait des blagues.
C'est pas Jean-Jacques. Non non non mais
nique sa mère. Voilà ça il faut
prononcer plus rapidement.
Ouais mais comme je te disais au début
c'est pas du tout pour de l'argent.
c'est on fait on fait un travail et on a
l'impression de de servir son
entreprise. On a l'impression de de bien
travailler quand on fait ce genre de
choses parce que on est dans un système
quoi. Donc il y a pas de mais la plupart
de mes collègues encore aujourd'hui la
plupart n'ont pas mauvaise conscience.
Ils vont me dire "Bon Christophe, oui tu
comprends ? Ouais ok une fois ou deux on
a fait du des lot pourri parce que on
avait pas le choix par exemple.
C'est pas tout le temps pourri quand
même.
C'est pas tout le temps pourri." Voilà
c'est ce qu'il vont dire. V dire "Ouais
c'est exceptionnel tu comprends ?
exceptionnel, ça se discute encore, mais
c'est pas dangereux, tu vois. Il y a pas
eu personne a été blessé par ce truclà.
Les additifs, tout ça, c'est encadré,
c'est donc il y a personne qui a
mauvaise conscience et moi, j'ai quand
même évolué par rapport au début, mais
ça n'a rien rien à voir du tout par
rapport à l'argent et je suis content
d'arrivoir évoluer parce qu'il y a un
moment quand même, je me suis dit bon,
je consomme plus ces produits là, je
veux pas les donner à manger à mes
enfants, il y a quand même un problème.
Et puis ces problèmes de de santé et de
maladie au tout début, on en parlait pas
il y a 25 ans, c'était pas d'actualité.
il y avait pas encore de l'obésité, les
diabètes et cetera, les allergies, enfin
tous ces problèmes là. C'est c'est venu
petit à petit, le sel, le gras, enfin,
il y a eu toutes ces modesl qui sont qui
sont donc
c'est pas un problème de conscience,
c'est un problème d'évolution et de
maturité.
Et et quelque part, oui, un problème de
loyauté par rapport à l'entreprise. Ma
loyauté allait à mon patron, à mon
entreprise avant d'aller à des à des
consommateurs qui pour moi étaient
lointain et même n'existaient pas parce
que notre client c'était même pas les
consommateurs, c'est le supermarché avec
lequ on se bagarre. Tu vois, il y a une
relation d'amour haine entre industriel
et supermarché.
On fabrique pour les supermarchés leurs
produits à leur marque. Donc on a ils
ont besoin de nous pour les fabriquer.
On a besoin d'eux pour vendre ces
produits là plus vendre nos produits à
notre marque. On se bagarre pour la
marge puisqueen fait c'est pour ça en
fait on parle de baisse des prix et mais
c'est ce que ce que le supermarché
arrive à récupérer c'est ce que
l'industriel pourra pas garder. Donc en
fait il y a une bagarre entre les deux
pour garder la marge. Et moi dans cette
guerre j'étais du côté de de moi de ma
société contre le supermarché et contre
mes concurrents.
Donc psychologiquement, c'est
intéressant, mais
il y a pas de volonté de nuire, il y a
pas de volonté de s'enrichir. On était
pas mieux payé que dans n'importe quel
autre industrie.
Donc il y a pas de volonté de faire du
mal, de volonté d'empoisonner ou autre,
mais il y a une loyauté à un système et
c'est le système dans son ensemble qui
serait à revoir.
Et donc, je suis désolé, je vais être
obligé de poser encore des questions. On
fait comment pour changer le système ?
que ceux qu'ont le pouvoir, le vrai
pouvoir, c'est les politiques.
C'est c'est vraiment c'est une question
politique. Le il y a il y a il y a il y
avait un excellent rapport, il y avait
je crois que le gars s'appelait Chris
Elliot, un anglais qui avait fait un
excellent rapport avec des propositions
pour arrêter donc c'est un anglais qui
avait fait des propositions en
Angleterre pour arrêter les les fraudes.
Mais les positions sont super simples.
Sanction
six entreprises en carrière six fois
loyal.
Loyal à quoi À mon entreprise ? Loyal à
Ouais, c'est ça.
Oui, à mon entreprise. Oui, c'est
précise que tu es devenu loyal avec les
consommateurs. Bah, c'est quand vraiment
j'en pouvais plus, que je suis parti à
l'étranger et même s'il y a pas eu cette
affaire de lasagne au cheval, j'en
aurais pas parlé. Oui, j'ai je me
considère comme loyal aux gens qui qui
me payaient à mes collègues. À mes
collègues. Je veux pas je veux pas créer
de tort à mes à mes collègues.
Enfin, moi j'ai eu des situations par
exemple où mon boss m'a appelé en disant
"Christophe, on narrive pas à payer les
salaires ce mois-ci. Est-ce que tu veux
pas nous faire un coup de négoce ? On a
besoin c'est quoi un coup de négoce ?
Un coup de négoce, c'est-à-dire que si
tu veux de l'argent du cash rapidement,
tu peux pas attendre de livrer un
supermarché qui te paye à 60 jours et
cetera. Donc il faut de l'argent de
suite. Il faut que le mec te fasse un
virement tout de suite. Et le seul moyen
d'avoir de l'argent de suite cache,
c'est de faire du négoci un coup de
trading. Je te vends brader, je sais pas
moi, 50 tonnes de champignons, 100
tonnes de je sais pas trop quoi. Il y en
a pour ou je sais pas enfin n'importe
quel produit qu'on peut avoir à ce
moment-là. et je te dis ben je te fais
ce prix là par contre tu me payes dans
la semaine. Voilà, ça ça m'est arrivé
par exemple c'était pas rare, le mec
m'appelle en catastrophe. On narrive pas
à faire les salaires ce mois-ci. Il me
faut 80000 €. Trouve-moi ça, trouve-moi
80000 €. Tu tu me vends ce que tu veux.
Voilà, tu me le vends brader. C'est pas
une question de marge. Il nous il nous
faut du fric ce mois-ci. On est sec.
Donc tu vois ce genre de situation ça
marque euh
une petite un truc une petite parenthèse
juste pour que tu comprennes ça pas
prendre longtemps mais la première fois
que je suis allé en Chine j'étais
embauché depuis 3 semaines par une boîte
et ils me disent voilà dans 3 semaines
tu en Chine j'avais 25 ans, je démarrais
aucune expérience rien du tout je
sortais de l'école donc autrement dit je
savais rien faire on dit dans 3 semaines
tu pars en Chine tu vas inspecter des
containers tr containers à inspecter
paiement s fait par l'aide de crédit et
tu vas avec les documents. Donc l'aide
de crédit en fait c'est c'est une
garantie pour le fournisseur. Il reçoit
son fric contre des documents. D'accord
? Donc je devais aller en Chine, lui
donner ses documents pour qu'il se fasse
payer et en échange, moi je devais
regarder les containers et les sceller.
Je vais en Chine, pof, j'arrive. Bon, je
te la fait courte mais en gros le mec me
balade une journée donc j'arrive à Hong
Kong, il me balade en bagnole et cetera
en voix fin de la Chine, je
des filles un peu. Non,
j'y viens. Et et donc le gars me dit
voilà donne-moi les documents et je te
montre la marchandise.
Moi j'avais 25 ans, je me dis [__] ça
se trouve en Chine, c'est pas pareil
qu'en Europe. Ici c'est de la politesse.
Enfin, tu vois, j'étais vraiment
vraiment naïf à cette époque hein. Moi,
j'avais jamais sorti du territoire.
J'ai vraiment aucune aucune malice quoi.
Finalement le soir se passe, je
téléphone à mon enfin à ma société, je
dis mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Ils
ont ils ont pas de marchandise, ils me
disent "Non, tu donnes pas les
documents, tu j'insiste, je vais voir la
marchandise et cetera et cetera. On va
manger ensemble le milit très bien. Le
soir, on va remanger. Quand on va manger
avec des fournisseurs chinois, c'est une
table, on est on est 25 quoi. On est 10
quoi. Il y a plein de gens que tu
connais pas, des gens de la production,
des machins commerciaux, enfin bref, il
y a plein de monde. Super sympa comme
ambiance. On mange avec une table avec
un truc qui tourne au milieu tout à Donc
le soir on mange on picole machin puis
je me dis [__] quand même il commence
à faire nuit je dis à ma march
t'inquiète pas ta marchandise je bon bah
ok on fera le contrôle de la nuit c'est
pas grave c'est sûrement comme ça qu'ils
font ici.
Et puis euh un moment on p campay c'est
cc là cuc cc cu sec et puis moi à la fin
je commencé à dire oh là faut que
j'arrête de boire parce que sinon ça ira
pas. J'ai non maintenant il faut qu'on y
aille. Le mec me dit "T'inquiète pas la
marchandise on ira l'inspecter demain
matin. Elle est pas encore arrivée. On a
un cadeau pour toi. Un cadeau pour moi.
C'est vachement sympa. Vous êtes gens
les chinois." Et là il me il me dit il
me montre et puis il y avait deux jeunes
filles. Puis j' bien vu queil en fallait
au moins deux satisfaire. Bref.
Alors tu as croqué ou tu as pas croqué ?
Et en fait
ce clignement d'œil
ça m'a fait Non mais à ce moment-là ça
m'a fait comme une douche froide d'un
coup tu vois. C'estàd que mais je me
suis dit mais quel gros con. Enfin de
moi, je me suis dit mais comment c'est
possible que j'ai pu être aussi idiot et
naïf quoi ? Comment j'ai pu enfin suivre
ces gens-là, me faire manipuler toute la
journée pour au final que les mecs ils
essaient de m'acheter ?
Donc je me suis levé, j'ai dit écoute
maintenant ça va, tu me ramènes à parce
qu'on était on était on avait Hong Kong,
Chenzen, on était parti en bagnole donc
je sais même pas dans quelle ville on
était. J'ai dit "Maintenant, tu me
ramènes à Hong Kong." Mais il dit "Bah
si tu veux rentrer tu te démerdes."
J'étais bourré.
Je parlais pas un mot chinois. Je dis
bon bah écoute c'est bon, je me casse.
Je sors dans la rue, je marche plus
d'arrêter des bagnoles et je leur diszen
machin. B il y a un mec qui s'arrête, il
me prend, je monte dans la bagnole et je
me dis c'est bon ma carrière est finie,
j'ai pas trouvé ma marchandise,
je suis je sais pas où.
Le mec, il va me demander je sais pas
combien. Je sais même pas, j'avais dans
ma poche, j'avais des dollars, j'avais
je sais plus des francs, j'avais des
travel check. On avait ça à l'époque,
travel check. Je dis bon, c'est bon. Je
dis [__] c'est bon, ma carrière elle
a commencé, elle est déjà finie.
Et et en Chine, à cette époque-là, il y
avait encore des frontières à
l'intérieur, tu sais, il y avait des
zones économiques spéciales. Donc, on
passe machin, on arrive à la première
frontière, mec, il s'excite, il
qu'est-ce qu'il veut ? Qu'est-ce qu'il
veut ? En fait, il voulait mes papiers,
je filme mes papiers. Paf, finalement,
on arrive à Shenzen.
Je savais pas comment il fallait filer.
Alors, je salias de de Yan. J'avais je
don un billet, deux billets, trois
billets quatre billets enfin autant de
billets jusqu'à ce que le mec il
paraisse content. Je sais pas du tout
comment je lui ai filé. J'ai jamais su
comment je lui ai filé. Bon, une fois
que le mec était content, il est parti
et je suis rentré et j'ai passé après
une semaine là-bas à trouver ma
marchandise chez quelqu'un d'autre.
Donc, j'ai j'ai quand même réussi à
rattraper le coup sur place avec
d'autres personnes.
Et tout ça pour te dire que
cette loyauté, c'est pas quelque chose
de fin, c'est quelque chose de
de de réel par rapport à cette sociétél.
Et juste pour finir par rapport à ça,
quelques temps après, donc un autre
fournisseur de Hong Kong, je fais enfin
on fait un tour en Chine pour inspecter
des fournisseurs. Pas à la fin du
voyage, le mec me dit, enfin la femme me
dit c'était une femme, une
intermédiaire, une chinoise, elle me dit
tiens, on a vachement bien travaillé
ensemble, paf, je te remercie. Et elle
me file une enveloppe. Al je dis
qu'est-ce que c'est ça ? Alors je
regarde, j'ouvre puis c'était plein de
billets. Il y a une li de billet. Je dis
merde. Alors je dis ben non, tu on s'est
mal compris, ça m'intéresse pas. Je lui
rends sa li de billet.
Et c'était pas très longtemps après la
première, peut-être 6 mois après ou un
an après, je sais pas. Donc j'étais pas
encore du tout dans le moode de pour moi
ça je comprenais pas que ce gen de truc
puisse exister et et je dis non non
c'est pas possible. Elle me dit je suis
confuse, je suis confuse. Non écoute on
s'est mal compris. Elle me dit mais
pourtant ton prédécesseur
on faisait comme ça. Je dis bah écoute
peut-être mais avec moi non. Donc voilà
euh je rentre en France, je vais voir
mon patron. Je dis [__] quand même tu
sais pas ce qui s'est passé. Notre
fournisseur avec qui on fait le le plus
de business, on faisait je sais pas
combien de millions de millions de
dollars avec elle. On sait peut-être 10
millions de dollars avec elle par an.
Enfin, pas rien. Je dis voilà ce qui
s'est passé et il me dit "Ouais, super,
tu as bien réagi et cetera." Bon bref et
euh
et au bout de quelques temps, j'ai eu
plus besoin de refuser puisque j'ai eu
une réputation comme quoi j'étais pas
achetable. Et de ma carrière pendant 20
ans, on a dû me proposer des paiements
peut-être deux fois.
Mais en contrepartie, à chaque fois que
j'ai voulu quitter une société, ça s'est
fait sur un coup de téléphone voir on
est venu me chercher. Et une fois, je me
rappelle, j'avais un ancien employeur
qui m'appelle, il me dit "Christa, je
cherche à embaucher quelqu'un pour un
boss machin et cetera. Est-ce que tu as
pas quelqu'un à me conseiller ?" B je
dis "Bah écoute, là où je travaillais
avant, bah j'ai été remplacé par un tel,
ça fait 2 3 ans qu'il y est, je pense
qu' peut-être il aura envie de changer."
Il m'a dit "Ah non, j'ai eu des échos."
Je dis "Bon bah OK."
Donc
tu vois cette loyauté c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est pas 20 et une
réputation c'est aussi un capital.
J'ai pu faire la carrière que j'ai fait
aussi grâce à ça. Et une petite anecdote
pour te juste pour te faire marrer parce
que
on va faire vite. Alors
bon juste juste le mec à qui mon ancien
patron de la boîte où j'ai raconté que
la chinoise m'avait filé une enveloppe,
la raison pour laquelle je suis parti
c'est que j'ai découvert quasiment 3 ans
après que ce mec recevait de l'argent
d'un fournisseur serbe.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Et ben, il faut il faut il faut il faut
se battre. Il faut
il faut il faut pas il faut pas regarder
les médias mainstream et puis se laisser
endormir. Il faut voilà. Euh c'est quoi
? C'est bah c'est Einstein qui disait
"Le monde est dangereux à vivre pas par
pas par ceux qui font le mal mais par
ceux qui le regardent sans rien faire.
Donc il faut il faut faire quelque
chose. Il faut il faut méditer il faut
voilà. Donc peut-être une question que
tu as eu tout à l'heure qui disait
"Qu'est-ce que je fais moi aujourd'hui
?" Bah j'ai écrit ces bouquins pour un
petit peu alerter. Euh je soutiens des
associations comme Foodwatch. Donc
voilà, je les aide, j'en parle, je leur
fais de la promo. Je dis aux gens
adhérrez chez Food Watch parce que c'est
des gens bien qui se qui se battent pour
vous. Ils sont pas ils reçoivent de
l'argent deux personnes si ce n'est des
adhérents. Je suis aussi adhérant chez
anticorps par exemple. Donc voilà, il
faut soutenir des gens comme ça parce
que si vous-même vous pouvez pas, vous
savez pas, ben adhérer à des à des
associations de gens qui font les choses
pour vous. Euh c'est un minimum. Et puis
bah renseignez-vous, discutez, allez sur
internet, regardez Syerview et d'autres
quoi. Voilà.
Christophe Bruset. Merci. Merci à vous.
[Musique]